That doesn't necessarily make it okay. You should respect if
somebody's like not wanting to be close to you physically. You
should probably respect that. Even if you don't think it's like
something you shouldn't I don't know, right? A 30-year-old guy
with a 19-year-old girl and he's like slipping her alcohol and
then they after or she wants to
>> You gave me your ID for alcohol.
>> No. Uh-oh. I This is crazy cuz I think Zena would be
100%. I've seen Zena show some bluffs that are like absolutely
out of this world where she like she says she has proof of something
and it's like not even close to the proof of the thing she says.
Zena saying look you say like I was the person who did this.
You had no part in this but here you are coaching me to get Darius
in even more >> First of all actually where the other phone
why did you buy the strap on? >> The fact that you have
to resort to trying to make up slander things.
Why did you buy the strap on why did you buy the strap on? Like
you're talking me instead of answering the question because you
know why did you buy the strap on?
Wait, who's leaking what? So, Shui and Zena were breaking up
and then I believe they started making like escalating accusations
about each other, right? So, they started making escalating accusations
about each other and I believe this got into like assault
pegging like a lot of things that ended up coming out about this.
Okay, so >> you didn't go if she didn't go to court. You
said you wouldn't with her is what she's saying. >> No,
let's see. So, he's looking at some in the Discord first. Oh,
it starts with this. He's leaking this. One second. Just tell
me why you justify hiding my wallet so I can't leave. Because
I'm selfish and afraid to lose you and thought it was smart to
hide your ID because I didn't want you to stay in a hotel and
not be with me. Not any other
Wow. Wow. Did I just see some insane some insane Zena Riz? Let's
go. Oh, wait. This is Would this be would this be Shuy himself?
Hold on. This is this is from Zena's phone. So Gray would be
Shuy, right? Shuy and me overlap a lot. >> I don't really
care. I have nothing to >> Dean, should we just become
best >> There's nothing she can use against me. Um,
I love you so much. All right. Anything else that she leaked?
Uh,
uh, I remember I seen something.
She said,
where was he? >> Okay, I need to use the I need to get
a drink, use the bathroom really quick. So, I'm going to let
Chubie cook for two
>> Do not do not
judge me for the dead air that's about to follow. I have a feeling
that this guy's going to like actually sort of zone out. Like
his chip's going to reset and he'll just zone out for like 30
seconds and stare off in his >> Stuff happened because
of him pushing it. So basically what she's trying to say is that
she the only reason that she got a restraining order
or like press charges or anything. It's cuz of me.
I said this is your decision to make it care. But obviously she's
gonna try to paint a baddest picture that she can
and I knew that she would do that when I'm gone.
But let me just show y'all something since she wants to leak.
Um, let me see. Let me go full screen. >> This is a picture
of us in a hotel room. This is a picture. Wait, what? >> Dude,
I just screamed back to my computer. This is a picture of us
in a hotel room. I'm like, "No,
I'm on Twitch. Shy, don't do it."
Sorry. Wait, what was it? What was it? >> A picture. >> It
was like a picture of us in a hotel >> Is this pause? >> Let
me go full screen. >> This is a picture
of us in a hotel. >> Okay. There's nothing going on there.
Thank god. Thank god I was >> This is a picture. Wait,
what? >> Okay. All right. >> How do I do this? >> No,
it's just them. They're doing drugs in a hotel room. Dude, this
guy is the worst. This >> Dude, I don't know how to film
this. All >> dude. Dude, what the is he doing? >> All right.
Basically, she's holding a cup with all her pills that are in
a
>> saying um saying that saying that she's going to eat
them all and kill herself when I said that I was going to leave
her. That's what that is. >> So, uh you know, every time
I try to leave her, which was multiple times, she wanted to uh
go and uh
um post it in Discord. Oh, okay. Yeah, that's a good idea. a
very xenicoded thing to do apparently. I don't know. I feel like
if
you stick with somebody on that I feel like you don't use it
for content later, you know. I I never like people using that
aren't that clear, but I mean obviously I mean you could believe
me if you want or not. >> Feels bizarre. >> They're
sending I'm on trash. I won't regret leaking the message simply
cuz he's leaking stuff on me and publicly talking about the relationship
and the end, etc. I didn't say anything. I looked at bad cuz
it showed that he feeling I have at least he claimed. >> Dude,
this guy is >> what is happening? >> Okay, I can't
dream. But anyways, >> okay. I just wanted to share my
side and uh my side and that I was thinking with feelings and
being shown the same in return. Never meant to hurt any never
meant to hurt him. I didn't groom anyone. When we first hooked
up, I told him it was a fling because of the age and he convinced
me otherwise. Then he ended up agreeing she might cause issues.
Then he wanted to leave when he was harassed by my past, etc.
And I freaked out and I ran in the bathroom and hurt myself.
I felt like I wasted my time letting someone in my heart again.
Ever since we tried working out and a lot of it was him trying
to make it work. I wasn't alone. Maybe it wasn't real feelings
all along. He's young and probably just was in the motions.
Rough. >> Uh when we first hook up, I told him it was a
fling because of his age and he convinced me otherwise. Hold
on. >> Hold on. Okay, I'm going to Sorry, guys. I do have
to end on Twitch. I just don't trust that it's like it's like
going to be Zenosu breakup drama. I It's going to break the Twitch
to at some point, right? Eventually the Twitch stuff's going
to get up. Okay. It's going to be It's going to be messed up.
So, I love you on Twitch. We're going to head over to kick kick.com/jdk.
Head over there. Okay. All right. All right. We'll see you over
there, guys. Okay. We're going to end the the Twitch stream.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Also, guys, consider this the first shill of
the stream. Guys, if you like the content, go ahead and follow
on every platform. Follow on Twitch, follow on kick, follow on
Twitter, x.com/jsdk
with an underscore, join the Discord,
If you like the content, you want it to keep flowing. You can
donate to the stream. You can add more time. Couple ways you
can do that. You can TTS through either Streamlabs or Kickbot.
You can you can give subs. You can buy subs through Kick or Twitch.
You can
actually those are all the ways. Anyway, you can give subs kick.
Do give subs kick if you want to cuz it's a 95 vlade is way better
than Twitch. I think Twitch is 60/40. So, if you give subs on
kick, it goes to it goes way further for me in my pocket. Okay.
Uh we are
I believe,
10 subs away from two more hours on the stream. 10 subs away.
Two more hours. So, get your money in, guys. Right now. Last
but not least, there's the Patreon.
There's multiple tiers. Go ahead, sign up. Even the $5 tier is
nice. Go sign up for the free tier. patreon.com/jdlk.
It's separate. It comes with the Discord perks. Okay. soundboards
and the VCs, extra content, extra roll permissions um to do stuff,
especially when we shut down general chat before the stream.
All right, so go get on there and we'll we'll see everybody on
there. Okay, Patreon. I'm trying to load it. It's literally won't
load. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Why would it go? Why would it go? Why would it go?
I don't know why you waste time on Twitch anyway. I waste time
on Twitch cuz I like having, you know, the audience there. Gives
people a chance to move over. They like the content. beat.
>> Elmo 7662, thank you for the two gifted subs. Thank
you. Thank you. Let's go.
>> Really appreciate it. Really appreciate
>> All right, continue on. Shuy drama. Let's go. >> My
wife. How could I have respect? How? But wants to be my wife
of my kids.
>> Is he talking about like with her doing Only Fans or
something like this?
>> That's goofy. There's >> he like unaware of the
content she did >> other stuff.
No, no, no. I'm not going to say I'm not going to leak anything
else unless she wants to. But I don't think she's going to do
that because there's nothing she can do. There's nothing she
can leak all >> me POV or me and you know that there's
like eight more hours of content to go after this. He just said
that. I don't think she could. Listen, she could leak more, but
I don't think she's going to do that.
Moments before disaster. Okay. words spoken directly before disaster
strikes. Well, she could leak more, but I don't think she's going
to do that. And here's why, guys. >> All her screenshots
is just me saying I love you. So what? I don't give a [__]
>> That's so disingenuous,
by the way. It just feels like weird and gross to me in a general
sense to tell somebody you love them and then be like, "What?
She going to be the wife of my kids?" Why are you telling somebody
you love them if you if you're just like them? Why would you
do that? That's so weird. That's such a weird thing to do. >> Pretend
that not be in a relationship. I wasn't in a Well, it was just
a friend
>> It Okay. Okay, bro. Okay, bro. It's just a friend relationship.
A friend relationship, guys. Yo, thank you for the five. It's
not weird for a 19-year-old. Okay. It's weird to after those
messages get leaked to go, "Guys, it wasn't really a relationship,
guys. It wasn't a relationship." I understand if you're young,
you might fall in love at the drop of a hat. That's fine. I'm
not mocking you for that. I'm mocking you for after the fact
going, "I wasn't in a relation. I wasn't in love with that person."
Nick or nasty
>> I loose about you. >> Zena going to put you in
jail. Congratulations on catching a new case. She can't put me
in jail. Things about
>> guys. I didn't do anything. She can't put me in jail.
>> She She can't put me in jail, guys. Sorry, you're not
going to see this all that. Well, he tried to me after Hunger
Games. I said no. I'll post the pic of him cuddling me a year
ago. I said no. We called a lot and talked a lot. We talked about
before I came to the beach house. So yeah, we day two because
we already knew each other. Oh, never mind. We day two because
we already knew each other. I see. I see. For a second, I thought
that was going to be something different.
How old is she? How old is Zena? 29
or something.
>> 29. 30. >> Dude, this guy's connection. This is
going to kill me. This is going to kill me. This is going to
kill my segment. This Jesus Christ. >> Yeah, we read this.
Okay, dude. This guy wor streamer.
>> She said I was smooth. Like what? And we were not flirting.
I never flirted, bro. The only thing that was said was
her being cringe on the call when I was talking to her on the
boat before she came out.
And she was like, I was like, >> did somebody throw me
logs? Maybe I got logs and content or something. >> You
want me to come Shuy? You want me to come? And I'm just like
cuz that was just pathetic. RZ. This is why girls cannot try.
>> But I never I never flirted. >> Okay, dude. >> But
actually, no, I guess I did. One day before she came to the beach
house, she randomly texted me, "How big is your D
or how big is your D?" And then she and then I sent question
marks and then she unent it and said, "Never mind." And I said,
"Nah, you're funny.
Find out." And then she did find out. But anyways, I I don't
know. I mean, >> wait, where are the logs in research here?
I'm looking right now. Sorry, Funky Boss. I'm looking. I'm just
trying to figure out if we got anyone who's looking any deeper
into this at all.
me sleeping on her leg in the Uber. Like, wow.
>> So, I'm looking in the background to try to get stuff
uh caught up as well. >> Why am I fighting with her? I'm
>> I'm like I'm so close to breaking down right now. I'm
going on to
>> I don't know. Yo, get this ho,
bro.
>> Ain't nobody want to your old ass either, bro. The
Show some mercy to Merc. What the >> Why would I go from
one Why would I make a mistake and go straight to another one?
Okay, I his stream is so that I can't even just read logs. I'm
just sad I let him convince me that age wasn't an issue, lol.
And then when he had an issue about it, we could work it out.
I I should have kept my original mental state about it and not
let it get to this. I fell deeply in love. Lol. I'm a fool. We
all know this.
Damn. >> Yo, am I still lagging?
>> Kid is wise. No, he's not. No, he's not. What do you
mean he's wise? He's in this. No, he's not wise. I'm not going
to judge him, but don't say he's wise. He's literally just playing
to his chat. Obviously, when he's off when he's off stream, not
with his chat, he doesn't think this way. He's just playing to
his tra his chat. That's all he's doing >> Picture, you
mutant,
bro. I'm getting emped, bro. I'm getting targeted. I I don't
want to. >> Okay. I mean, he me good every day like eight
times a day. Is very big and stuff. I hope I wasn't recorded
cuz I didn't ever do that to him. I heard something about some
recording happening here. Some weird going on. Illegally recorded.
Illegally recorded, huh? >> Oh, I did hear it went the
other way that like Cena had recorded something.
>> But I We'll see. >> Well, it's not illegal if
you're committing a crime. So >> that's kind of true.
I can't imagine there's a crime you're committing during like
but so but yes if you're if you're recording somebody in a like
I think the one of the exemptions to the wiretapping law is if
you're recording somebody in the commission of a crime or using
it to like get a confession or something then it's okay >> right
now it's like how the cops get around it
>> you leveled up >> good job playing dump that you
win >> hold on let me wait all right listen
>> bro are you going to move from the door and let me leave
or no
>> I just stopped the recording cuz she was coming to see
if I was recording. >> Oh, what state are they in? Are
they in Texas? I hope they're in Texas. I think they're in Austin,
right? They're in Austin. That is legal. If they're in Florida,
that is not legal. Oh, boy. Texas. Okay.
Uh, Texas is Texas is single party
>> I'm being so immature. No, I'm not. >> I'm immature.
He >> Somebody asked who this guy's audience is. I have
no idea. >> He's getting better, bro. Oh, shut up. >> Delete
my Only fans cuz he didn't trust
>> Look, it's Creger. I see him. I see him >> He
said he would pay me. And what? What?
What? No. No. Y'all photoshopped this, right? Wait. Wait. This
is >> I feel like if I had to bet right off of that reaction
and off of what Zena said, I feel like I think Zena is right.
I feel like Zena He probably did say this. I would bet.
>> He said he would pay me instead and take care of my
bills. Wait, wait, chat. Tell me this is Photoshop. You guys
are trolling. No, she's trolling. She's trolling. Oh god, she's
trolling.
No. No. Wait. Can someone actually confirm if that's real? No.
But
Wait. Wait. Can someone tell me if Tell me if that's a real screenshot.
>> how much he said I'm the best girl ever. We made stuff.
>> You never love me. everything he said about me being
the >> me and wanting to be with me and how much he said
I was the best girl ever. We made tapes and stuff too, but I
doubt I doubt that he would ever leak that >> Tapes and
safe. Wait, what? We made tapes and stuff, too. But I doubt he
would ever leak that. Why would I commit a crime? I don't >> What
kind of viewer is this viewership is the Slender Boy pulling?
I think he gets like a,000 to 2,000 concurrent
Chad, the other day she asked to use my for her only fans
and she said nobody would know that it's me.
>> All right, dude. I was going to say if that was real,
bro. Like >> what a cooked way of communicating,
she's like watching his stream and responding in her Discord
so people could screenshot in her Discord and send it to him.
Cool.
That's always cool. Oh, apparently um apparently Zena might have
been streaming during this and she changed her title here to
like oh, she's doing like a romantic date with Dan or something.
Apparently this triggered Chuy a little bit too. I'm hearing
that
a total Zena S. So listen, I don't know that that's true for
sure. I'm just giving you guys this information and and attaching
the modifier that a complete Zena Simp. Okay, so possibly possibly
>> What is this? All right, I'm just waiting for more information.
Apparently that that title was from before the breakup. Might
have led to them breaking >> from happening. >> Dude,
I don't want to get >> uh I'll go back on trouble with
legal stuff, etc. He Why would I call Ice? >> Yeah, it
was all for content. Clearly, he won't even admit to all the
things he said in my ears, his feelings, etc. He can't be real
with himself. It's okay. This had to happen. I'll remove him
from the order like he said. It's okay to do so. I don't get
in trouble with legal stuff since he isn't with me anymore. And
I don't want him in any trouble either or stopping the Aiden
stuff from happening. I don't want to get more hate for stopping
content. >> It's time to lift the restraining order on
Dus and make amends. Make content >> I don't have a restraining
order on him. Yeah, she's trying to play Vlickum. >> Play
Vlum stuff seems very immature. I know, but everybody wants to
watch it. >> All the things he said in my ear. He can't
be real with himself. >> It is what it is. >> She's
just projecting. She's trying to say I'm delusional right now.
What? >> Sorry. We got to pull it back just a little bit.
If you leaked it, it would be revenge. Why the would I leak that?
I love him anyways and don't need that [__] I can
use it for my own self-pleasure. The cast of his is here still.
We tried to mold it. I have it right now. What the did I say?
What did I say, chat? She's going to use the video to >> cuz
she's weird. But I honestly still don't believe
>> Why would it be believe she even has the video? I really
do not believe that. >> I need I need I need Zena live
somewhere talking about this. Okay, I don't need any more Shuy.
Shuy, I don't understand how this guy's streaming right now.
I need I need Zena to go live and talk about this because holy,
>> she let me record.
Uh, no. She let me record
every single time whenever I wanted. >> Yo, she's
actually weird. >> All I have to do is put silicone in
it. Haha. Is this is this like one of those home kits? You like
mold it to the You make a out of it. Is that Is that what she's
doing right now? >> She pulled this out of the trash, bro.
Wait. Wait. If not, it's >> Yeah. Yeah. I know she's on
detal. >> I'm just saying she was going through. >> You
still watched her on her own vans live next to her. Darius tried
to warn you. You were too young to be Zena. Darius was right.
>> Darius was right. >> Weird. She's really going
to She really pulled this out of the trash, bro. >> How
How do you go Darius was right when Darius like humiliated himself
like trying to chase her down at at the Kickon thing? How do
you go Darius is right there? I don't, man. But okay. All right.
Maybe. Maybe >> she pulled this out of the trash.
>> Which is kind,
Hold on. Let me let me do some other investigations here. I'll
try to I'll try to clear this up a little bit.
Eclipse last
week, I guess. DBR exposing Zena's lies. DBR call. So, there's
a call with DBR coming up in just a second. 49 minutes.
We're actually right there.
So, DBR call is about to be coming up. Oh
1280x720
maybe. >> Okay. All right. It's coming up. >> Am
I still effing? >> Dude, bro, >> I can't see. >> So
DBR is the person who brings the first big bomb of this stream
that I've been waiting for expecting. Okay. >> I send it
to you on Discord.
>> It's uh Zena says to this DBR guy, "He made me get the
order on Darius, bro. He told me he'd leave me if I didn't. This
is so unfair. I didn't want to. No way. Because I wanted there
to be peace one day. I didn't want to ruin his life,
I don't believe this. I don't believe this. And also, if that's
true, I don't think it changes anything. So, but I I don't even
believe it. Come on. >> Um, he made me get an order on
Darius, bro. He told me he'd leave me if I didn't. This is so
true. >> I just didn't want to say it. >> All right.
So, chat, what did I say? She said she's going to try to make
it my fault cuz I already saw this coming before I even left
her cuz she kept trying to >> I just I totally forgot as
well that I'm not sitting in a channel that Tree can join right
now. Me,
I'm like not sitting in Discord. Hold on. I don't know if Tree
would count this as Darius content, but I better go join a channel
that she could join just in case. You know, >> weirdly
think that it >> I would I would I would hate if Tree Could
you imagine how annoyed I'd be if I cover this by myself and
I find out Tree could have been here the whole time? That'd be
a >> uh you know, she's just easy to read. So, I mean,
this was predictable. >> But that's a crazy thing. That's
a crazy thing to make up. Like, like, are you saying that she
made up? >> I said she has a decision to make. I mean,
do you think I made her uh call the cops uh after she talked
to Sam Pepper? Like, no. I don't I'm not the one that does this.
Do you think I wasn't even there when she reported that he took
a picture of her and she got him arrested? So, I don't know what
this is supposed to mean. >> Mhm.
Bro, I I don't know, bro. I don't know how people think this
a script.
>> So, how long until Darius and Zen are back together?
>> I don't know, bro. But yeah, I I I don't know, bro.
It's just crazy. I don't know anything. She just messaged me
again as why he admitted it to Kimmy. >> What I said to
Kimmy was that Zena has a decision to make through >> really.
We're going to cut out right
>> So, I don't know what the he's trying to
I don't know why he
tells just parts.
He wants to tell instead of just being completely honest. All
right. >> I know. >> I'm going to kill myself. I'm
going to kill myself. I'm going to kill myself. Oh my god.
>> She literally says, >> "I'm glad I got the order
because I'm finally free. I don't regret it. I don't care if
people are mad that I got rid of the my ex for out of my life
for good or for good out of my life. I need that step to feel
free of that." So, I'm glad Sean pushed me to do this because
I needed to change my life. I'm grateful. Oh, does he think this
absolves him? >> I don't think that step, but I forced
her to do it. Like which one is it, bro? It's reasons why I love
him so much. Cuz he really did try to make my life better.
Yeah, I tried, but you're a lost cause. Out of an abusive relationship.
Nah, the victim card is so crazy to me, bro. Do you gifted? >> Dude,
I uh Hold on. Let me see. >> Yo, thank you for the gifted
sub, Michelin. I'm glad I have witnesses, by the way. Like, what?
>> Listen, there's a clips on Clouse video. It's only 13
minutes. I don't know what more I'll need out of this, but I'm
sure I'll get all the relevant parts and then we can go to the
Anthony VOD and just watch that. Okay, >> before I jump
into this video, I got to say it's been about 8 hours of exposing,
arguing, and whatever else. So, chances are I missed out on some
stuff. If you have anything you'd like to add, do so in the comments.
I will be summarizing whatever happened at the end of the >> Pretended
to not be in a relationship. I wasn't in a Well, it was just
a friend relationship. Zena going to put you in the comments
on catching a new case. She can't put me in jail. Yeah. Yeah.
All right. I want to try to predict what she's going to do and
how she's going to talk and operate in the next days. I >> Oh
my god, this is so much better. This is the all the dead noise,
all the dead air taken out. Let's go. >> Yeah, I think
she is going to try to play like a victim. She's going to try
to play all soft and sweet like, "Oh, I just thought that he
loved me and he all these two things." And I just thought it
was very much genuine. I didn't want him to go out and hurt me
like this. I tried to leave her. He tried me after Hung Games.
I said no. I'll post a pic of him cuddling me a year ago. I said
no. I want to get more. >> We're a little further forward
than >> We're over to stuff. Yeah, we're over at the say
that this is not a good idea. That uh we should stop. This is
where we were this >> that we should not be together. He
admit how he lied for months to my face and our friends about
loving me. >> Sucks. Hate that it is this way. He wants
a content war. I'm not doing that for him so he can become another
ex like >> I don't know. The text from Zena she kind of
feeding system. If you keep sending messages about his stream,
reacting to his stream like you're kind of doing it anyway, right?
I don't want that from him at all. I don't see him that way.
I don't even want to fight
>> bro. She doesn't want me to be a X. She's still trying
to save the >> Oh, what is that? Venomous Villain with
the five gifted. Thank you very much, Venomous Villain. Appreciate
it, dude. We are
We are $12 away from another two hours on the stream, guys. Thank
you very much, Venomous Villain, for your
Okay, we're two hours. We We got plus two hours in $12. a relationship
when I when there's no saving it. I don't you and I will never
you again. I'm not going to talk to you unless it's for content
and I don't want a serious relationship. I want to focus all
my energy into myself and my career. You need to understand this.
Please don't try to chase or contact me. I'm genuinely done and
it's nothing you did specifically. Well, that might not have
been true or maybe even intentionally that might not have been
true. I just don't want a relationship. So, I'm going to block
all contact with you cuz I know you're going to try to find ways
regardless, but I will not respond. So save yourself the time.
This is my last message to you and I wish you the best. >> I'm
going to tell you what I know, what everyone here knows. Okay,
I'm gonna say something that is just global universal knowledge.
No person in the history of this earth has ever sent a message
this long saying I'm done and actually meant that they're done.
Right? Every single element of this message outside of the content,
the meaning of the words is saying I am not done. I am not done.
I am not done. I am not done. I am not done. I am not done. Nobody
will ever send a message this long unless they're like still
invested. I'm just I'm telling you >> in your life future.
>> No, cuz in some ways French toast mafia, you say you
have. I don't think so. >> Wait, what? And future. Wait,
what? And I wish you the best in your life and future. You can
remove me off the protective order. Just focus on your career
and yourself.
Sorry I had to leave like this, but you leave me no choice based
off how you behave when I usually try to leave you. And you can
try to change or better yourself, but do not make the mistake
thinking I will come back and be with you because I will not.
But you should still take these steps for your own sake. Goodbye.
Also, I left the parking pass outside your door. And please,
I'm begging. Do not contact me from another number or try to
have your friends contact me. Thanks. Bye. >> Because he
was sitting there, he dead ass said the words, "I can fix you."
He's like, "I think I can handle you. You just be with losers.
You just be guys that can't handle you. I can fix you." So yeah,
he definitely that's what he thought he was doing. >> Dude,
there's already ghost cheese. Maybe we'll do that tonight. Usernames
>> kind of did he did fix a lot. I'm not going to lie because
now it's like I mean I'm not I'm not crying anymore. You're showing
stuff for me crying and having freak outs. Now I'm not. Now I
finally started seeing like how you behaved. Like once he came
back like eighth time staring in my eyes crying talk about how
much he loves me. It finally clicked to me. I'm like, "Bro, this
is" And he talk about it's disrespectful that I compare him to
someone else. No, you are. You're just like them. So, it clicked
to me I should not give this much.
>> That sofa is so cool. No, it's not. No, it's not. This
a grandma sofa right here. All this I I actually don't think
that. It's fine. It's fine. That sofa, we can all agree though,
Cherry. That sofa is not cool in that room. The drab wallpaper
with that sofa doesn't make any sense to me. I that sofa does
not fit in that room. That sofa fits in some rooms. It does not
fit in that energy because I already did this. Why would I go
back and forth and continue doing this crying and feeling like
wanting to because oh, something went bad today and he wants
to leave today, but he's going to come back tomorrow with the
same I love you and I'm sorry, but not publicly apologize to
me after slandering me online. And I realize I'm like, I already
did this with somebody. I could have just stayed with that person
and >> Script, by the way, 30 years old. Nick White, you
don't even leave your house, dude. I saw you literally a couple
days ago walking downstairs and your does not seem like it's
working. Your belly
>> Dude, why did people try to Zena? I don't get it. You
if you if Zena knows anything about you just stay down, bro.
This like she's throwing grenades all over the place and you
just push pushed your head up out of the the the trench, okay?
Out of your foxhole and just ate like a bunch of shrapnel in
your face. Shut the up. Keep your head down and watch the content.
>> Really flabby, buddy. Like, shut the up. Like, shut
the up. Eat some more Door Dash, dude. No one gives you quit
streaming cuz your KCIP turned to $5 an hour. Like, what? Turn
on your stream. Stream more consistently and maybe you will make
some more KCIP.
Make content. Stop being boring. Maybe you should learn how to
script. >> Ghost cheese. Thank you very much for the gifted
sub. Appreciate it, dude. We're $7 away from two hours. 40. By
the way, aren't you 40 years old? >> The I did move into
the building and leech. And guess what? You live here and you
don't even leech. You got no
>> That's the difference between me and you. Turn on a
stream, make some content, and maybe your KCIP will get
>> No, that's not No, I didn't. I insinuated that you illegally
asked for my ID. I insinuated that you on probation asking to
use my ID for
>> Wait, they actually they actually got on a stream and
argued with each other.
>> I insinuated
I insinuated that you asked to use my ID for something while
you're on probation, mind you. What do you need my ID for? >> What
is that something, Zena? What is that something?
>> Okay, they do this on the Anthony stream. Should we
cut over to the Anthony stream here? Maybe.
Maybe we just cut over to the Anthony stream. Let's look at his
subs. 257 out of 260. Where are we here? 267 out of 275.
So he watches Zena and Dan together talking a little bit. >> Great.
Did she Is he gone? Let me Let me >> No, it's fine. His
stuff. I'll keep it in his bags and zip it up. I won't destroy
his property. Hopefully, he doesn't destroy my property. And
he actually gives me back all of my stuff from the boat as well
that he knows I have. And we have text messages of me telling
him when he asks me how much it costs and like how much all my
stuff >> Hold on. I'm going to go to the D10 VOD.
Here's why we're going to do this, guys. Here's how we're going
to do this cuz I'm doing it on the fly. We are going to use our
dear friend of the stream, Anthony. We're going to use his stream
as a mapping point. Okay? So, we'll know when to jump between
the two. But as soon as we actually have the mapping, okay, we
don't need them anymore. We can go over to the DT stream. We're
looking for them walking down the street. >> That makes
sense.
>> How does that make sense?
>> Easy. Wanted to leave so bad and then wanted to fly
me out there.
>> They said I got to right now. I'm just saying, but This
is what this the way it should be. Now, how many times was the
butt plug used on [__] >> No, Mando. He needed
to be here so that he could go to Ice Poseidon's house like I
said. He moved so that he could leech >> This guy, that
guy's weird. Why is that guy pushing for leaks about Shuvi? How
about you chill, bro? >> Ice. So, he moved in with me and
was using me. But anyway, um yeah, he came here so that he could
go to Ice's house to do the Aiden event to make sure he got in
the Aiden dares. >> That's what I meant. I never said I
was part of it. I'm not part of that. I'm not going. That's why
I said, "Why should my ex suffer the loss of uh being invited
to a big opportunity like that just because of a order that has
nothing to do with Shuy? Why does Shuy need to be on my protective
order and prevent Darius from being a part of an event? That's
stupid.
The >> Yeah, I just heard Aiden talking about Darius and
Shy like right before we got on the phone." >> Yeah. So,
like why would I like he could get in legal trouble if he goes
and does it when he's on the order and it's like no he >> so
apparently we're going to drop Shuy off of the protective order
so Darius can still do some ICE events that Zena's >> my
boyfriend anymore and I would get >> Darius is back >> keeping
him on there when he's not my boyfriend and he doesn't live with
me anymore. So >> well for
No, it's fine. His stuff I'll keep it in his bags and zip it
up. I won't destroy his property. Hopefully he doesn't destroy
my property and he actually gives me back all of my stuff from
the boat as well that he knows about text messages of me telling
him when he asked me how much it cost and like how much all my
stuff was and I gave him like I told him it's like dude it's
over $200 and stuff and I have all my receipts for everything
I have on there. >> Dude, this is this detent guy. So hopefully
he doesn't you know up my [__] cuz I'm not going
to [__] >> why why is he live walking into
Zena's house and why is Zena not paying attention? I'll definitely
get back >> kind of weird.
>> Kind of weird.
What? He didn't say that to me. I don't I guess I mean I'm not
>> or I don't know what business. I don't know what the
business is.
>> She's a broke. Yeah, bro.
>> all my money just in case he All my money just in case
he So, they said you grew Shuy. You used a vibration device on
him and Shuy recorded it. Are you talking about when I put the
vibrator in his ass? Like why would he record that? I didn't
record anything said
So there shouldn't be >> I wonder how true any of that
stuff is. I do know when they went to the water park, Zena mentioned
pegging him and he was super uncomfortable. He's super mad she
mentioned it at all. So I do wonder if if this is legitimate
or if she's kind of just with him by mentioning it >> videos
except for one.
>> She has like the opposite of a filter. No, Zena knows
exactly what she's leaking. Zena is very calculated in how she
leaks things.
Zena literally knows. That's why she always does it in such like
a a way that like pauses for dramatic effect a lot of the time.
She knows exactly what she's doing. Do not buy into Zena does
get ruled by her emotions a lot, but when she's going to go leak
something, she knows exactly what she's doing and why >> Zena.
Can you put me on the paperwork instead since you're taking Shuy
off so I don't have to have an altercation? >> Who would
you have an altercation? >> Oh, I don't know. I just I
don't want to have one. >> I doubt you'll have it. >> That
is a weird request. Hey, could you file like with me as your
boyfriend and then I don't have to talk to Darius. Hello. Hello.
Uh, ice bes. Somebody said ice beside in that clip. Kick this
guy out of the clout or the clout circle. Okay, get him out.
Get him out. Get him >> dude. Anthony, we can get back
to it. You want smoke, dude. >> No, bro. >> Well,
that hurt my feelings so bad, bro. >> Yeah, of course.
And everybody should be able to be friends. There shouldn't be
all this crazy decoration. There should be a point where everyone
could be civil and just make content together. I 100% agree.
They should be able to be friends. there shouldn't be issues.
So, he should never have lied to that man. Fake confidence. He
shouldn't have been lying all the time. He should have just been
honest like, "Yeah, we're just talking. We're having fun to become
all this, I love you. I want to be with you." And all this other
extra secretive
and whatnot. It never need to be that. So, I don't have the time
to read. Why can't they be friends? >> Yeah. Why can't
they be friends?
>> He should be messaging him right now and trying to like
maybe they can meet up and like have a conversation manto man
and be friends, you know? There doesn't need to be actual smoke.
It doesn't need to be actual drama, especially,
>> you know, from a situation that was because of me
bed with someone. And I curved him. I was saying no. I was saying
no. I mean, mostly it was because of age. But yeah, at that hotel,
I got two beds. He was muting his stream talking about, "Let's
get one bed." I said, "Well, you funny." So, boom. Um, I got
two beds. And then that night, that's why I made jokes ever since
like a long time where he had like he had to admit, I was like,
"Oh, he had nightmares. He wanted to get in the bed with me."
Because he was sitting there, he dead said the words, "I can
fix you." He's like, "I think I can handle you. You just be losers.
You just being guys that can't handle you. I can fix you. So
yeah, he definitely that's what he thought he was doing.
>> And in a way he kind of did. He did fix a lot. I'm not
going to lie because now it's like I mean I'm not I'm not crying
anymore. He was showing stuff of me crying and having freakouts.
Now I'm not. Now I finally started seeing like how you behave.
Like once he came back like the eighth time staring in my eyes
crying talk about how much he loves me. It finally clicked to
me. I'm like bro this is if you talk about it's disrespectful
that I compare him to someone else. No, you are. You're just
like them. So, it clicked to me. I should not give this much
energy because I already did this. Why would I go back and forth
and continue doing this crying and feeling like and wanting to
end my life because oh, something went bad today and he wants
to leave today, but he's going to come back tomorrow with the
same I love you and I'm sorry, but not publicly apologize to
me after slandering me online. And I realize I'm like, I already
did this with somebody. I could have just stayed with that person
and continued it. >> Wait, Shuy, can I be the plus one
to >> Like, what?
>> None of these people are good actors. They clearly hopped
on a group chat to roleplay this out. I don't know.
H I don't know, man. It's I feel like a lot more of the like
Darius Circle stuff feels really scripted recently. Like it's
just not the same. The Zena Darius stuff always felt so real
and then a lot of the stuff I watch now it's like it just doesn't
hit quite the same. It feels like they're just trying to farm
it for money >> for opportunities.
Do you have the butt like on the >> Was that
you saw the Yeah. You know what he said when he seen it? He goes,
"A buck is there." And that's why you came out. I know when you
came out and I was like sorry about the uh >> about the
bathroom.
>> I saw it. I didn't know what it was but then like now
that we're talking about >> plugs. I mean I you want to
bring your stream. I don't know if you >> Oh, I mean I
mean sure. >> I mean is that >> I mean I don't want
to show a butt plug on stream. >> You can show I mean I
don't know. >> What is this? Your makeup plug. So that's
one that's >> Oh yeah. I don't want to show that on
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Uh-huh. It still got hair on it.
>> I don't want to show that on stream. Let me just walk
over to the bathroom and ask where it is and can you show it?
Oh no. Oh, I don't want to show that on >> Let me show
you the strap on that he >> Oh, no. I can't show that on
stream. >> You can see >> I can't I mean, that's
just like a That's like a streaming IRL chest mount, >> The
strap on he bought me >> IRL chest mount. Yeah. Yeah. He
bought me all this stuff. Look. I mean, it was >> This
is >> He got me this
ball. >> I don't know that I believe this with the vibrator.
>> That's not what that is. That's not
the vibrator.
>> I don't Man, I don't know if I believe this. on it.
All these lubes and like all these stuff like easy hella butt
plugs everywhere. Butt plug butt plug. I don't know what he did
with my diamond butt plug that was the last we used. But yeah,
anyway, I got a bunch of got a bunch of toys from >> I
think I think this is cringe when you share these details with
people. >> I'm not a fan
because you probably just >> Well, he took it out cuz he
had to take a shower. So, please >> this dude walk around
the house and say [__] in his ass. No, we'd be doing
freaky [__] in your [__] I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
>> this dude walked around the house.
>> No, we'd be doing freaky [__] and you're
[__] I'm just kidding. I'm just
It was all me. Don't worry. >> It was all me. It was all
me. It was all me. So, she says she's kidding right here. I I
but I have no idea. I I lean towards she was just making it up
to with him and now she says she's kidding. >> She gets
pegged. It's [__] done. I feel bad cuz he rated it
to me. I got thousand viewers. This is not good for >> Look
at D10's chat.
D10, make your move. She freaky as Okay. Yeah, there's a bunch
of people just saying try to Okay. >> Do what? I mean,
what? Just be honest.
>> Yeah, I'm just, you know, I'm just letting you chat
and let you do your thing. Why not? You know, just let g
say anything.
>> She's so happy about telling everyone she pegged a teenager.
You're 30 years old. Wait, why why would that be like not something
she could laugh about or brag about, assuming he was like fine
with it being out there or he made it public? I don't I don't
understand. You understand that? Like the solution to whether
or not somebody's content is not you're 30 years old, right?
Like Zena is better content than everybody else in this entire
like ice besidon sphere like by miles. Like literally watching
any of the people the normal people interact, they're boring
as dude. I wanted to kill myself watching that Shuvi stream.
Why would we pretend that any of these people are content in
comparison to
>> Like he would just show me messages from like chatters
like that would private message him all the time like that are
in the Discord. I don't even got to say names and stuff. And
he'd be like I just be fake with them talking about you were
real one man. Thanks for having my back and stuff like that.
And then he telling me it's all fake and they're weirdos and
they're obsessed with me. Yada yada >> She's a predator.
Wait, who are the other streamers you like? Who who are the IRL
streamers who aren't predators that you like? Go ahead. Sorry.
No, no, no. Actually, hold on. Tell me which IRL streamers you
like. Just do that. Just do that.
>> But then when people would message me stuff, he'd be
telling me I had to block people and like if someone flirted
with me, it was an issue. Like I don't know. I think he should
try to be friends with everybody again. I mean, there's no reason
for him to have beef with >> Like are we are we pretending
Darius didn't literally change his age on Tinder so that he could
still match with like 18 and 19year-olds? Are we going to pretend
that that didn't happen? Like I listen I understand that you
might think it's weird that Zena what a 19-year-old when she
was 2930 or 18-year-old when she's 2930 but like Darius absolutely
changed his Tinder age while living in Arizona toys.
That happened. We all saw it happen. >> I'm not with him.
I'm not with my ex. There's no reason for them to have either.
They might as well be.
>> Agree. Yeah. I completely agree with >> Yeah.
You should be messaging him now, you know. >> Yeah. Yeah.
They're probably on the phone call right now. >> I don't
know if I called Darius a predator for that, by the way. It's
weird though. It is weird. >> Broke I would be cooking.
He put me on the sink like he me over there. >> Okay. Where
can I stand >> Oh my god. We on the balcony. Oh my god.
I was out there balcony. Yeah. I put a blanket to cover cuz he
was like, "Oh, people will see." So I put a blanket to cover
the thing and it actually covered the privacy thing even more
and the wind kept blowing and trying to knock the >> Yes.
He Dude, you don't know. Is it? It wasn't Grace. Who was it?
Who's the blonde girl who showed up at Darius's house and he
got her high and they Who was that? Uh, it's not Hannah. It's
the girl before Hannah. It's like the first girl when he like
started streaming from. Why can't I remember her name? Oh, blonde
girl. Blonde girl. Destiny called her fat once. Elise. Elise.
Thank you. Ray Ray. Elise. Yes.
Elise was 18. >> He's like, "They're going to catch us
out here." >> What the is this thing? >> So that's
the And honestly, the dick mode was his idea. >> That's
a dick mold. No, dude.
>> Wait, did he touch it? >> What the is this? >> What
are you doing, bro? So that's the dick. And honestly, the dick
mold was his idea. >> That's a mold. No dick. Yeah. >> I
thought it was a candle. >> Yeah. And then was up, so he
threw it in the in the brand new fresh trash bag, by the way,
>> with like a pancake mix in there. And I took it out
cuz I was like, "No, I can just we could just get a different
one." And I threw it in the recycling one because Selfie started
licking it. But that's why I just >> Wait, hold on.
>> Yeah. Shuy packing. Wait, wait, wait. Hold on. >> So
that's the >> That's a That's a healthy circumference right
there. Shuy might be packing, guys. Jesus Christ. >> The
drink mode was his idea. God damn. No. God damn. >> I thought
it was a candle. >> Yeah. And then the silicone was up.
So he threw it in a in a brand new fresh
>> with like a pancake mix in there. No, I just we could
just And I threw it in the recycling one because Selfie started
licking it. But that's why I just like >> What the [__]
>> My streamer is literally watching. It's just listen.
When are you going to get when do you get a solid measure on
another dude without a dick?
That is the perfect opportunity. Nobody can even call you gay.
I'm looking at the I'm looking at the outline of his I'm not
even looking at his. Okay. It's not It's objectively the absence
of It's like the least gay thing you could look at. We're looking
at the absence of right there. >> No, he made it for me
because whenever he was gone, I was like, "It would be cool to
have a mold." And then he's like, "We should actually do it."
And when we were at the he was there and he picked it out and
he's like, "Wait, do this for you. Use this. >> Okay, that's
fine." for when he's gone for long periods of time so that I
don't like even feel tempted to get attention from anybody else
or whatever. So anyway, yeah, I have the mold and I mean I'm
going to make the mold. I don't give a call weird, but it's a
good size. Sometimes he would tell me I only wanted him for his
>> Okay, I'm going to tell I'm going tell this guy. Okay,
Dan.
Not a good look for you to be like here playing with her cat
while she's talking about how good some other dude's is on the
phone. I'm just saying.
I'm just saying. Okay. I'm just saying it's like that's a rough
one. actually say that too and last night that I only care when
he leaves and I only love him and show that I actually love him
when he's leaving but when he's with me I don't give a [__]
about him >> and most of the time I don't want to be touched
like no I just have anxiety and I don't want to be like touched
24/7 and I'll be sitting there on the phone talking to my friend
and you're trying to put your hand in my pants or grab my like
yeah I'm going to move your hand that does not mean I hate you
just means hello I'm on the phone my friend or my sister like
why are you trying to touch me I'm not horny right now you're
horny cuz you're young I'm talking to my sister my is not wet
dude >> he's probably on this >> today What's crazy
is today on the Fresh and Fit VC Discord, I thought I had had
muted and deafened or whatever. So, they heard us starting to
get freaky because he just kept grabbing me and telling me to
get off the thing and I said, "It's muted. It's muted." And they
got quiet as Oh. And they
>> What the [__] >> was going on? And
just said, "No, I had to get up indefinite like oh,
>> this an important section." Not really. >> Muted.
So, they basically heard us by accident or start to >> You
want to hop on and ask a question?
>> Is trying to trying to pressure you off your detail?
Yeah, he's trying to get >> I'm over here getting in the
middle of this [__] knowing she owes me some weed.
>> but yeah. I mean, I don't care. At the end of the day,
he got what he >> Hello. What's up, man? >> How's
it going?
>> How How long has Stardust been like a cowardly, hypocritical,
inconsistent, lying like
if you had to like throw just throw out an estimate if you could.
>> I don't know. I I all I know is she like never contributes.
I don't know if she's any of those things. All I know is like
I used to watch Destiny and when Stardust would join it was just
never like a contribution. It was like literally to to detract
from the content every single time. >> So when the Annavore
call happened, he was in like the corner smiling and giggling.
No, just really quick really quick. Listen, she was smiling and
giggling when Annavore was having her mental breakdown and then
everybody in that stream agreed to take down their VOD because
Anna asked them to. She was the only one who refused to take
it down when Anna asked her to. She refused to take it down.
She kept it up. Okay. And now now her stream from yesterday,
she's complaining about this space being
All right, that is >> Yeah, I think >> I No, I agree
with you that like I think um she used to have a personality
for being like really mean and being the person who would go
and like she could go where all of the like evil people were
making jokes like she'd go on the stream or on some cozy stream
and just get called like a dirty
like curry cell or whatever the like whatever they say that to
Indian people, right? I don't know. Oh, I'm not racist Indians.
I wouldn't know. But just get on all the time. And so her whole
brand was like, I'm tough. I'm like, I'm here. I'm hanging out.
I can hang with all these people. But she kind of just got mocked.
So I could see her attitude changing from like, oh, that didn't
work out for me. Like I kind of just got made fun of the whole
time. >> And then out of nowhere on her stream from yesterday,
she starts, she's like, "Oh, people were too hard on Willie Mac.
People were people people were making fun of of uh of Pixie.
And then they also hated the Willie Mac video because he didn't
talk to Cherry. And it's like she doesn't care about the criticisms
of Willie Mack. And then I try I sent you some DMs. You can leak.
I already leaked these. Okay, you have they're already public.
I already put these on my stream. And I'm like, "Hey, I'll talk
to you. I'll explain to you the Willy Mack criticisms." And then
she's like, "No, thank you." I'm like, "Okay, well, you know,
I just think it's a little a little odd that you're complaining
about the space being misogynistic, yet you helped to forge that."
And then also, you know, you're you dismiss Willie Matt criticisms
when he included revenge audio and exactly where to find it.
Uh, which would lead to other women also being exposed and stuff
like that. Uh, hopefully you'll honor discussions with people
critical of your behavior going forward. Have a nice night. And
she's like, "No, thank you." And then she follows that up like
a couple minutes later. She's like, "Oh, I just read I made amends
with Anna like years ago, but I don't really care about getting
involved with your beef. Have a nice night." She can't even comprehend
the critique that I'm trying to lay out. The critic, the issues
that I'm trying to lay out. She can't even comprehend it. Her
entire like brand is based on like utter buffooner. It It's insane.
This is so maddening. I've never been this mad. I think before
in my life, >> she doesn't really have a brand. >> I
don't know how she could criticize me and then not want to talk
to you. You're literally offering to talk to her about like some
stuff on stream. I don't know why she wouldn't. I don't know
why she was like she wanted to talk to me so badly and then I
offered to talk to her and she was like no you everybody here
is so
but now yeah I don't know why she wouldn't talk to you
>> has she like dude she went on to like the stream why
is she such a now >> I don't I literally don't know I actually
don't know I maybe something like um thinks if she loses like
conversation she'll lose audience I have no I don't I literally
don't know I couldn't tell you >> am I being like I I feel
like I'm being incredibly cordial in these DMs, too. Like, I
feel like I'm being real nice. Like, I'm like, "Hey, I'll talk
to you if you like here's the issues that I had. I'll talk to
you on stream." >> Hold on. Let me read this. Let me read
this and see. Hey, Stardust. Smile. Watch a recent live stream
and saw you made a claim that Willie Mack was being crybullied.
I don't like Willie Mack and I can probably lay out to you some
of the issues I and many others have with two his two Destiny
videos. For example, he said he spoke to all the victims, but
he didn't. Not just Cherry, but also people like Stalia were
ignored. Furthermore, he shows Cher's revenge audio in his video
and the with the Kiwi Farms page shown directly showing where
you can find the audio. I think these among other examples are
pretty deplorable. If you're open for a chat, I can elaborate
or expand. Looking forward to your reply.
>> Uh, also I agree with your take here. He didn't prove
she lied about anything. So, apparently you had messages before
this. So, also >> I agree with your take here. It seems
like from what I can tell, she did just dox Kyla for no reason.
Or he did just dox Kyla for no reason. No, thank you. Understood.
I think it's very rich. You complain about the misogynistic.
I guess this was not that bad. Uh, she probably just knows who
you are, right? >> Here, I want this. I I'm I'm I'm
like I'm okay. I'm I would have been cordial, too. This is just
like disgusting behavior. She's just like entirely hypocritical
and like running from anybody critical of her. Like if if you
if you outright just like lie on your stream or like lead people
to misinformation and and then someone's like, "Hey, you you
might be wrong here. Like people do have a reason to dislike."
And then you're you're like, "No, I'll not talk to you." Like,
you're just I don't know. I don't know. I just I feel like that's
like on the same level of of like being complicit in misinformation
and stuff. And then she's complaining about the space being misogynistic
when she was complicit in misogyny and she's not clarifying like,
"Hey, in the past I was uh complicit in this type of behavior,
but I disavow it now." Like it's just she's just entirely like
hypocritical and like I don't know how anybody can >> wait.
So you're saying that that like I she disavows it now or something?
>> No, she didn't. She didn't. That that's my point. I
can't think. I imagine she could have said something like that
and I would have been fine with it because it's like, okay, she
changed her position, but she didn't. She's acting like the past
never happened. She's acting like she was like a a perfect kid
when she was complicit in the Anavar shed. Uh, and then now she's
like, why is this space so misogynistic when she's the one who
helped like forge that path? She didn't stand up for what apparently
her principles are. Does that make >> Um, yeah, it makes
sense. I think like if you Yeah. If you want I don't know if
Stardust has like a lot of principles. She's just like a drama
streamer who I don't know just >> I think if you don't
have principles you're like meaningless. I think that's like
worthless. You should definitely have stuff you stand by.
>> Yeah. You should have stuff you stand on. I just mean
I don't think she has like a wellfounded philosophical view of
the world necessarily, but I I mean I don't have misogyny. She
should have like said something. I think that's what I think.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Principles on specific
>> Um what was I going to say? Somebody asked who dosed
Kyla. I assume you were talking about Sunday there or something.
>> Yeah, like a couple months ago, she wrote this like
massive paragraph on Twitter saying that Sunday docs Kylo and
I never heard of it. So, I reached out and I was like, can you
explain this to
>> What was her explanation? I actually don't know. >> Um,
sure. >> I won't I won't because I don't I don't I don't
care to leak those DMs. I I'll like TLDDR it. But I was I tweet
I'm just asking for her reasoning.
>> Yeah, I'm just asking for reason >> cuz I I was
genuinely just curious. I was like, "Why? Why do you think this?"
>> cuz I've seen some people argue that she didn't dox
or sorry, he didn't dox Kyla, right? I've seen some people argue
that, but I forget sometimes if I haven't like looked at it recently.
I just forget exactly how it went down, >> what was done.
>> Yeah. So, I I sent her her own tweet and I was like,
"How did Sunday dox Kyla?" I'm not attacking you. I just assumed
her name, location, etc. were all public, so I'm confused. Uh
and then uh she basically made the argument that by Sunday's
standards uh he doxed her. uh which I won't go into detail there.
I'm sure you can imagine what you know that means but >> well
being public doesn't mean you're not doxing right just the fact
that it's public information it would depend on if it was so
I think if you're a public influencer so there's this like Elder
Drazzi situation people bring up a lot where Elder Drazzie thought
that >> I think somebody in Chud's Discord doxed him because
they brought up like his his TikTok for his Elder Drazzie name
and it had like his real name on it or something right and they're
like that's not really come on that's not really doxing like
you can't you can't have social media tied to your streaming
account with your name on it and then Hey, people using your
name is doxing. And so I think I think it was something close
to that that she talked about content on stream where her name
was used or something. I think it's I don't know how concerned
she is about it now. I'm not going to say it or whatever, but
obviously she says her name's Kyla, but there's a there's more
there. My memory was that Sunday had an email on his hit piece
on Kyla that had PI. >> So was that was that her email
or was that that he said Oh. Oh. Was this the was this the criticism?
was that it was an email to her university, but he didn't know
that it was her university. There was only like >> there's
only like two or three universities that offered that that degree
program. And so he reached out to one of them and he happened
to land on her university. I want to say that was his argument
back >> here. I'll I'll DM you the TLDDR. >> I don't
know how much of this is public, so I don't want to announce
any of this if it's like private. So ba basically by Sunday's
standards, he had doxed Kyla is is what she explained to me.
Kill the Sunday got doxed through his Facebook. >> Don't
read it aloud. I don't know if it's public. See if it's public
for I don't know if that's public. You know more about this.
>> Well, I mean, sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I started reading
I was reading a different message. It's It doesn't help if you
don't know, right? >> Sorry. That that message I just read
I won't read more. But no, that is not I don't think that's a
problem. Right. Obviously, people have social media profiles
and I didn't say anything about like what it is. Sorry. I just
started raiding. No, you're fine. You're fine. I wanted to clarify.
Yeah, thank No, yeah, you're you're fine. That's the explanation.
Um, you know, that that she gave me. I thought Okay. Yeah, that
makes sense. That makes sense if that's a standard.
>> But hold on. No, I don't think that would make sense.
I need to see what actually happened. >> I don't know what
happened. I know Sunday did like a stream on it. >> Like
if he Okay, if he did like a stream on it and he straight up
like
posted her Facebook profile, that would be weird. That would
be like, yeah, I would call that probably doxing. >> Uh,
well, he found the information through the Facebook is what I
what what happened. I think that's how it was explained to me.
I don't know if that's true. I don't know that's true. >> H
Did she explain exa explain what actually happened? What Sunday
specifically did. Does nobody in chat know or cuz I could have
a lot of people stand in the line that he never do. >> I
don't know if I want to leak everything she said. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I've I've just heard I've heard people argue.
I believe Sunday argues he didn't dox her. So, I'm like trying
to think of how I'm just trying to figure out like exactly what
happened there in my head so I can know going forward. Dude,
what the hell? Where's the when you need him? This guy's like
an infinite repository of um 2020 to 2022 Destiny community knowledge,
Twitch politics knowledge.
Where is this guy? Where is he? And his argument is that he didn't
share the info he found with others. Well, yeah, doxing necessarily
requires like a public component,
right? like you could say I don't think there's I don't think
there's necessarily something wrong with investigating something
um
and not making it public right I don't know there's probably
arguments both ways there yeah so
calling her school so this is this is what I'd heard people say
was like calling her school was doxing but from what I understand
Sunday's statement there is she said she had a very specific
degree program I googled it I took the first result and I called
that school to ask about that degree program and like what somebody
could could say. And I never revealed I was asking about Kyla.
I just asked if somebody was a graduate from this program, would
it be like okay to use this this title?
So, I don't know that you could I I don't think if that's what
we're talking about that you could possibly call that doxing.
It's uncomfortable.
It's weird, but I I wouldn't say that rises to doxing. You remember
that freak stream where Kyler Van Menace Sunday with his dogs?
Um,
no. I remember, dude. I remember the thing with the thing with
Nick was weird. The thing with Nick was weird, but I don't know.
I don't know about the Kylo thing. But yeah, I mean, Forgotten
Jones, if you want to make the argument that that him like you'd
have to argue that he found that information through through
like nefarious means or something, I guess. And then if he never
uses it to publicly harass her, like he's not he's not trying
to call the school and say like this person is faking their credentials.
Far as I know that never happened, right? And he um also, as
far as I know, he just asked generic questions about the school
or about the
>> Yeah. I I think as well, again, I'm just paring information
that I was told. Um the information that he ultimately did find
didn't lead to him like catching her in a lie or her using credentials
to win like a debate where she, you know, whatever. So, it was
kind of like meaningless and useless. He just really didn't like
Aerodite. >> Um it wasn't totally meaningless. I feel like
he had there was like some point there with how she was using
like representing herself. There was some point there, but it's
um like I don't know. It probably wasn't really worth somebody
investigating that hard, I guess. But I who am I to deter like
I also think a lot of things are waste of time that happened
on the internet, so I don't know who I am to tell other people
how they could spend their time, right? I'm just looking at chat
here. So, oh, and the person Sunday did speak to did turn out
to be Kyla's supervisor. I've heard this litigated on a stream
recently, so I don't I feel like this is all public information.
And the person that he talked to turned out to be her supervisor,
but he was just calling a school and he called like he didn't
even call I don't think like the I think he called like some
department and it the way he's described it. Listen, if it happened
as he said, which I realize there's reason to question that,
but if it happened as he said is absolutely not doxing, right?
I feel like I remember her mentioning her mentor giving her a
heads up about some someone asking about her, which would mean
that he did ask about her specifically. Well, if he did ask about
her specifically, my concern would be, okay, here's here's the
progression that would seem concerning to me. Sunday does this,
he does the video, right? Also, two subs, guys. Two subs, two
more hours in the stream. 12 minutes left. I know you'll get
there. The the concern would be he makes the video some maybe
in the video he includes the university or something. Maybe not
even the emails, but somehow he includes the university or it's
easy to find the university.
Some skitso
takes that video and like the things that are said there and
goes, "I need to fix this." And starts calling the schools with
that degree program and saying this this person who whose name
you could probably find if you like if they also doxed Kyla,
right? But I'm not advocating for that obviously, but I'm saying
if they if they knew who she was or if they said, "Oh, it's Kyla
something, right?" That there'd be ways to like do that. That
would be the concern is there'd be like some skitso. I don't
know if I'd hold Sunday responsible for that 100%, but Ghost
Cheese, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. Oh, and one more
Ghost Cheese. Another gifted sub. Thank you. Thank you. That's
two more hours in the stream. Let's go. I wonder why nobody's
ever done a retrospective on this. I think everybody basically
I think things got like really crazy around that stuff and basically
it was like, "Okay, everybody go their separate ways. We don't
talk about this anymore. Let's all off." like like there was
allegations of doxing going both ways and then
both parties kind of were just like yeah let's pull this back
and not like go super hard anymore. I think that's how it went.
Or call. Well, if I So, I think from the Sunday video, what I
remember was Kyla did introduce herself improperly early on a
couple of times, like once or twice, right? So, she would she
did actually introduce herself improperly. It did seem kind of
odd. Oh, wait, hold on. It was only one gifted sub. I'll I'll
do We're $2 away, but it
it that's fine. >> This is like so
She is she is she keeps like ending the conversation but then
like 5 minutes later sending me a new message and I I don't know
if I'm being trolled or not. She's being like
genuinely >> ask her well ask her if she wants to come
on stream. Tell her she can come on >> and she can uh I'll
I'll sit out. I won't uh I won't argue anything. >> Uh
Byron, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go.
>> Yeah, I'll sit out. She can talk to you on stream
if you want to join the waiting channel.
Otherwise, uh, if you message me when you're live, I'm more than
willing to private VC with you, uh, in DMs. I don't even have
to be alive.
>> just looking for a
Don't care about clout on my end or gaining anything. mostly
want to
convey my position to you.
>> Okay, smile.
Sophia, thank you for the two gifted. Bob Rub, thank you for
the one gifted. I actually didn't add enough money onto the next
hour of the stream. I ripped you guys off. Hold on. Let me fix
that super quick.
>> Right before we get Modib with a gifted sub as well.
Thank you guys. Thank you for the support. Really appreciate
it. Really appreciate all the support. Thank you guys. Thank
you. Thank you. Another gifted sub. Have a productive Stardust
combo is the first mistake. Well,
also tell her um >> man can dream. >> Tell her tell
her we'll keep Queen away.
>> He won't be allowed. >> No. No. No. No Queen's
allowed. >> I mean, listen, my from my perspective, I just
want to con I want to convey to her because it makes me mad when
people say like Willie Mack is getting hate for no reason when
he has valid reasons to for for getting hate. So, at the very
least, I would like to convey to her why people, including myself,
are critical of Willie Mack and see, you know, if she maybe responds
to that or see if she has uh like opinions uh to that or see
if, you know, anything. I don't know. I know nothing about Stardust.
Maybe she's like
completely. I don't know. I haven't looked into her at all. >> Man,
I have opinions. I'm just trying not to be rude, okay? I'm just
trying my best to to not be rude right now. >> I know you
want to convey whatever to me, but I don't really care about
your opinion. To be honest, you aren't special to me. Okay, this
is like >> I mean I don't So
>> what the am I even supposed to say to this? Like you
got something wrong on stream and I want to talk to you about
>> I just think she's lost all of her like all of the So
she already lost her high ground on like wanting to talk to me,
right? She wanted to have a conversation with me and I was like
no thank you. And then sorry, not no thank you. I said you could
hop on the stream. She said no. And I was like well we could
talk oneonone. She still said no. So that was weird. But even
when she had like a little bit of a high ground to stand on,
I don't understand how she'd do that and then say, "Oh, no. You're
a small creator. I don't know you. I don't care about you." Right?
That seems totally worthless if
Also, don't you you probably get the same viewership she does.
I don't even know why she'd say that or do that. >> I don't
know, dude. This is like >> had 30 viewers. Well,
>> she gets more. I get 20, dude. Sometimes I get 20 sometimes.
Okay. She mugs me on Tuesdays or something. I saw you at like
I saw you at like 80 or 90 last night. Don't lie to me. >> I
was at 80 earlier. When I jumped on your stream, I don't think
my my people like you. They kind of left when I came >> Wait,
you're you're live right now? I didn't know you're live. >> Yeah,
I'm going to end soon. That's why I joined. >> No worries.
Yeah, no worries.
>> No, how this happened. I was I was natur I I was watching
I was covering something and then she had actually covered the
same thing and she said something stupid on the stream and I
was like, let me let's look at one of her modern streams. I looked
at her most recent stream and I clicked randomly to a point and
she tried to say that a bunch of people were saying that she
had sex with Destiny which I've never seen before. I've never
seen that. >> No, I think I think uh the joke is literally
like how up must it be
to like never have gotten a pass made at you. I think that's
the joke. on her stream was was trying to say like um like people
keep saying I had sex with Destiny and it's so it's so dehumanizing
to have that happen to me and then she started complaining that
the space was misogynistic and racist and she pulled up Gamma's
video on Mudahar where it says liar fraud Indian and she's like
this is just disgusting why is Indian in red and I was like okay
this is ridiculous and she's like this space is just so misogynistic
and then I pulled up the stream of her and Anna when Anna was
having the mental breakdown and she was in the corner uh just
giggling to herself and like making jokes to herself while she
was muted and she I I learned uh that she is the only person
in that stream to have refused to take her VOD down. She refused
to take it down when Anna asked her to. Okay. Um so she she's
complaining about a misogynistic space when that's a space that
she was complicit in. Uh and then the whole Willy Mac thing.
She just didn't understand the Willy criticism and she tried
to downplay it. So I was like, "Okay, I'll message her. I'll
say, "Hey, I had an issue with your misogynistic thing. It seems
like you were complicit in it. Uh and I also want to explain
the Willy Mac stuff to you if you if you genuinely don't understand."
And I was I feel like I was really polite in DMs, but uh maybe
not. I don't know.
>> Uh you were uh so shockingly polite, Maro. You were
shockingly polite for the first part of that DM. I did not expect
you to do that. >> I mean, I I actually want I I being
serious. I wanted to talk to her. I wanted to have her on stream
and and convey my position to her. I I was not even now uh I
am I am typing out a passive aggressive message to her. Um but
I'm still there's still an air of politeness. I feel I'm still
trying to be polite. I'm still trying to be nice. I'm not trying
to crash at I'm not trying to call her Porky Pig and say that
she should be sent to a slaughter house and have her throat slit
and drained and made into sausages and sent to Palest. He's joking.
That's
a joke. Total joke. Total joke. He's joking. >> I'm not
saying anything like that. I'm not even saying anything like
that. So, I don't know. >> I don't know. >> These
people are You better still be live on YouTube saying that talking
that >> I 10,000% am. >> Okay. Well, as long as you
don't come As long as you don't come on my stream and not be
live and then start fed posting on my stream.
>> I have said worse on this stream so far. Don't worry.
I got really upset at the things the Stardust was saying. I got
real mad. Okay, don't worry. >> Yeah. Jesus Christ. Jesus.
>> I said some uh I think at one point I said she was like
in her head she was like every time she met Destiny she was begging
that he would rap her or something and now she's like sad and
and butt hurt that that she didn't get raped or something. Hey
bro, >> I said some like going off. Disavow that. Disavow
that. Disavow that. >> this guy's crazy. Something wrong
with this guy.
>> This guy is crazy. This guy is insane. All right, I'll
I'll I'll hop out. Thank you for letting me call in. Smile.
>> Yeah, no problem. Thanks for coming on. Talk to you
later. >> Love you.
I can't do that one anymore. It's just It's weird. Oh boy.
She'll see this and definitely not talk. So DMing is pointless.
Okay, this might be true. As soon as she said I'm As soon as
he said I'm on JTO, he probably lost his chance.
>> I'll be honest. I'll be honest. >> This and now
I got what I wanted to. And I'm just glad that now it's not this
weird secret thing. >> All right, we're back. >> He
made it sometimes he would make it like like at the party when
he begged me at Hannah's party and I was like, "Bro, you're underage.
No one wants you here." And I had to beg them to let him come.
And then originally he's saying, "We need to be exclusive." And
he told me, "I can't talk to any dude. If dudes talk to me there,
don't I better say I have a man, whatever, whatever." But then
because his chat was like hyping him up to talk to this chick
that I already talked to by the way, Marky's friend. And then
anyway, so I of course, you know, I cooked like, "No, we didn't
even decide this. You're not going to come to a party I invited
you to and try to play with me, buster. Like you need to go somewhere
else and find a different [__] or whatever." So anyway,
long story short, like thanks. Oh, you're done. Damn, this [__]
little
roasted got a cane and no left. >> Probably remember what
I was saying. I was gonna say dude been with I am glad that mindset
to keep pushing on me because now it's like okay live. Okay.
>> White car for like six months straight. Let's be real.
Come on. >> I'm not saying I didn't say he doesn't have
content. >> Who's on the phone now? >> Oh that is
still that's still Anthony right on the phone with them. >> He
quit streaming how many times? >> I'm just I'm going forward
cuz I want to get to the >> All I know is I follow him
and I never get a notification that says >> I'm going to
go and find the actual conversation. That's what we need. We
need the actual combo. >> All I'm saying is like what do
I need to beef with him for? Like he don't even like do anything
like >> this is
you got 20 views. That's why your KCIP is dog.
>> Yeah. Like but >> Okay. Shooty is responding.
He said he's down to hop on a call. Are you Do you want a three-way?
>> No. I don't even think he wants to either, so it's fine.
>> But if you said yes, would you? >> No. It's okay,
man. >> Okay. Just make sure. >> Unless he would
be >> No, Darius got out of jail a couple days ago. Al
be 100%. >> He ain't still in jail >> as honest as
I am. Then then I wouldn't then I wouldn't mind and then and
then it wouldn't even be drama. If he would just straight up
admit to things, then it would just be fine. But I feel like
he won't. >> All right. Just waiting on the response. >> She
knows she lying. I mean, I shared >> The guy that went
to court with her, right? It is. Yes. >> Make a decision
here. >> Did I not go far enough for this? >> I can
do a call straight through there. >> Let me check. Make
sure you can hear me. Can you hear me though? >> I can.
There we go. Isn't that cool?
>> Mic check. >> Here it is.
>> All right. But how we is it good everybody? We good?
Phil one's guest for >> Here we go. >> Nina, you
admit to holding me uh against my will. >> Do you admit
to locking me in my room and not letting me out even last night?
>> No, I never did that. But I have recordings of you.
Uh >> but you did do that. And two people were in my house
when you were doing that. You forgot that, right? >> Okay.
D10 and squeeze. Let's ask them right now. Why don't you ask
D10? He's with you. >> I don't want to get involved. No,
you don't want to get involved. >> Wait, what? Why was
Squeeze there? I plead the fifth. >> Okay. And I mean,
I'm sure we could ask Squeeze. I think he's going to say the
same thing. >> Oh, wait. What's the date on this? No, pause.
What is the date on this? I held you against your will, right?
>> Yeah, multiple times. >> Wait, they broke up?
Uh, yeah, they broke up. That's what this whole thing is. They're
leaking cuz they broke up >> and you admitted >> multiple
times, right? But you >> What is going on? Okay, real quick.
Catch up, guys. Shuy and Zena broke up. Uh, they've both been
like escalatingly leaking different stuff about each other, possibly
all scripted content. We'll see how this last interaction goes.
But now they're finally getting They spent all day like kind
of passive aggressively leaking and responding to each other's
streams. Now they're on a call together and they're doing contact.
>> You left. No, you were always free to leave. I did get
in front of you to try to talk to you. I never held you against
your will. >> Yes. You held me in your >> No, I said
I got in front of the door. Yes. Just like you did multiple times
and I also have recordings, but that's also fine. Again, talking
over me. Talking over me. Talking over me. >> Let her talk.
Let her talk, bro. Let her talk. Let her talk. You got to You
guys got to have the same reciprocal respect. So, we're going
for lunch. >> So, why did you keep coming back to my >> Why
did you drive to No, no. I just want to know. I just want to
know because >> as a >> Oh my god,
Dude,
uh, somebody just sent me this. Apparently, Destiny's going and
reading um different subreddits and like trying to look at the
profiles of different people, right? So, there's Missy Elliot,
known YouTube chatter, known former Lonerbox fan, former Queen
or current Queenman fan possibly. I don't know. They've been
gone for a while. Who deserves the most fault for what happened
to Pixie other than the anonymous solo leaker? Lol. They're literally
just down voting without answering. Very telling. Posting the
Queen and Leftovers H3 sub. You are the person who sent this
video without consent. What are we doing? What is happening?
How does he think that he has any argument here? My My guy. Dude,
he's turning into Casey Trotron. He Dude, I told you you can't
read your Kiwi Farms thread publicly like on a live stream and
not be like past the event horizon, right? You're you're in the
local black hole. You cannot escape anymore. He's in there. He's
never getting out. Yeah, I know he's easy. I know. I know. I'm
just I didn't see I didn't recognize that it was his account
that was commenting that he's like going around and trying to
like pull people's papers on Reddit. He's like a Reddit mod without
the actual mod powers. He's just going around being like a Reddit
mod. That's what he's doing. Cool.
Very, very cool. All right, back to back to our Zena. >> Actually,
I have a better question. >> Oh, also after this I think
after this I'll go do the skitso stream. Okay, I'll go pull up
the skitso stream. We'll go through that whole first skitso stream.
One second. Sorry. Sending messages. I'm sending messages. We
might have We might have some stuff. >> Can you mute him
for a second? Dan, not anything pertaining to the case, but one
>> quickest quack. Unfortunately, there's like there's
like hours of this stuff, isn't there?
We'll cover a lot of it. I think I comment on the on his Destiny
clears his name YouTube video and my comment got deleted. He'll
delete Descent where he can or go after people in the comments
when he doesn't control.
Oh, dude. Dude, the Destiny clears his name video is so embarrassing.
He's actually being like a total lull cow and all we need is
like some bigger YouTubers to pick up on it and start farming
him. Like he is he is so farmable right now. Like the he's doing
is so embarrassing. If you go we could we could pull this stuff
up too. I might leave this for tomorrow. But what we should do
is we should just go look at the Keles manifesto and go look
at every defense he used for himself and show how it applies
one to one to me. He is Keeffles right now. Okay, we're about
to find out that the last he leaked, okay, of somebody is himself
doing fart. Okay, that's like that's how Keles he is right now.
He's going to start doing streams where he tases himself for
subs. It's over, right? He is just Keffeles. I don't know how
he let himself become Keeles, but he is. >> What did the
judge say about if you're continuously interacting with someone
and responding and going back to them, this does not matter?
>> You're asking me what he said? >> Yeah. What did
he say about that? I pleaded the fifth.
>> That's your defense. Oh, you said plead the fifth. >> I
plead the fifth. I plead the fifth. >> I'm wondering if
she'll remain quiet for what I have to say. Okay. So, she said
>> I mean, you didn't remain quiet for anything I had to
say or answer the questions. Like, >> if we start right
now, >> go ahead Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead. And then I'm going
to record the recording of him pinning me down. >> No,
we're good. We'll start new new new uh brand new click right
now. But anyways, I uh you know, I guarantee she won't be able
to do it. But so,
>> um, no, your boy Ski, we we found you in the the comments.
Actually, >> I remember pulling up one of your comments.
It was a good comment. >> Basically, she said that since
I kept coming back, that means that whatever
uh type of things that might have been illegal doesn't mean anything.
So, I just have a question. If you or a victim goes back to their
abuser multiple times and they get, you know, let's say abused
in some type of way every time, does that just negate whatever
happened to them? Does that mean that nothing actually happened
to them just cuz they went back? Does that mean that no crimes
were committed? If >> No, absolutely not. Just like none
of the crimes you committed also aren't negated. Absolutely not.
You're absolutely right. >> Notice how you interrupted
me. >> No, I just agreed with you. Absolutely right. Just
like the crimes you've committed, Sean. Just like the crimes
you've committed, even staying here all this time when you're
not supposed to. >> You're just bluffing. >> No,
you were freaking out about staying here all this time because
you're illegally supposed to stay with your >> Recordings
of you
admitting that you held me against my will. >> I didn't
hold you against your will. I stood in front of the door >> and
blocked my exit. >> Okay. And then you left. >> Yeah.
Once you moved away. So, >> and then you left. So, therefore,
you were not held against your will. I prevented you from leaving
while I was trying to talk. Then I got out of your way and you
left.
And then you left. I I only prevented you from leaving until
we were finished talking. >> Then you came back. >> That's
all I needed. >> And you left. Yeah, that's all you needed.
And then you left because you were free to leave and then you
came back. Make that make sense. >> I moved out the way.
>> You left. I moved out the way. You left and then you
came back.
>> You realize you just admitted again, >> I didn't
admit anything. I stood in front of a door just like people who
press each other stand in front of the door. took my ID so that
I couldn't leave and go get a hotel. >> And I have the
messages where I said I didn't take your ID. I was mocking the
way you were pretending that I did to prevent you from leaving,
dude. >> Uh, no. The messages I saw seem pretty conclusive
that she took it and she literally said why she took it. >> The
rest of those texts. You only showed one part. You didn't show
the other part. Then you're like, "You're lying. You actually
did take it. You forgot I have all that, too." Right. >> That's
fine. >> You're just like when you were looking for your
wallet yesterday, freaking out about it. And I was like, "I didn't
touch your wallet. It's probably on the counter. Where was it?
On the counter or on the thing by the TV. You knew where it was.
>> That's fine. I'll send a screenshot for Anthony to put
on stream right now. >> Okay. And send the rest. Send all
of it. >> You made a mistake getting on a call with me.
>> No, I didn't.
>> Yeah, you did. >> Sean, no, I didn't. >> [__]
out of yourself.
>> What did you say to leave? I said you're going to incriminate
the out of yourself and you are too stubborn to >> Sean.
This guy's so zed out. It's crazy. Whenever he's whenever he's
on anything, he's just always so zansed out all the >> You're
going to prison. >> Anthony, can you please put that on
the stream if you want? >> Do I have both y'all consent
to put it on the stream? >> No, you can put it on the screen
and and I'mma put the rest up there too after >> Yep. Let's
play all the recordings.
>> No.
Uh-oh. I
This is crazy because I think Zena would be 100%
I've seen Zena show some bluffs that are like absolutely out
of this world where she like she says she has proof of something
and it's like not even close to the proof of the thing she says.
So I'm I'm leaning a little more towards
towards Shuy here to be honest. I think Zena kind of she decides
this is what stuff means and she'll like move forward with that
at the time, right? She's like, "This is what this means." And
she'll post it and she'll It'll not say what she said says it
said. So, I haven't seen that from Shuy yet. Let's
>> I don't even know what they're going to try to put on
this >> except you wanted to hide the booty stuff. You
didn't want to admit to that. You keep saying you had nothing
to hide, but you were hiding everything all
>> I'm not going to argue against senseless
>> But you keep saying that you didn't want to hide, but
you were hiding everything. >> I know you was on the stream.
>> Yes, Sean. I have I have the rest of those too where
I mocked and I said because I'm selfish and afraid to lose you
and I said I thought it was smart to hide your ID. Uh-huh. That's
because you were saying I did that. Right. That's because you
were saying I did that. Where's the rest of the messages, Sean?
Where I said I didn't actually do that. Where I told you I didn't
hide your ID. Show those messages too. >> Show me. Why
don't you >> You have them, Sean. >> That's your
job to defend yourself. That's your job, Cena. >> All right.
Where's my other phone? I'm going to show it all. >> I
presented the evidence. You present your defense. >> Why
don't you just show it?
>> I told you it was a mistake during this call. I'm going
to cut that. >> No, you're just a [__] Se >> Sorry,
I went and got some caffeine. Dude, what? >> And you forgot
cuz we got other people >> that the phrasing of that. Uh,
it's not my job to defend you. He's not saying that didn't happen,
right? He's not saying you're lying right now. He's saying it's
your job to present that. Actually, I'm not my job to present
that >> involved in that situation, too. >> You liked
controlling the narrative when it was just you talking and you
got to >> "Hey, controlled in the narrative. You already
showed that in your Discord. You're not showing nothing new.
Do you think I'm afraid of this?" That's the funny thing. I'm
not You are shook right now because I admitted that I put up
your ass and you let me talk about you got nothing to hide. Okay.
And >> again, I'm not going to >> I'm not going to
I think he means baseless, guys. He means baseless. He doesn't
mean senseless. He means
>> Senseless claims. Now they're senseless claims, Sean.
But that's what's got you so mad right now.
>> I'm not mad. >> Oh, yeah. >> I'm just going
to let you incriminate yourself. I'm not incriminating myself,
>> Okay. Well, you're also showing no proof for the >> uh
because I'm scrolling through my laptop because remember you
took control of my iPhone so that you could delete all our text
messages. Remember the screenshot of you taking control of my
iPhone? The screen recording of you deleting our messages. I
have to go through my phone. No, I have to go through my laptop
because you took control of my phone to delete things out of
my phone. You know that.
>> You know that. >> You say something. >> Yeah.
All right, let's click this. What about uh when we were in uh
Dream Hack? Where was it? Dallas. And I tried to leave and you
you know you were taking out all my stuff out of my packed bag
so that I couldn't leave. >> You mean like videos of me
throwing my ex's stuff all around when he would do that to me
and I would throw his stuff all around? I know about that. Throwing
[__] around. You mean like you did to me too? Yeah.
And >> your your Did you just bring up cuz your ex did
it to you that that means >> I said I did it to my ex.
I'm saying those videos of me like throwing stuff around with
my ex. >> Even better. Okay. Okay. So, you're a repeat
offender. All right. Thank you. >> Yeah, I'm a repeat offender
just like >> Thank you. Thank you. >> Gun in your
car, by the way. >> Bird. Uh, what about when you tried
to grab my dick and try to seduce me to stay with you and try
to >> Really? What about all the times you did that? And
we have those recordings as well. In fact, you had to record
me say that you did. Pause. Why are you talking over me? Why
are you talking over me? Why are you talking over me? You had
to get a video recording. You had to get consent of me saying
you didn't me because you pinned me down the night before and
were real pushy trying to me after Hannah's birthday party and
we had issues and I didn't want to you because I was very upset
with how you behaved and what you did and yeah and then you started
recording me so we both recorded and I still explained what happened
and you said nah you weird you weird huh why did I have to consent
to you recording me to say that you didn't me >> I don't
know what is that what is that >> I don't I'll be honest
the way she presented that it sounds like like he got pushy during
and then she was probably okay with it afterwards or didn't want
to break up and like he was like, "Okay, well, I need you to
say it wasn't." That's what it sounds like. Like it was like
something in a gray area, right? And she wasn't necessarily like
mad at him. She's like, "Okay, I'll say that to you or something."
>> What does that say? That says how many times you did
to me and initiated
with me when I was mad at you. Yeah, we both did that. Yes, I
can I can confirm that we both did that. I can confirm that multiple
times. You would grab my body. You would touch on me when I would
say I don't want to. And then you would convince me to. Yeah,
you did. >> You're nothing if you don't. >> Sean,
we talk about it in messages, too. What are you talking about?
>> Okay. So, where's >> Open your entire phone? No.
Why don't you open your entire phone right now? Just put it on
screenplay. Just messages with us. Just messages with us. Just
messages with us. >> Wait, my phone screen can be seen.
Which one? Oh, [__] My bad. >> You're fumbling,
bro. You're fumbling. >> I'm not fumbling. And you think
I did.
>> this is one of the best debate tactics. You lost. You
lost. It's over. You lost. You lost.
>> You lost. I won. >> I don't give a show everything.
Post all the recordings. Like I said, post all the recordings.
Sean, >> I literally just showed proof. >> Post all
of it. >> You admitted that you held me against your will.
You said >> I didn't hold you against your will, Sean.
You left that same night. You're missing a big
>> I just held you there until we were done talking and
then you got to leave. You left the same night. I didn't hold
you against your legal mistake talking. >> No, I'm not.
You left that night, Sean. Didn't you Sean, you literally tried
to and coerced me to make legal actions and get someone arrested
on your behalf. You coerced me and I have it in messages. You
coerced me to get a man arrested on your behalf.
>> Yeah. And you know that. >> And you know that.
And you know Oh, wait. Why did I close this? cuz I actually needed
those messages. And you know that you predicted that I would
do this, right? Because why would you predict it if it wasn't
a thing? >> I predicted that you would do this.
>> I'm still waiting for proof of your >> Oh, I'm
scrolling through it. He said you can see it all on the screen
right now. You can record all of Oh, wait. That's legal stuff.
Wait, that's nudes. That's us sending nudes. Don't show
>> She talking about Darius. She's talking about Shuy.
She's talking to Shuy. Jesus. I have to scroll this stupid [__]
on my laptop cuz he wanted to control my phone to delete stuff,
you know, to protect himself is what he said. So that he can
narrate things in his way, which is fine. What he should be doing,
by the way, is instead of him trying to do it this way, he should
already like call the police. You should just call the police
right now, actually. Yeah. No, actually that's what you should
do right
>> No, you should. >> No, I'm going to sue you.
You're going to sue me >> and Ire
and you're going to dig yourself. >> Continue to do what?
I'll continue to do what? Cuz weren't you the one that got on
the internet and started posting stuff about me? >> I'm
still waiting for that. >> You went on the internet and
started posting stuff about me, right? >> I sent it on
a screenshot, by the way. It's not crazy. It's just me predicting
that she would try to say this. It was obvious to me from a mile.
>> Sorry. Sorry. >> Yeah. Another screenshot of you
predicting that Shu is the one that made me get the restraining
order. I didn't even want one. Okay. Why did you have to predict
that? Wait, is this is this is >> you saying you >> But
why did you have to predict that? Like, I don't know what you're
trying to prove with saying you predicted that I would admit
to something when I already showed the messages of you literally.
>> I mean, I'm not trying to prove anything other than
what you would try to attack me with when I leave you was obvious
to me from a mile away before it ever even happened. This was
July 24th. I can show proof that I did on my stream, but the
date is further up. You can't show it on >> Okay, Sean,
but you did you did do that. So, why? Like, I don't understand.
Is this supposed to be bad that I listened to you and got the
protective order? Still waiting for the proof of me allegedly
holding you against your vote. By the way, still waiting. >> What
do you mean? >> I mean, we still have yet to see any proof.
I've shown a lot of proof. >> I mean, yeah, Sean, you have.
And in fact, you pulled me How about even in the streets? You
pulling me away from people when I'm interacting with people.
Like with Merc. You literally grabbed me and pull me the out
the way and not let me talk to people cuz you don't want me talking
to people. >> What are you saying? >> Stop acting
like you're not just as violent. You need to stop that. >> You
know what?
>> He hearsay, right? And that's why you wanted to delete
stuff out my phone so that you could control the narrative. Thank
you. >> I'll be honest. Um, this breakup sucks compared
to any Xenadarius breakup. Dude, this is this is not good. >> They're
waiting for proof. >> Still waiting for proof. I'm looking
at all our messages. I'm just gonna I'm gonna just record the
whole thing and leak our entire messages. >> It might have
been split kitty lit. It might have been Darius a little bit.
>> Oh, you got mad. Here's another thing. You got mad because
I posted cutting people off like vermin and you texted to me
mad and asking why I turned my location off. I had to keep my
location on while I was with you. >> Oh my god. You I asked
you to keep your location on. Damn, you really could. Why did
I have to keep my location on when I was with you all the time?
When I call you, you better answer. >> I had to keep on
red receipts. >> And there you go. >> You went through
my phone every single day. Why? It kind of sounds like um I don't
know. Things weren't working. And I think it was pretty bad.
Excuse me. >> Or Hold on. I think um apparently we should
switch over to Anony's POV for this call cuz Anony's the person
who's got it up on his monitor. So if we switch to his POV for
the actual call, he'll have like the screenshots the whole time
as well.
You went on the internet and started posting stuff about me,
right?
>> There's a little bit I would admit >> me allegedly
holding you against your will. By the way, I'm still waiting.
>> What do you mean? You could control the >> illegal,
bro. They're about to lock me the up. >> I mean, you are
getting locked up, but not for this. You're getting locked up
for the stupid You already did. That happened way before.
>> No, I just said you're not getting locked up for anything
here. None of us are. I mean, what? Are you going to make up
slander? >> I'm a little worried now. >> You sound
a little worried now. >> Oh, I ain't worried. Like I said,
call the cops right now. Call the cops right
>> Call the cops right now. I'm looking at stuff and I'm
showing it right now. >> No, I'm not going to call the
cops. >> What do you guys like better? That we would have
like the full screenshots here or do you like better that we
um
that we have Zena's voice in real time with her actual camera.
>> No, just call the cops. Well, then do it right now on
the phone. Even do it right the lawyer at 2 a.m. Are you >> Should
I try to Should I try to go grab it on? >> Don't you have
lawyers on retainer? Don't you have access? >> How do you
not have a lawyer on >> Nope. How do you not have a lawyer
on retain lawyers? >> I have lawyers for specific states.
Should have known that I should have had a lawyer before. [__]
wrong. Hold >> on, Anthony. I'm going send this to you.
>> It's like hard to get all of this cuz I'm happy to get
off my computer. >> Are you going to send it to the group
chat or you just going to send it to him cuz you don't want me
to delete it, >> No, I'm sending it to the group chat >> even
though it's supposed to be proof against me. >> No, I'm
just sending the messages of what you do.
>> All right. I have I have I can show this >> like
you're still like it's in reply to >> audio is a little
better, but it's like you like
you know you did. You know you did. Going to rig up how he talked
out how he talked to me outside. Should I? I mean, he's already
getting arrested. Lol. This deputy probably already said something.
>> Yes. Add to it. Why wouldn't you make the judge go judge
more mad at him and go harder on him and put it on record? So,
this is Shuy telling her to do this. Yeah. This is Shuy telling
her to do >> What you told me to have that. >> So,
this is basically Zena saying, "Look, you say like I was the
person who did this. You had no part in this, but here you are
coaching me to get Darius in even more trouble." Where's actually
where's the other phone for for the Aiden Ross thing where he
said make sure he gets arrested before the Aiden Ross event.
He needs this. Is >> this your proof of me committing a
>> Did I ever say you committed a crime? You're the one
making those claims. By all means, collect all the data you need.
I will give you whatever data you need. Guess what? Guess what?
I've done take that data, too. I did not say you >> because
Zena can't stop winning. Zena always wins in the end. It's all
It's all Zena all the way down. Yeah. You want data? I did. >> A
crime, Sean. The only thing I am talking about, I'm not trying
to [__] you over. The only thing I am talking about
is that you are a liar and you lied for months to your community
about what was really going on in the fact that I was pegging
you. That's about it. >> Yeah, you were definitely pegging
me. >> Why you buy? Why did you buy me, >> dude?
Kick is totally right now. By the way, my my viewership numbers
are going like up down up down up down crazy. Like 700 550 700
550 and the chat is like not showing up at all. >> The
strap on Sean, >> what is going on? >> You're claiming
>> I don't give a [__] Why did you uh buy the
strap?
Why did you buy the strap on? >> The fact that you have
to resort to trying to make up slander things. You don't need
to make up. Why did you buy the strap on? Why did you buy the
strap on? Like you're talking over me instead of answering the
question because you know. Why did you buy the strap on? >> But
we're still waiting for proof. This has nothing to do with the
proof. >> You never said you committed crimes. What proof?
What? What? I didn't say you committed a crime. Sean, >> you
said I held you against your will. >> Yeah. Sean, you blocked
me from leaving my [__] room multiple times. Yes.
And like you played that one recording when it was going off.
Why are you talking over me when I'm talking? This is what you
do when you lie. >> Hello. Are you up and let me talk?
Are you going to let me Zena? >> He's too about to get
He's about to get on. Why Zena got bought a strap on? Okay. Not
good. >> Why did you stop the other recording? Why did
you stop the other recording when I was going off on you and
you were like, "Oh, you're so quick to give up. Wanted it to
be forever, by the way." Why' you stop those recordings when
you also try to make me not leave multiple times? Why'd you stop
that? Why didn't you just play that whole thing? >> No.
Play any recording you. Oh, you have the recording and you started
to play it on your stream and then you had to mute it and turn
it down and put it in your ear because you realized what you
were saying. Play the whole recording. Play the whole recording.
>> We're all waiting for >> Play the whole recording.
>> Play the whole recording. Cuz you were playing it earlier.
>> Are you talking about when he said it was going to be
cringy and he stopped the recording midway? Is that that you're
talking about? >> That's what I'm talking about. There's
been multiple times where he's prevented me to leave. I'm not
going to sit here and be like, "Oh, you held me hostage." Like,
I didn't hold him hostage. He obviously had left multiple times
and has been able to leave multiple times just like he's gone
now. There's no holding hostage. The doors are not locked. I'm
4 foot 11. I am 4 foot 11. This man is 6'4. He might be skinny
like asing whatever, but he can walk out. And he has walked out.
>> It's a pretty good point. >> To realize that even
if you hold someone against their will or Zena fails to realize
that even if you hold someone against their will for a couple
minutes and they leave afterwards that that's still a crime.
I don't know. >> Okay, so call the police because guess
what, Sean? You illegally recorded me in the state of Miami.
So that can't even be used as evidence. Just so you know, you
can't record two party without consent.
So, what are you talking about?
>> the state of Miami. >> I actually have no idea
what you're talking about. In the state of Miami, it is a two-
party.
>> Curious. I wonder where Zena might have learned this
from. >> So, what what did you what what >> where's
um where's the video of Zena telling Lauren De Laguna that she
doesn't care what the law is, you should be able to record in
your own house. Does Zena forget that she argued that with Lauren
De Laguna when she was defending Destiny from her?
>> Uh-oh. You're allowed to record someone committing a
crime.
>> I hope you get a really good lawyer then. Then I just
hope you get a really good lawyer. I don't know what else like
what else do you want me to say? >> State of Miami, by
the way.
>> Oh, whatever. State of Florida. >> Miami, by the
way. >> You're the last one to try to make fun of anybody's
intelligence. Sean, I think we've already known how stupid you
are. You came back to this, by the way, for >> I'm 19 years
old and clearly >> You're 19, but Sean, you're you're actually
kind of slow. >> He's he's >> you're 19 and you're
letting a 30-year-old Only Fans up your ass and you're too scared
to admit it and you want to say it's claims it's slander, but
you did something illegal. You jumped to the law. >> She
got a real strap on and a brain strap on. Okay. She's mentally
this guy in the ass as well. It's not good >> stuff when
I start to talk about your booty. Like be real, dude. You ced
off stream and now you want to press charges. Press charges.
Press charges so we can sit in the courtroom so it can look just
like my just like the courtroom looked with me and my ex and
the judge being like, "You both are stupid." Yes, please do it.
Get your lawyer. I'm not shook. Just do it. Like I'm laughing,
buddy. I've done way worse than that. I went to prison. I've
done way worse. Like you really need to just Let's just do it,
dude. Just do it. Just do it. That's what you need to do. Just
do it. >> She's 11 years older. Yeah. And >> Lena,
the thing is you wish that we were >> do it. Also, I do
want to I do want to wish you luck. Hey. So, I do wish >> it's
it's like up to have this leaked, but like I All he had to do
is go, you know what?
I I'm out. I'm not I'm not responding. I'm just
He got in a call with Zena. How are we How are you going to go?
She's 11 years older after this guy goes and tells Zena on this
call. Zena, you're going to You regret getting on this call with
me. I'm totally I'm totally dominating you, Zena. I'm I'm totally
winning right now, Zena. You lost. Zena, you're going to incriminate
yourself. You're going to regret getting on this call. And now
he's getting destroyed. >> Look at Brandice. Are you going
to learn how to box? >> The funny part is you wish that
we both look stupid in this situation, but in reality, you're
the only one that looks >> You're going to look like a
look stupid. You lied to your community. Dude, I
like I agree Zena could look stupid in this situation, but unfortunately
you got in a call with her and she's way better at talking than
you.
And incriminate >> I'm not incriminating. You're making
about me and I said do what you have to >> Thank you for
at least what you have to >> Thank you for making me realize.
Oh, wanted it forever by the way. Here, let's go back to that
language. Wanted it to last, by the way. Said she loved me, by
the way. Said she loved me. She didn't really love me. Like,
why use >> Notice how you changed the subject from the
proof that you apparently had. I didn't say I had proof of you
holding me hostage. I said I have our messages. I have the conversations
of us talking about everything. And I do. >> You changed
the subject and you >> Wait, pause, pause, pause. Okay.
Are you not Are you not getting legal stuff involved? Cuz
>> did you not say that? Are you not going to take legal
action? Yes or no? You said you're taking legal action, right?
So now that means that your lawyer will now have to contact my
lawyer and all the evidence will be put in the box. Why >> Hold
on. Did end up talking to his uh to Stardust?
Give me a second. Did Moro end up talking to her? Cuz moral said
he was going to talk to Stardust and I don't know if he actually
ended up doing it. Let's see. Let's see if he started to talk
to her.
>> Is this just my broken or
>> Oh, it was okay. Okay. >> With like, you know,
>> this is just
me talking to me. >> I'm totally not like attracted to
>> Yeah, I mean
>> Oh, so apparently he's going to talk to Stardust. He's
just waiting. No, she declined. Wait, I thought she I thought
she did not decline. Okay, well I think she did not decline.
I think she is actually going to end up on there, but I'm going
to leave this up. We'll keep watching this until starts. >> Like,
why would it be on stream? No, I'm just going to repeat my whole
phone. I'm going to Google Drive my whole phone and record it
all. I have Jerry Corrigio and Robert Trackman still to this
day, though. I have two lawyers on
>> and you think I'm scared. I never committed a crime.
>> You didn't say you were scared. You want to shake somebody,
but you're a twink. You don't shake nobody. Sean, >> sorry.
Apparently, apparently moral is going to talk to Stardust, but
the Willy Mac video I Okay. >> You apparently got allegedly
you got held hostage. No, no, no, no. You allegedly got held
hostage by a 4-11 chick. You left. You were safe multiple times.
You had your own car. You were safe at home with your mother
in Virginia and yet you drove 24 hours straight here. So, I I
really don't know what you're going to like like what this is.
What? And I get it. I mean, listen. I know how to real good.
I know you came back to to let me put that toy in your that detail
scene on the sink. But like, yeah, you drove you you're this
victim and you drove 24 hours to come get pegged. Like, okay,
tell the judge that. Get your lawyer. >> Not just grab
your own toys and try to say that you used the money, >> Sean.
You know, we used them. That's what got you so mad. >> Do
you think the fact that you >> The funny thing is is anybody
else I would make if I was making this up and I was like, "Oh,
I you in the ass" or whatever. Like if if like Dan for example,
he's going to be like and I liked it and what? Nobody else is
going to crash out. >> That's not true. That's not true.
>> I mean, >> is his thing is his thing cutting out,
Anthony, or is it >> It's cuz it's cuz the dude got like
a $30 motel room with bad internet. I wish you didn't do
>> Yeah, you're lagging a bit. You've >> just convenient.
He starts lagging about the buttload. >> Oh, I don't know.
I don't I don't think Stardo is actually going to talk to him,
>> It's not The thing is The thing is he's taking offense
to it. It's not even offense. We just >> Can you hear me?
>> Yeah, we can hear you now. Maybe maybe switch to like
>> I think if I'm not mistaken it seems like probably Stardust
told him she was going to talk and then basically just lied and
is trying to like make him think that they might talk. >> Kind
of weird but >> uh phone signal instead of Wi-Fi if you're
on Wi-Fi or do the opposite. That would be >> fun. I forgot.
Hold on. Just as a as an aside, I forgot um
some dude from Auggie's audience.
I was watching this Auggie stream last night and I noticed this
screenshot.
Um, this was Cherry and Jay-Z are my favorite interracial couple
and Cherry tweeted it.
I found the perfect clip to respond to this with. I'm sorry.
I thought it's perfect. >> You think that >> Hold
on. Hold on. >> And if you think that black girls are bad
sometimes, but also you're racist, then follow me. That's that's
really the message of the show. And that's really the message
of this movement. And if you think that >> is that not
is that not exact? Is that not on the money? Is that not perfect?
Oh my god. Listen, I wasn't a fan of this guy, but he kind of
he's kind of spinning right now. >> Are bad sometimes,
but also you're racist. Then follow me. >> That's that's
really the message of the show and that's really the message
of this movement.
>> And Wy.
>> So true. >> Yeah, that's is that him or is that
me? >> That's him. That's him. Definitely 100%. One second.
>> I sent a message told me to switch 5G or >> You
guys can't hear me? >> We can hear you. It's just a little
delayed. I can hear you now. I'll put it in the chat for you
guys. >> All right. Well, uh, yeah. I mean, I don't really
have anything to say. I >> can you hear me right now, Shie?
>> Uh, can you guys hear me right now? >> Yeah. Yeah,
I can hear you guys >> Oh, okay. >> I can uh try
using my phone hotspot. One >> Oh,
apparently. Um, very Guys, I'm just I'm just trolling.
LFAO. Guys, who's here? I'm trolling the out of this morale guy.
I told him I'd be there in 5 minutes. Uh, you're on your way,
right? I'd hate to be dishonest to whoever this morale guy is.
I'm totally on my way metaphorically. Okay, the goofing around
is over. It's Patrick Page season.
Uhoh. Is this like Stardust Community or something? Getting sent
some screenshots.
What is this from? Uh,
okay. So, she ran, I guess. I guess she she ran, I guess. Sus
has a community. Well, it's a couple guys. Isn't being isn't
that being mean? Hypocrite.
Uh, I'm not sure Stardust understands the distinctions. Like,
I'm not sure she understands this could be quote unquote mean.
That's grim. I to I mean, in her defense, okay, the death nail
for a Cheeto is getting totally dogwalked by Moral when Moral
called him like
I forget what Moral's exact accusation against a Cheeto was,
but I remember watching a Cheeto and Moral argue over it and
a Cheeto got totally walked on it. Like totally dogwalked. So
Mal's Mal shouldn't be underestimated. Okay.
All six Stardust fans found that joke hilarious.
Oh,
sad. I was hoping I just get like uh some content,
but unlucky. >> I don't know how to make a hotspot on Android
or how to find the password for >> It's got to be settings
and then >> text Wi-Fi hotspot. Maybe I've never used Android
either. >> It just so me. He slammed you in front of three
people. I didn't slam him. I'm not going to say bad stuff about
him, >> but you're making things up. >> I didn't
make it up, Sean. And you know, >> kind of kind of what
that's like, I >> We had some kinky,
>> Sean. Okay. So, why'd you buy me the >> You You
bought that? >> I bought that.
Show your card history, >> Yeah. You know what?
>> I bought that. >> Oh, did she buy it with his
credit card? Did she buy it with his credit card? And she knows
that. >> Show my card history. >> That you forgot
that we were there together, right? Show my car history for >> Show
my card history for when? >> Why don't you show it? >> I
said for when? >> He said I bought it cuz I can show my
card history and I can show that I haven't bought a damn thing
at a shop in how long?
>> I can show my bank. Actually, I have my bank statements
because I'm doing my tax. So yeah, I mean yeah, I can have my
tax guy actually
show that I didn't go to a shop and buy any toys. So and I have
like the photos of when we got the stuff and everything too.
So yeah. Um yeah, I can show my bank statements and show that
I never bought this stuff. What? >> I mean, I don't know
why you're arguing about anything when we still >> No.
Why is No, no, no, no, no. Don't don't don't change the Don't
change the goal post. Don't change the go. You're the one that's
changing it. If you ask right now saying I don't know why you're
arguing about it. >> You said you have me on holding you
hostage. Cool. Take legal action with that. That no longer needs
to be discussion. Take legal action now. Tell me why the [__]
you need to feel that you need to maintain power. All right.
Yes or no? Do you want her to show proof of her claims, chat?
Yes or no? Do you want her to show proof of her claims? >> I've
been showing proof. I'm still leaking everything. Look at him.
Yes or no, chat? Yes or no, chat? That's all he cares about is
>> look at you gonna go look what they >> I'm not
[__] Wait, I'm scrolling through the photos of receard
fan here checking in. >> Buddy, I ain't even on no chat.
And on here is our text messages from day one. Wait, where am
I looking at the chat? Show the computer. >> Chat ain't
even open. >> Still waiting. >> Chat ain't even open.
Wait, what are you waiting on now? What are you waiting on? >> You're
in a like good position right now. Like you look like a >> That's
what you're worried about and that's why you're doing all of
this, Sean. You are doing PR cuz you care about your image so
bad and you care about what everybody thinks about you. I don't
give a [__] what people think about me. Why do you
think I portray myself as crazy? I am crazy. I do dumb ass. Okay,
you're cleaning up. As soon as someone said they put their finger
in the toy up your ass, you shook and you talk about legal. You
care about your image. What?
How dare you try to flip that on me, boy? You literally all the
time say you're young and impressional and yeah, you care about
the chat and you admit that to multiple people. So, why are you
even acting like that's not the case? >> I mean, whatever
you're saying kind of goes out the window when you can't even
convey yourself calmly.
>> That's not true either, Sean. You're the one getting
emotional and agitated. >> I'm laughing at you.
>> Just makes >> because you actually got mad. You
literally got mad over this stuff. >> You realize everyone's
still waiting for >> Wait. Proof of what? You just keep
saying proof. Proof of what? Be specific. I never said you did
anything illegal. So why would they need to
>> I have recordings of situations between us. Yes. But
I'm not talking about holding you against your will. >> Yeah.
So I guess we will use that in court, right? >> You Yes,
you did. You said >> So I guess we will use that in court,
right? Is he I held you against your court case right now? Are
we having the >> I like that. That was like Dude, that
sounded like she did like an aside. Is she Is he like like to
her chat? I don't even know >> right now or >> I
don't think she's even live. Oh, it's detent chat. >> I
held you against Jesus. >> What is the data going out?
>> Yeah, you're lagging again. >> There you go. >> Wait,
what? >> I mean, >> did I say I recorded you holding
me against my will? Did I say I record? Whoa. So close. >> That
is what you said. Our tape's almost just on the screen. I did
not say I recorded you holding me against my will. I said I recorded
us talking about that >> No, the recording is the one where
you tried to record. No, no, no. The recording is me explaining
how you pinned me down. I have that recording how you pinned
me down and we talked about that and I had to tell you that and
I had to record that. Oh, and I had to record No, you got that
as well. And I had to record and say you didn't rape me. We have
that. >> Oh [__] I didn't realize how far back
I
>> You have proof, right? So why not show me? Why not show
everyone that I'm this terrible person? Or is all you can say
that you >> Who said you're a terrible person? That's the
thing. Who said that? >> Sorry. The morph thing got me.
>> No, it just means you're pushy. It just means you were
being pushy. >> Although, it's possible we didn't loop
>> And you were. >> She doesn't have her laptop out.
When she said that before, she had her laptop out, right? Oh,
our tapes are on there. >> Your claim. >> Okay. I'm
not backing up. >> No, Sean. I'm not. Now, listen. Why
did you have to record me to say I didn't Why are you talking
over me? Why are you talking over me? Why did you have to record
me to say I didn't or to say you didn't me? >> I don't
know, Zena. Maybe that's something you should be asking yourself.
Maybe cuz I thought that's that's because you're that type of
person, >> bro. I'm like, uh, I'm spun around. I don't
know what's going on. >> And why did you have to keep ending
the recording? Because I was explaining what you did do to me
and I recorded it. >> I don't know what you're talking
about. I'm still asking you to show the recordings.
Yes, you do. >> You're not credible until you show at least
one thing of proof. >> We have a whole bunch of, Sean,
and you know it. >> So, why don't you show everyone? I'm
not the one scared to show proof. You are. >> I'm not afraid.
You are. Sean, you didn't want me to leak stuff. What are you
talking about? You got upset that I leaked the love stuff. Can
you mute him so I can start playing these audio? >> I showed
I showed the messages. I even said she's going to pull up messages
from me. >> He exposed the messages. No, he didn't. You
started talking and then I started
>> You're not credible. You've shown zero proof of anything.
>> I'm showing I'm showing stuff right now. I'm literally
pulling stuff up, dumb >> Whenever you want to do it. Yeah,
we can do a a lower volume. >> How she's resorting to name
calling? I haven't done that one time, by the way. Zena in shambles.
I ain't going to lie. >> Oh, no, I'm not. I'm playing the
audio. You think I'm in? >> Ever happened to that spinning
character? I don't know. I'm a little bit nervous. You >> I'm
not nervous, but I know you want me to be. I want you to do this.
Go ahead. Like, you don't shake me. My ex could shake me, but
you don't. >> I mean, what you want me to like what? Hopelessly
be obsessed with you.
>> My ex shake me. You don't, John. Like, you don't. >> Ain't
nobody crashing out over you, bro. You're not like that. >> I
don't give a Sean. You get >> You're 29 years old. >> Wait,
I'm recording. You holding me down and you're talking over me
when I said get off of me. >> All right, let's see it.
>> on detents. >> Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if you
can even hear it. I might have to like clip it and stuff cuz
>> this guy drama. Uh, I don't know what this guy's This
guy's involved right now. He's like um he's like Ice Boseidon's
former roommate, right? He's the guy who actually the stream
I got banned from YouTube for was uh was one where this guy was
bullying Darius. Remember that's this guy. >> Stuff does
happen, so I don't want to >> I can always clip it on the
back end if you send it through the the group chat. >> M
just said stop. Move over. >> I can always clip it on the
back end.
>> Hold on. Hold on. >> N just said stop.
Move over.
Good night, Sean. >> I'm saying good night cuz I don't
want to up. >> Stop. Wait. Oh, there it is. I'm saying
stop. Hold on. Let me run it the back. >> You're not going
to believe it. You're not going to believe it. >> Not going
to believe what? What's up? >> While I was reacting to
her VODs, guess what she was doing? Guess what she did? >> What's
that?
>> I I'll send you her channel right now. I don't I want
you to I I'll send you those. This is her channel. Notice how
there are uh there are no VODs available. Go ahead and take a
peek. Thank you for the 50, Hannah. I appreciate it. >> This
is very kind. What? You have fifth? Oh, hold on. Whoever that
person is, kick.com/glk, if you want to come join my community,
be cool. >> Uh, you mean she used to have live VODs and
now they're all gone? So, she private all her vods while you
were
>> She privated them all as I was watching
>> That's funny. >> So, she said, and to be clear,
in our DMs, she said, um, she made a retraction. She said, um,
you know, if you saw a little bit further in the stream, I absolutely
owned up to partaking in what you're talking about. And I said,
okay, can you send me a time stamp? And she said, "I stream for
8 hours. Why the am I going to time stamp ship for you when your
instinct is to jump on stream and about me like a baby, lump
foul?"
So she tells me to go look for it myself basically and then private
them. So I can't look for it. I can't find it. >> Uh, okay.
Yeah, she's kind of the worst. I don't know if you didn't know
this. She's kind of the worst. >> I knew nothing about
her. I knew that Queen hated her. That is the extent of it. And
she's in my chat right now like coping about removing her VODs.
I I feel like I'm not Listen, I feel like this is like some of
the most like cowardly pathetic behavior I have ever seen. Uh
I I sent you those Did you pull up those those three screenshots
I sent you? >> Yeah, we just we're all just like uh it's
weird. >> This is just like pathetic. She's like running
to her Discord server. She's like, "Dude, look, I'm trolling
this guy." Like, dude, if you're trolling someone and you have
to go to your friends or go to your Discord server, go to your
fans, you're like, "Guys, look, I'm trolling this guy." If she
was funny, if she was funny, if she was entertaining at all,
she'd have a >> Yeah. I mean, she'd probably have VODs
up that people could look at after the fact, but >> Yeah.
I can't imagine uh somebody who's watching with like 70, 80,
60 viewers, whatever you got right now. I can't imagine taking
all my VODs down because of that one person. How many VODs does
she have? She didn't have more than like three VODs up, right?
How many VODs? >> She had she had I'd have to rewind my
stream to see. She had like a bunch up. >> I I can't imagine
privating all of my VODs because like 60 viewer streamers looking
at them. This just crazy.
>> Yeah, I know. >> I actually don't know if I'd
private them because one streamer is looking at them regardless
of size. It's weird.
>> That's it's it's very bizarre behavior. She was saying
some insane in the stream as well. But like I said, like I said
when I first called in, she was like people have been saying
I had with Destiny. I've never seen anyone say >> Like
she was she was literally just like lying in her stream to her
viewers trying to make her seem like more
>> Yeah. I I I think I made that joke. I was like I don't
think Destiny would have even you. I mean hypo someone said that.
I don't know if it was me. I don't know if it was me. Sargon
of a reference. That's a Sargon of a ref of a reference. Sargon
of a COD reference. Listen, I I don't know. This is just like
this is deplorable. I don't even know if there's much more I
can say about this. This is like disgusting. >> Uh-huh.
Uh, somebody suggested go look at Twitch. See if you get Twitch
VODs.
>> Um,
maybe. I don't know if I care that much. I I think I care to
the extent of uh Oh, she hit her VODs live while I was talking
about her. Uh, and she said she would call in and then did some
like shorting and took it back and said she was trolling. Um,
so >> I think that's probably if she Listen, I'm still
open to the She's watching the stream. She's actively talking
in my chat right now. I am still open to the conversation. I
will talk to you if you want to talk to me. I will talk to you
about Willy Mack. I will talk to you about your hip-hop for you
right now. >> There literally is nowhere further for her
to go down. So like, you know, there's not really like she there
is no she's she's at bedrock, right? She can't like hurt her
reputation or anything about herself any more than it's already
like she's already there. She's at bedrock. So, >> here's
a screen cap from my stream when I looked at her channel. >> Dude,
really? Apparently, there are a bunch of VODs that all got privated.
It's a good thing she privated that VOD that I was watching that
I wanted to watch with the um what is it? >> She watched
like one of my VODs where I talked to Sunday and she literally
didn't react to any of the points made in that entire conversation.
She just like took questions from her chat and only talk to her
chat the whole time. It's like the least transformative. I cannot
believe you talk about Caseyron and then run content that way.
It was so dumb. It's basically like background noise for her
stream.
>> Yeah. I don't know. Uh >> this is like I don't
know if she has a history of doing this stuff. Like I said, maybe
this is like for you this is just like like yeah, she does this
[__] But like for me, I've never looked into her.
I found I found her like pretty boring. So I just never watched
her content. I never watched people covering her until it was
like relevant for me >> And it was like >> it's like
Darius, right? where she has like a history of like super of
like being annoying in the least entertaining ways possible.
So when she finds a new way to be annoying in the least entertaining
way possible, everybody's like, "Of course she did it." That's
literally what she's known for, being annoying in the least entertaining
way possible. So yeah, right. It's like I don't know if she's
ever done this, but she does like adjacent behaviors all the
time. So it's like
>> This is like This is Yeah, this is shocking. This is
like this is this is I've never seen anybody do something I've
I've heard of people doing this but like you're you're you private
your VODs live how many viewers do I even have right now
like less than 50 maybe when I was covering I had like 90 I peaked
at 90 when I was covering her right and then as I've as I've
slowed down uh you know whatever I'm at 50 now and it's like
dude you you're you're worried that 90 people are seeing you
being made fun of this is like so bizarre I don't know this is
like this is this is the definition of cowardly behavior. I don't
know how she can like sleep sleep with herself at night. This
is like >> Acting like she's trolling is is probably the
worst part. Like trying to trying to do like shorting like I
was actually trolling when when you're just like completely like
spineless cowardly piece of >> uh Oh yeah. I don't think
these insults do anything to her to be honest with >> Well,
I'm mostly talking. I don't listen if if she she knows she's
a coward. If she's act like if she's privating live, she knows.
I don't think I I need to be alone to tell her. I think the only
thing that would make this better is uh is I I just want to know
if like Becket is the one that broke it off with her or if it
was her that broke it off with Becket because I think the only
way my opinion my the only way my opinion could get lower of
Becket is if I find out that she's the one that broke up with
him. I think that's kind of where I'm >> What's your problem
with Becket? What did Becket do? >> Uh Becket's also recently
just being like extraordinarily cowardly and inconsistent when
it comes to a art creator called Laio Convoy.
>> yep. I can go into it if you want, but that's the TLDDR.
Maybe I think didn't Stardust wasn't that like all of her best
condu uh content was all Leo Convoy >> Yeah, I was covering
Lio and then I started covering one of her Lio VODs and then
I looked at a recent one. That's that's why I I went and covered
it.
>> that Barbie I actually reacted to a VOD with Barbie
in it and I had some wonderful things to say about that >> that
lovely woman in that VOD. She definitely provided a lot of interesting
interesting interesting uh interesting. I will not repeat anything
on the stream. That's okay. I don't think you need to talk about
Barbie on the stream. It's fine. >> I don't even know.
I She might not be in the community anymore. I I don't know if
she's like around anymore.
>> dude. This is like so like
Why does she even stream? I think Ral and Jtock are lame. Like,
dude, why does she even >> I I don't know. >> What
is the point? What is the point? >> I I don't Yeah, I don't
know. Um >> Star dated Becca. Yeah, they were dating for
like a year. >> I couldn't tell you, man. I don't know
what she's doing. The Must have been crazy to stay with that
pause for a year. That's all I'll say. >> Jesus Christ,
dude. Could we? No. Stop.
>> All right, I'll I'll leave. I'll post your kick link
in chat. I can't raid you. Obviously, I'm on YouTube, but I'll
send people over. >> Yeah, no worries. All right, we'll
see you then. >> Bye. Love you. >> Bye.
Bye-bye. Oh, back to this. >> You talk about
>> I'm saying good night. >> Oh, right. Zena just
started playing the um Didn't you say Stylo was into Star? No,
I've never said that.
Stardust is too skinny for Styl to be into her. >> Hold
on. Hold on. >> Can I just said stop? Move over.
>> Good night, Sean. >> I'm saying good night cuz
I don't want to [__] >> Stop. Wait. Oh, there
it is. I'm saying stop. Hold on. Let me run it the [__]
back. You talking about
>> and then I'm apolog Sean. Shut the [__]
up. Mute him. Mute him. >> Uh, we should be back. We should
be back. We should be back. Are we back? I hope we're back. Are
we back? Hello. Hello. Hello.
>> For Anthony, >> guys, we're back here. >> Report
like the bar for sure. >> There you go.
>> I mean, >> did I say so? Why would they need
>> Hold on. Hold on. >> Okay.
Right here.
>> What happened? My internet dropped for some reason.
I don't know why my internet dropped, but we're back. We should
be back, right? Refresh. And we're back. Refresh. And we're back.
Refresh. And we're back. This is when ISPs do updates to their
gateways. Okay. Well, my whole internet dropped for two seconds,
but we're back. >> They actually tried to warn me. Everything
they said that was going to come true is coming true. >> She
tried to say she wouldn't do these things, but she's doing them
all. >> Here we go. >> Wait, let's run right before
that cuz I'm saying no. Hold on. All right. Now, let me start
the recording. >> We are back. Dude, it always sucks cuz
like when you die like 5 hours, 6 hours into the stream, you've
always got like 50 to 100 people, maybe more even, who are like
AFK just watching this and they walked away from their computer,
they fell asleep or whatever. And when you disconnect, everybody
has to refresh. So the viewership always drops by like 200. My
KCIP so annoying. >> Literally, right, they actually tried
to warn me. Everything they said that was going to come true
is coming true. She tried to say she wouldn't do these things,
but she's doing them all. >> Here we go. >> Just
run. Wait, let's run right before that cuz I'm saying no. Hold
on. >> All right. Now, let me start the >> We're
back. We're good. Okay, we're starting. Why the [__]
were they recording? I don't know. I actually don't know exactly
why this was being recorded to tell you the truth. Okay. I really
don't know. I can't tell you. It was bizarre. >> Good night.
Stop.
>> Good night.
>> I don't want to. >> I don't want to. >> Not
a good
It's just not the best. Okay. It doesn't sound the best. It's
like a little uh What kind of odds would you give for Darius
and Zena to be back together in
Brother, you're going 50/50 2026. I'm going 50/50 in 2025.
We got four months of 20 five months of 2025 left. I think I
I think I go Dude, Anony's face,
dude. The the the
distortion from like the pixelation here is not looking okay.
This guy looks like Quasimoto right now. Not great. Not great.
He was defending our stream like 20 minutes ago, probably. Yeah,
dude. Honestly, I might take Yeah. Sorry, Elmo. Elmo just said
it as I was saying it. It might be 50/50 odds in in August. Not
even 2025. >> Not a good idea. >> Not a good idea.
>> Is not a good idea.
So don't
>> you made things very clear and I respect >> Are
you good?
>> You're sorry.
What are you sorry? What?
>> Okay. I'm sorry.
We all know what's We all know what's happening here, right?
He wants to I don't know if it's him pushing for right now. I
think it's him pushing to like be close to each other cuz he
up and she doesn't want to be near him. Really? Is that That's
what I'm reading into this. I know it looks bad. Okay, I know
it looks bad, but to me I feel like it's somebody's giving you
the cold shoulder. I think I think that's what's happening
>> Thank you for your apology. I forgive
It doesn't work that way. And I said I forgive you, but that
doesn't mean like I'm going to just like get used. >> You
can use me also. >> I never said I just use you for
now.
So this is touching on me. >> You said earlier that you
don't win. >> Uh what is her allegation? That he was pressuring
her for is the allegation here. She has a recording of him pressuring
her for
you. Can you not see him losing this?
Do you not see us?
Don't just say you're
>> If it'll work when you raise up these girls, it'll work
on them. >> I'm promise it won't work on me. >> Sadly,
it did.
>> Back to stop.
>> that's the sounds of him kissing on me. Clearly sucking
on my >> that Jesus. This guy goes aggro as Is that what
that sound effect actually is? The Jesus, dude. What? >> I
don't have proof. By the way, let me stop this because I don't
want it to get But there's 59. Anthony, I can show you the video.
But let me just send
>> Boom. You're on. You're on. >> I'm sending a fivem
minute one of me saying stop and you're
saying sorry and
>> sorry. This is all audio from the same stream. I don't
know why it cut in like that. I don't even She's not going to
let me talk now. >> She's not going to let me talk now.
>> You deserve you deserve some stage. Yeah, for sure.
You should say what you >> Oh, was I muted during that?
Because I wasn't talking cuz I assumed I was >> No, no.
I I I knew that you weren't talking, but I just muted for better
audio. But go for >> Is there any way that she could be
muted while I talk for this? >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Since
this is serious allegations. >> Yeah. Boom. Now, she's
mute. You're good. You have the full stage. >> I feel like
I feel like Shu is going to say exactly what I what I said that
that's what happened. That doesn't necessarily make it okay.
You pro you you probably you should respect if somebody's like
not wanting to be close to you physically. You should probably
respect that. Even if you don't think it's like something you
shouldn't I don't know. There's like some there's some unspoken
thing there where like if you I don't know how to approach this.
Okay. There's like a there's like a what do you call it? An unbreakable
deadlock between I have a feeling that she's going to be angry
at me if I don't try to do anything. But also, if I if I just
go to sleep, she's going to be mad that I didn't try to fix it.
And so, there's just I don't know. You might have to keep distance
and just talk it out. I don't know. There's like something else
happening there. >> Can she be muted? Cuz I'd like to >> Well,
okay. You You're going to have to mute her your side. I'll mute
her my side and then you can talk cuz I can't administratively
mute her in here. >> Oh, okay. Okay.
>> But the stream will hear just what you're saying.
>> Yeah, true. He He seems to have gone He's gone for the
the toddler suckling move.
Very interesting. Not Not RZ I've ever tried to employ. Okay.
>> Uh I don't know how to do that. It's whatever. Um basically
this is when I was blackout drunk from the alcohol
that she gave me.
>> you can
blackout drunk. You hear in my voice I'm not talking coherently
and I'm >> That didn't sound like he was talking totally
incoherently.
>> Clearly slurring my words. So, and it sounds like she
might have pl It sounds like she might have intentionally recorded
this. And I don't know. I mean, I don't know what to say, but
I know for a fact that I was drunk off of alcohol that she gave
to me in this clip. >> He's literally going, "Is Fool under
21?" He is under 21. And she did give him alcohol,
but also
I don't know. Like, okay, I feel like that's not the first time
he's drunk. He doesn't seem to be blackout. We can watch the
end of that stream and see if he's up. What do we see him get?
Like two shots, three shots.
I don't know that I believe he was blackout drunk. Maybe we have
to hear his voice again. That looks bad on Zena. It looked bad
on Zena and people called it out in my Discord when it happened.
Are they in bars? Zena was sneaking him alcohol at a strip club
or a bar or something. Zena was actually It was like some party,
some rave or something and she was sneaking him alcohol. >> So,
I don't know. Is this the proof that you think it is, Zena? Cuz
I have messages of you talking about alcohol that you've gave
me. >> You're saying I gave you alcohol and that means
you were allowed to forcibly get on me when I kept saying stop.
>> Yeah. Like
I don't know. Can you like think about So somebody's like, "Oh,
she's older than him." And and it's like so her rep her rep so
think about what you're saying here. She's explicitly saying
stop stop. It wouldn't be okay for him to do this, right? It
it would not be okay for him to to still go after he You can't
just say I'm blackout drunk.
That can't be the defense. I Because I was blackout drunk is
not a defense, right? That we can all agree that's not a defense.
I was blackout drunk and so I couldn't respect your consent.
I don't even remember. That's not an excuse. I just hope we all
all can agree that that wouldn't be an excuse.
>> And you now you just said that you just gave you alcohol,
right? At 4:00 in the
and you're waking me up out of my sleep, but you're drunk yet
you're waking. >> Ah, was Zena waking up out of her sleep.
Well, how was she recording the second she got woken up? >> Me
up out of my >> That analogy is a little off. It's not
that far off. Like he's not actually I'm just saying that you
can't do like a consent violation and be like, "Well, I'm drunk.
That makes it okay." In this video, I confirm I'm waking up out
of my sleep saying, "I'm trying to go back to sleep." But somehow
we were drinking. How are we waking up out of sleep and now we're
drinking and you're just drunk trying to apparently me? Which
is it? >> All right. Is she unmuted on your stream now?
I >> No, she is. Now she is. Yeah, but the whole first
part you were It was just >> I'm just saying. And I could
keep playing this [__] So basically, Zena, you're
saying I you know, is that what you're saying? >> I never
No, no, no, no, no, no. I'm not saying that. I'm not even saying
that. I'm just showing the audio. I'm just showing the audio
of what happened. >> So did I. >> I don't think that
there's blurred No, it's a very She said a very firm no. No,
I don't want to. No, I'm mad. No. Like I' I've not heard it be
playful here.
I've not seen any playfulness. I also don't think it's quite
seems like he's trying to get something.
It's like not not like actual
not full on
the audio of what happened. You said you were drunk in this
Sean. You said you were apparently drunk when any of this >> It's
a simple yes or no question. Did I said that? I never said that.
I never ever It's a yes or no question. >> All I said was
you've gotten extremely pushy with me when I would tell you to
stop. So yeah, you said yes or no. So yes or no. Did I do I keep
proving to you that I do? >> So yes or no. Did I review
it? >> I don't know. What do you consider that? Should
I keep playing this? >> I don't know. What do you consider
it? Should I keep Should I just hit play >> Audio. Let's
find out. Let's actually find out.
>> Disco tactics.
Yes or no? Yes or no? Does that fit the definition of Yes or
no? Yes or no? Does that Don't Don't dodge. Don't dodge the question.
Don't touch the question. Yes or no. Does that fit the definition
of Does that fit the >> You're the alleged victim, right?
That's your decision. >> Let's find out if you me. Let's
just find out from you. >> No, I'm just going to rewind.
I'm >> rewind it. No. Why don't you keep playing it? >> No.
I need to hear the >> Are you worried that it's not going
to go your way if you continue to play it? >> Now, if Destiny
was on the on the other side, the side, the answer would be something
like maybe. I mean, what is I don't know that, you know, what's
the definition of this or that? Maybe, possibly. I don't know.
>> Wait, can you pause him? Can you mute him? I want to
hear the audio. I really just want to hear this audio. >> Yeah,
we can keep listening to audio for >> Okay, let's just
let's just listen.
Wait, can you pause him? Can you mute him? I want to hear the
audio. I really just want to hear this audio some more. >> bro.
You really keeping tabs like this, brother? Are you good? Are
you good?
Hold on. Hold on.
Uh, hold on. Desessie, could you could you explain this log to
us really quickly? It just, if you're here, you could maybe explain
this. Was this the day after you sent her the pixie video? Was
this like the day
>> And was it before or after this where you discussed
her parents blocking her from coming to see you. I can't remember.
Hold on. We got a donation. What was the donation? El Mo gifted
a sub to Destiny. Thank you very much, El Mo. I just I'm hoping
he will explain this log next. And just if you could answer the
question of if this was before or after her parents blocked her
from coming to see you, that would be cool.
I'm just going to see if you'll respond again. Oh, just wait.
He might type
>> Bro, this is the this is the former king of Red Pill.
Uh I had sex with your girlfriend. That means uh that means you
shouldn't like them, brother.
What has your girlfriend do? Who's your girlfriend been with?
Do we have to go to histories here or are we really going to
Are we going to play this game? Do we want to? Cuz I can pull
some stuff up. Seems a little absurd. No.
Oh, wait. Hold on. Never mind. You can't pull me into that. I
forgot. I actually care about the person I'm with. And you want
the person you're with harassed cuz that's your MO. I'm good.
Don't leave anything. >> Can you uh am I muted or what?
>> No. No. You got the stage. It's all you,
>> So, Zena, I'm just wondering. Yes or no? Did I you >> When
did I say you me? I said you were pushing with me. >> I
said you definitely prevented me from leaving when I said I didn't
want you as you can see in there and I was telling you I don't
want to be with you that way. You definitely prevented me from
doing that. You definitely got on top of me. You definitely been
pushy. You made these claims about me. You said I was touching
you without consent. Did you or did you not say I was touching
you without consent? Did you or did you not say I touched your
dick without consent? >> And these are crimes that you're
accusing me of. >> Oh, did you or did you not make the
same comments about me? >> Yeah. And it's interesting how
you
caused and then you said that I didn't have proof. Right. >> Cena,
I just have one question. So, >> and then you kept baiting
me. And then you kept baiting me and baiting me because you wanted
me to show it and then I showed some of it and now you're worried
thinking I'm saying you're a or something. I never I didn't make
these things. You won't answer the question. >> You won't
answer. >> What question do I need to answer? >> You
don't need to answer any question, but you won't answer it so
that you can choose either answer in your favor when you think
that it might benefit. >> Either answer. What answer, Sean?
>> I already earlier in my discord. Earlier in my discord,
I made a declaration and I said it. So, why do I need to keep
>> Okay. So, do you feel that I assaulted you or raped
you? >> Do you feel like I assaulted you? Are you trying
to make me say? Uh,
>> No. I'm just wondering if anything that either of us
were doing to each other when you were doing that to me. >> By
the way, I don't think that Zena fully believes that this is
like or something. I think she's playing this cuz it looks bad
for him. If I if I had to guess now, I don't know, maybe she'd
take it to court or something. I think for content, she'll like
lean into this and not be specific about what she's saying. But
like, I don't think she'd take it to court on this guy. That's
just my this is my read on this. You have to see. And you're
saying that I, you know, grabbed your and stuff when you were
mad at me. I'm saying, were we assaulting each other? >> Yes,
you did. >> And yes, we both assaulted each other. Unfortunately,
I guess the boundaries believe that I assaulted you. Okay. >> I
believe that when I said no and you got on top of me, that technically
you assaulted me then. Yeah. I mean, if you said you said what
I did is assault, then I have to agree with you. Then I have
to agree with >> you. Realize this is after you got me
drunk, right? >> I logically have to agree with you. >> I
was blacked out. >> Oh, you were blacked out drunk. And
so you you somebody or assaulted someone.
Is that what you're saying? >> I mean, is that what you're
saying? I did in that audio cuz it didn't sound like I >> I
mean, you're saying in that audio I got you drunk, but in the
audio pause. Let me rewind this. Cuz in the audio, >> you
didn't get me drunk in the audio. I already was. This was after
the club after you already put shots down my >> Oh, I put
shots down your throat. >> Did somebody were saying everybody
>> So, do we want to pull this? We could pull this, right?
Let me pull
content factory. Let's take a look. Let's take a look. Let's
take a look. Let's take a look.
Let's take a look. Okay, so this is the video.
Pours her cup of alcohol into Shuy. 19 Shuies 19 red.
>> It's like right here, right?
>> She actually like dumps whatever was in her cup into
Shi's Red Bull. Malikwood baby Zena. All these people are out.
I don't know like how drunk she got him to be honest. So he is
a child and cannot control what goes into his mouth. I don't
know.
I think it's like it's bad that she did this, but I don't know
that this would be I don't know that you could defend any consent
violations by saying no, no, no, your honor. I was blackout drunk.
Also, I don't think she had that much alcohol that I would expect
him to be like totally blackout. But we could watch we could
go back and check out this wood baby stream and when they leave
and see if he's like stumbling or anything, they just let underage
people into bars. Yeah, I think usually they basically put a
wristband on you that shows that you can't be served alcohol,
right? So the bartenders will never serve you alcohol, but obviously
there's a loophole in that what Zena just did here, right? Somebody
buys other alcohol and just pours it into your drink. Yep. Yep.
Hello legal regardless of consent. Wait, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. Dinglingus. Um, Zena is claiming that Shuy
was like kind of violating her consent, being super pushy, trying
to push for that night. Shuy says, "I was drunk cuz you got me
drunk."
That's That's the argument so far. So, you can't just take off
the band. Maybe it's a maybe you get a banned if you are able
to be served alcohol. I've seen some things in the States where
this happened. Where was this? I think was this um Oh, it was
the George Not found stuff with Katie Bugs. Katy Bugs. Apparently,
this was one of the things that showed there's like a mixed party
with people who are 18 plus as well, but some people would have
the band that shows you could be served alcohol and some people
wouldn't. >> So, now you're saying everybody there was
helping you drink. Got it. >> Where is >> So, anyway,
in the beginning of this video at 3:00 in the morning and I woke
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Where is there?
>> I don't know. You said it was at a club,
>> Yeah. So, >> so the only club I know is there.
>> This ain't a club, but I don't know. This ain't at no
club. So, >> no, it's not. It's afterwards. Do you remember
when we went to the club? >> Yeah. And this is in Texas,
too.
>> Are you sure? I have this. >> Yeah, it is.
>> I forgot. I was thinking that was in Miami. That was
a dream hack. So, uh Okay. So, you are saying that I do not >> I
never said these words.
>> That's That's up. Zena, you should say what you think
happened here. Okay. >> Play the recording. What I'm saying
is >> why don't you continue to play the >> Um because
it's getting super and I'm going to give it to Anthony and he
can decide whether or not you know we can share it. >> Why
don't you be playing it? >> No, it's not just kissing.
No, it's not just kissing. Hold on. Mute your stream. >> Oh,
I see. So, this is like at concerts and stuff, Sophia, they do
this. They'll give you a band if they've IDed you so that you
can get like through the lines faster or something. >> Real
quick, I'm going to skip through this real quick. >> I
mean, I don't remember doing any of >> Hold on. Can you
mute yours? Hold on. Let me mute this. My
>> when she asked you if if if her grabbing your was assault,
she was waiting for you to say yes or no and then she was going
to go with whatever you said. So I feel like if you just back
up >> and just say no, maybe there's no more >> do
that to her.
>> That's that was her trying to escape cuz she's scared
that I have stuff against her that I can use in the court of
law. That's why she just tried to pull that. But I'm not >> I
feel like both of these people have probably gotten into a dynamic
where they're fine touching each other like that and now they're
both going like technically that's not allowed and other that's
the impression I get after watching this obviously could be convinced
back >> but are we >> listen listen I'm playing more
of it >> okay roger >> now I'm asking what is your
claim what are you claiming >> did I make and say you me
I never did I said we both were >> so does that mean that
I did not you >> like what
>> why can't you just answer yes or no whether I rap you
or not. >> I mean, I think maybe you should just get a
lawyer and we should just play it in court and find out. That's
what you want to do, right?
>> why don't you play the end of the recording after after
we allegedly have >> I'm not I didn't make this claim.
You did. You made this claim. >> You want me to back down
so that you back down? >> No, you made this claim.
I didn't.
>> Oh, what is this?
>> Like what?
>> Damn. Zena handing me alcohol in the
>> Oh, wow. And I have pictures of you actually texting
me asking to use my ID for something recently. What was that?
Let's find You never told me what it was, but hold on. Let me
Let me screenshot that cuz what did you ask me for my ID for
when you were in Arizona? Is that not illegal?
>> Wait, Zena, what does that mean if you >> We We
pulled this up. We already showed that to me for alcohol. >> I'm
curious. >> Wait, Zena, I'm actually curious. What does
that mean if you >> I'm sorry. I understand that it like
this could be like a weird thing. I me I wonder if it's just
the guy versus girl thing that it's like obviously you reverse
the roles in this, right? It's not great,
right? A 30-year-old guy with a 19-year-old girl and he's like
slipping her alcohol and then they after or she wants to it's
it's a complex situation. Okay. It's a complex
>> You gave me your ID for alcohol. >> Did I give
you ID? I don't think I can go ahead and bring it up. Go ahead
and bring it up. >> I don't think I can send it to anything
like that. that I said, "What did you need my ID for?" is what
I said. >> Bring it up. Bring it up. Bring up whatever
you're bringing up. >> What did you need to use my ID for
and why did you ask me for it? >> No. Why don't you show
us what you need? >> Why did you ask me for my ID? You
never >> Let me guess. You're not going to show us now.
Let me guess. >> Why did you ask me for my ID? I'm definitely
pulling stuff up. Why did you ask for my ID? Why' you ask me
for my ID? Could you please send me the back of your ID? And
I said, for what? You never said for what? You said you're so
cute. >> So, what are you trying to say? >> Wait,
I don't understand. Where did you say it was for alcohol? But
wait, Anthony, how can I show you this? Hold >> You just
brought up a separate instance. I never said that was for alcohol.
>> You insinuated that it was supposed to be for alcohol.
>> But wait, aren't you literally violating your probation
by asking for my legal government documentation for you to use
>> Did I Did you believe that it was going to be used for
alcohol? >> Yeah. Did you believe that it was >> I
actually don't recall, right? I think the details were weird
for sure. But I think he kind of like pushed her to play whatever
this was, right? If I'm remembering correctly, I feel like he
kind of pushed her to play this. Was like, "Present the evidence
then." If you if you if you say this happened, present the evidence
then. >> Can it be used for alcohol? >> No. Where
did you say it was going to be used for alcohol in these messages?
It's >> You're the one that insinuated that it was going
to be used for alcohol. >> No, that's all over the place.
>> No, I didn't. I insinuated that you illegally asked
for my ID. I insinuated that you're on probation asking to use
my ID for something. >> I insinuated
I insinuated that you asked to use my ID for something while
you're on probation, mind you. What do you need my ID for you?
>> What is that something? Zena, what is that something
you use your ID? It doesn't matter what it is, Sean. It's
>> What is illegal? >> Trying to use my ID for anything
to gain >> Yeah. Yeah. I know what you're talking
Whether it's to get into a place. No, you don't use my ID. I'm
saying the recording. Obviously, this details things is weird.
But what? >> Okay. Anyways, regardless of that, why don't
you talk about the evidence that you were just presented with?
>> Also, what's this? >> You handing me alcohol.
Notice how she always changes the subject. >> Did I hand
you alcohol?
>> I don't know. Why don't you react to the video and comment
on it? >> I mean, I don't know. You You said I gave you
a Red Bull, so I mean, there's also a video. Wait, but there's
also a video of other people handing you the same stuff. So,
I mean, I guess we're all hu from your logic.
other people. You realize it doesn't matter. I'm the minor in
the situation. That means I'm the victim. If other people are
handing me alcohol saying,
>> uh, sure, I mode. Basically, he said, "You assaulted
me." She said, "Oh, didn't you do the same thing? Didn't you
pressure me for this night?" And he was like, "Well, I presented
evidence. Why don't you present evidence?"
>> Are you trying to drag down your friend? >> You
think because you're a minor that when a >> You're a liability.
You're a liar. >> When a person says stop, you don't stop.
Is that what you're saying? That gives you the excuse to not
stop when you're >> She wants to drag her friends down
with her. Chat, >> I'm not dragging nobody down with me.
Half those people I didn't know there. So, what what do you mean?
There was a couple people I didn't know. >> Alcohol, apparently.
>> Go watch all the clips, Sean. Go watch the whole live
stream. Why did I come snatch a cup out of your hand? Why did
I snatch a cup out of your hand? >> Who gave you that cup?
>> Could we replay the clip in half or watch it? Zena,
are you willing to watch the clip and comment on it? >> I
seen the clip. We watched the clip together. Do I give a [__]
And what do you have to say about it? >> I do not give
a What do you have to say about me saying stop and you continuing?
Like what do you think? What do you think a judge actually gives
a more about? Let's be real. >> I'm just wondering you're
arguing the dumbest [__] right now that you're saying
that I >> call the police. Matter of fact, wait. Let me
call the police and ask them right now. Let's call the police.
>> Let's call the police right now. >> There should
be like a non-emergency number, right? >> Yeah. Probably
like 311, right? I mean, we might as well call them and ask them
like, "Hey, this guy wants to say that." >> Uh, technically,
technically Shu is the not sorry. Technically, Shuy is not the
one snitching here. People knew about this when it happened.
People brought this up in my Discord as if it was a big problem
when it happened. Like, literally back when it did happen. >> Watch.
I'm going to make I'm just going to make a police report right
now. What else are we going to do? We're just going to make the
police report. Okay. >> Hold up. Let's just make the
>> Wait. I almost feel like we should pull it back.
Use your pullet back.
>> This sounds like a serious thing. I'm making the police
report right now. What do you mean? It's not an emergency, but
I'm making actually mentally ill. >> I'm mentally ill?
Why? I'm >> I did not know it was this bad. I knew it was
bad being with her, but I did not know it was this bad, bro.
And I'm so glad that I'm gone. >> Me, too. Cuz you're a
>> Your ass was with me to to get a restraining order.
>> You're literally doing all this cuz I left. You didn't
want to get beat up by a guy. You didn't want to have a family.
You said I was going to be your husband. >> I'll send 311.
>> Now you want to act like you don't care. You literally
want to have my kids. >> I'm going to mute this guy. I
need to make a uh I guess I need to make a report, right? So
a month ago, >> we should spend time thinking about this
before a month ago somebody gave a minor alcohol. Like how do
I go about that? >> Jim, I'm not sure yet, but I can look
into it. So you just found it, >> dude. Really? Seriously?
Well, yeah. And apparently the minor was handed alcohol. So,
I'm like, what? What do we do about it? >> Or what?
>> Starting to feel like a queen stream in here. Oh, don't
worry about it. >> Like a professional or like a relative
or something else? >> Um, it's just like it look I guess
they're saying it's alcohol in the club. It's I guess it's alcohol.
So, I mean I
>> Yeah, I mean I I can't I don't know if it's actually
alcohol, but they are saying it's alcohol. So, and it's a minor.
The guy's under 21. Don't make a report, please.
>> One thing for sure on this is going to be the TABC,
>> which is the Texas Alcoholic Beverage Commission. They
need to be notified is what I would tell you to do. >> Okay.
So, I'll call that.
>> Okay. But you don't know anything, right? Just off ripped.
It's not like >> I'm still looking. I still have to look
into things here. But you can report like the bar for sure through
CABC because they have to follow certain obvious. What if it
wasn't someone in a bar? Like, what if it was, okay, people are
hanging out at a bar and it's just a girl that's at the bar and
she handed him a cup and they're now saying it's alcohol. Of
course, you don't see the
she's they're now saying it's alcohol, but all she really did
was hand him did all she really did was hand him a cup. Guys,
what would happen there? I think there's another clip, by the
way. So, she's There's two clips. There's the one where she pours
it into his drink and there's another clip where she like kind
of subtly hands him a cup and he grabs it from her >> alcohol
even being poured into it or anything, but they're saying it's
an alcohol and he's taking the shots of >> Yeah, that's
a good question I'm going to have to look into.
Yeah. So, if it's not an employee situation, bar situation, you
know, people working there thing, then it wouldn't be TABC.
Okay. Let me try to find out. You mind hold for me? Is that okay?
>> Okay. No, no worries. know she's got to find out a bunch
of So, >> am I muted? >> Oh, good. >> I'm just
curious like what's like what we're supposed to do about it.
Like that's that's the only reason why I called. I just I'm just
curious. What do we do about it? >> When we're in a heightened
state of mind, we probably should >> vice I think the people
who answer like the general line like you wouldn't call emergency,
right? You wouldn't call emergency services, but like you could
call this and ask of the police department like this question.
I know it's like kind of annoying that people are doing it for
content instead of but like as a citizen, you literally pay taxes.
They literally have a phone number so you can call and ask them
questions. It's not really like that big an abuse. They're calling
emergency services. I would be super, right? I would be very
annoying because that that service actually is bandwidth. Their
response time matters. The the general like info line that's
not that big a >> You know, a cop call making report this
isn't cop calling. This isn't this is not emergency. This is
just how to make a report. So, she's trying to figure it out.
Like it is the legal whatever, but they're trying to figure out
how to make this report. >> I don't understand the logic
behind this. I mean, you're saying I handed you alcohol. Like,
so I'm saying like, how do we report this then? I feel like this
needs to be reported, right? Like, >> oh, are you about
to self-report? >> I guess you're saying it's alcohol.
Can we prove that it's also alcohol? >> Okay. Um, I guess
self-report yourself. All right.
>> There's no way to prove it. You're right, Z. There's
actually no way to prove the liquid is alcohol. So, >> no,
but I did I did record I do got uh squeeze given him Jack Daniels,
though yesterday out the car. >> Interesting. Trying to
throw other people under the bus. have nothing to do >> I'm
not throwing nobody on the bus. He got rid of it. He said he
didn't want it. He didn't even open it. So, you did bring a bottle
of Jack Daniels. >> You know, at the end of the day, you're
just proving that you're a untrustworthy, liable >> Oh,
why is it at the end of the day? Why is it at the end of the
day? >> What? What is that? I don't know what that's supposed
to mean. What? At the end of the day, you're just proving you're
distrustworthy. Why is it at the end of the day? Why is it at
the end of the day? You can say it in a way that makes it sound
like it's a little better, but not really. >> Cuz it's
the end of the day and I'm realizing it.
>> But I've been realized and your behavior is pathetic
at the age of 29. >> [__] I really don't, Sean.
I really >> I know you don't care. >> I don't care.
>> We know you don't care about your life. >> That's
why you were about to kick yourself over a 19-year-old. >> Yeah.
That's why I was about to kill myself over everything. I have
slit marks from years. There's no need to be talking about
>> saying this like you're saying this like you made me
mentally
I almost myself over crashing my car like I'm mentally yes we
knew this you were warned I told you before your chat told you
I told you like what >> you're delusional >> so basically
you're just admitting that you're a dumbass idiot
>> no I'm just curious how to go about this like how to
report it and then what does it mean If the the minor was like
really wasted drunk but like got on top of a girl when she kept
saying no like how do we go about that? >> It's not a minor.
Zena you didn't Zena. Zena you didn't a minor. Zena he's not
a minor. Zena he is just below the drinking age. Zena do not
confess the things that you did not do. Hey this minor is like
trying to this woman. What happens? Uh-huh. That sounds complex.
>> So it becomes two different things. So is that assault?
>> Yeah. Even if even if the minor is drunk, is it assault?
I'm just curious. Like I'm trying to get information. >> I
thought we were talking about alcohol. >> Listen, I was
I I would say it's a
>> Okay, thank you. That's that's it. I just needed that
information. I just really wanted to know that information. Thank
you, >> dude. That operator, everybody knows what's happening.
Like Zena's like hypothetically if I hypothetically if I was
in a situation where this happen. It's like I know you're in
a fight with your boyfriend. Okay. I care in your tone that you're
in a fight with your boyfriend or some [__] I know
what's happening here. You're not fooling anybody. Like we just
You don't have to abstract it for us. We don't. >> Thank
you so much. >> No, no, no, no, no. It Sorry, she's not
confused. I'm guessing this happens a lot that like people call
this line to settle disputes. I'm almost positive that would
happen a lot. >> I'm just guessing. >> Well, are
you now claiming >> I have the info? That's all I wanted
to know. I was just curious. It's funny how she tries to frame
and twist the >> I'm not framing and twisting nothing.
I never made a claim. I asked a question. I asked a question.
I asked a question. That's all I asked. I asked a question. >> If
you if you get uh like this is a example that has nothing to
do with you, >> You're the only one talking about legal
stuff. I just asked a question. You said you're suing me. I
>> Okay, cool. Can you calm down and listen or No.
>> Okay. So, this is an example that has nothing to do
with you. Just an an analogy if you will. So if an adult gets
a minor drunk and then them did the minor them >> did I
the minor
I'm pretty sure that you realize you realize proving there's
alcohol.
>> Wait wait that was not a good analogy but you realize
adults cannot say that a minor them right? I don't think so unless
it's an idiot. You're a idiot. Yes the they can. Are you dumb?
Oh my god, he did not just say this. Oh my god, he did not just
say that. Oh my goodness, he did not just say that. >> I
mean, I actually might be wrong on that. But I mean that if they
wrong is rape, buddy. No way you just said that. This conversation
is so over. There's no way you just >> What I meant what
I meant to say is that if they both consensually,
it's automatically rape on the adults end. And I don't know why
I actually brought that up. It doesn't really make sense as >> So
wait, you me while I'm drunk. You're saying it's not because
you're under 21. >> Sorry, I'm tweeting right now. >> So
when I'm wasted drunk as like on the boat with squeeze and you
know heard back as the cause. So when we got when I was drunk
as on the boat now you're saying that because someone was drunk
it's correct cuz I was defending you that whole time. But now
you are saying that if someone's drunk, there's even if the person
was saying no, mind you, which in my videos I'm saying no. But
um you know, apparently you're drunk, so you're free to do whatever.
Um and apparently I got you drunk. But wait, when I get wasted
on your boat, um are are you saying when someone's drunk and
there's activity that means it's cuz you were sober? >> So
are you saying when I was wasted and drunk on that boat and you
had hickeys the next day, are are you saying what >> Cuz
it sounds like you're the one saying this. It sounds like you're
the one saying this stuff. I'm just asking the
>> So, did you just try to bring up an instance where you
said that I said >> I'm asking the question? I am just
where you did the alleged exact same thing on me. >> So,
I'm asking a question. Did you What is that? >> I mean,
it just sounds like you brought up another thing against yourself.
>> Against me? When I'm wasted on the on a boat? That's
against me. That means you me.
By your logic, you're saying that if someone is sober and the
person drunk, it's so on the boat when I was wasted drunk and
you me. Is that not right? >> My analogy. Ignore my >> Now
I need to ignore your >> Oh, hold on. I'm Guys, I'm uh
>> I'll be real. >> I just noticed um these guys
are lying again. Uh oh. These guys think I propagated the whole
not so Aerodite um Kylo Maxwell thing. I said it was a funny
joke, but I don't believe it. And I also tweeted defending her
after that stream.
Uh-oh.
DJ's caught lying again. Here, let me pin that. Juice that tweet,
guys. Juice that tweet. Juice that tweet. Liars stay >> Analogy.
Now I need to ignore your analogy cuz you realize how stupid
you sound. No, you just realize how stupid you sound, buddy.
>> I did realize how stupid I sounded. Yes, you're right.
Absolutely, Zena. I can admit when I sound stupid. >> Okay,
well then cool. Hm. >> Like what? I don't know what you
think is a gotcha. Like I admit that that sounded stupid. We
can ignore that. But I don't understand what your goal is. >> No,
it's your goal. I'm just picking apart at your goal. >> What
the does that even mean? >> I said I'm just picking apart
at your goal. What What are you saying? You made the analogy
and then sounded stupid. >> No, I'm talking about in this
whole thing. What is your point? What is your goal? You're trying
to say that I got you drunk and that gives you an excuse to apparently
get on top of me upon me saying for over 10 minutes, "No, get
off of me. I don't want to." >> No, I'm just saying I think
you said I think you I think you said this. >> That's what
you said. That's what you said. And then I'm saying And then
you literally said, >> I have a question. >> You
literally said a minor can't an >> Did anything happen
beforehand before that recording? >> You said a minor an
adult. Wait, Zena, does that recording Does that recording show
show everything that you wanted to bring up or does stuff happen
off? >> There's a whole hour long of it. >> Is there
a world wait guys guys? Is there a world where you both could
agree that nothing illegal happened and we can and we can just
like separate without having law legal cops reports? Like is
it possible? >> But all this law stuff only happens because
of him. He wants this. He told me to have my f He told me I didn't
love him if I didn't actually make the steps to get the restraining
order because my ex won't stop harassing me. And every time I
had friends mediating and trying to fix it and try to be civil,
which I was talking about in court, like yes, I contacted him.
Yes, we were trying to be civil. I wanted things to be able to
be civil so everybody can make content and just be cool together.
He's the one who said I'm a for that and he can't respect me
or be with me if I don't press charges. And then when I chickenened
out and didn't want to go to court, that's why DTN was with me
because originally Shuy was going. Shuy came for the second part,
but Shuy was supposed to go with me just like he took me to file
the charges in the first place cuz I didn't want to do it in
the first place because I was scared and I don't want to go through
legal. But anyway, and then Yeah. So, so what what just like
his text messages of saying you should share this and tell the
judge this so that he's more mad. What? All this legal comes
from him. >> I feel you. I feel you. I >> don't need
to do anything legal. I didn't make claims about him. I'm not
sitting here saying, "Oh, he did this. I'm going to the police.
But wait, Shuy, >> I didn't make a claim. I asked questions.
Let's not bring up and try to put words in her mouth. If she's
saying she didn't make a claim, why don't just be cool with that
reality? >> I didn't make a claim. I asked. >> You're
offended by my questions. You're offended by me asking questions
based off the things that you said. >> Wait, wait, wait.
No need. No, no, no, no. It's all good. We can take We can just
keep I feel like honestly this is a cyclical issue that's happening
right now. And at this point, it's actually evolving and escalating
rather than devolving and deescalating. And I don't want to be
the center of that happening. As much as this is content, everybody's
happy. Everybody's spinning in chat, whatever. You guys, I know
you in real life. And I think you guys need to just take some
time. You need to take some time away from each other. Stop texting
each other. Do your do your own individual things. Don't bring
cops into it. And let's just
calm the down. Let's calm the down. >> Wow. and just separate
without there needing to be a huge chaotic >> I have messages
Anthony I want to share the messages with by the way that says
um when I invited him to Hannah's birthday party I just want
to share some of this where it said she said >> can you
show details >> dude also my social stream is like delayed
again >> god damn it this broke again why did this break
what's going on oh whoops I it up the scrolling paused never
mind it didn't break
please don't drink I have messages literally asking him not to
drink and I said JJ's coming to get you. I was like please don't
drink. Like I have Let me screenshot all this real >> Zena,
you gave him alcohol. >> Yeah. Yeah, I could pull it up.
>> I didn't let it do anything, Lana. These are two adult
overlay. >> I'm not in control of either of them. I'm just
here.
I got raided. I got called. I'm barely saying anything. Okay.
This isn't my I'm trying to help. >> On the property. Don't
even drink soda. If you want to get a water or soda, we can even
go to a gas station. Just don't drink anything on the property.
Like, let me keep going.
>> All right, Zena, bring them up. I got something right
when you're done. >> No, just post it now. The You mean
right when you're done? Just post it now. I already just showed
it. Just post now. I don't give a like. What the does you mean
when you're done? >> You didn't even send anything. >> Yeah,
I saw lab replying to tweets. Yeah, I saw it. I Dude, it's so
weird that um that these people just like lie.
Like I I obviously I believe Arerodite messaged me to thank me
for not propagating this stuff, right? So I think Destiny showed
these logs on his stream cuz Crow said this was like the next
thing, right? Like I I remember this stream I had this up and
I was like as funny as it is, we don't believe this. She's not
Kyler Maxwell's guys. It's not that's not the case. That's not
the case,
right? That's not the case. And this is the next this is the
next log, by the way, that for some reason these people never
include. This is obvious when you see my tweet at Nicholas Dioro
that ruined our friendship. This tweet.
This tweet right
Right. But they don't they don't want facts. They don't want
any truth to be laid out. They just want to they just want to
lie.
I don't know if we can let them just lie unchallenged.
Probably not. Probably can't. Probably can't do it.
You're not at the clip. What clip? I don't know what clip you're
talking about. I'm continuing.
>> I showed it on the camera. I showed my on the camera
to Anthony. Did Did Anthony not look? >> I already showed
it. I been What are you talking about? >> Oh, he's watching
my stream. So, show >> Yeah. Yeah. Defense. Yeah. >> Oh,
my bad. Okay, I'll have to scroll back up then. Hold on. >> I'm
just going to send this to this group chat. >> Yeah, I
can pull that up as well in a >> Like, I don't give a >> She
wants to keep bringing up I can just keep bringing up more >> bringing
up stuff. You're the one bringing up stuff all the time. Like
you act like I give a I don't. I keep telling you. I really don't.
>> All right, here's one screenshot.
>> Unfortunately, this video I have a video, but it's other
people and I'm not doing that to them. That sucks. Wait, also
he's on probation. >> There's three. Anthony, there's two
>> Yeah, there's two more. And he's on probation, by the
way. >> Boom. Should be all three.
>> So, everything closing. We won't go to a shop or drink.
Go drink. I guess you never Okay. >> On probation. >> There's
three. Anthony, there's two
>> Is DGG just infesting everything? Yeah, they they they're
like a totally like they're like Kiwi Farms without the don't
touch the poop thing, right? Like totally just always brigading,
constantly brigading, constantly harassing, constantly doxing.
This is like that what their community is at its at its core
at this point. >> There's two more. And he's on probation,
by the way. >> Boom. Should be all three in there. Like
I said, call and make the report, but buddy, you want to >> Okay,
I want Yeah, I want to end things. Yeah, you're cut off. I'm
done officially, clown. You owe me money for them drinks also.
your your boyfriend who's under the drinking age. You owe me
money for those two drink those drinks, too, [__]
You owe me money. >> You on probation doing this? Oh, and
I have the videos of you at the kick party, which I didn't host.
And you're at this table, so doing stuff on your >> Oh,
where are you? Come back. Pay for the drinks, by the way. What
drinks, >> I mean, in this one, it literally says we could
go to get you water. So So which So which do you want?
>> What was that, June? Yeah. >> $47 apple juice.
>> $47 apple juice is funny. >> Oh, yeah. I'm sure
it is. >> You guys could be you could be cordial, right?
You could share a laugh. >> Be more. What do you think
should be more? Should I keep playing me saying stop, get off
me? Like, what? Like, what do you think? >> We don't hate
each other, guys.
>> E, go ahead. >> Obviously, this in my house living
with me like was living with me. Like, do you think I give a
[__] I do not.
>> Underage alcohol supplier versus teenage nipple sucker.
Who's more cooked? >> Give a [__] about what?
And I mean, now some of these messages are implicating other
people because he's telling me about other people that he's like,
"Oh, he'd buy me a drink. Why can't you?" Cuz I'm arguing with
him about not wanting to buy a drink. And I can't show it because
unfortunately it happens to be another streamer and his dumb
ass. So that he manipulated >> manipulate minor. Uh, no,
not minor. Underage person manipulating adult into buying drinks.
By the way, >> when you talk to somebody else and you claim,
you kept telling me that they would give you drinks. You're saying
that they give you drinks all the time. So that's what I'm saying.
I don't know that person like that though to know if that's even
true. So I'm not gonna I'm not going to make claims on this person
or add this person to it. The >> you wanted to add squeeze.
>> No,
for some reason I just looked at my screenshots folder. For some
reason I've got a bunch of like Danny and Darius soy faces.
I've got like a bunch of soy faces in my screenshots folder for
some reason. I have no idea why. Oh, I put I usually put them
in the Discord. Never mind. I know exactly. said Squeeze got
rid of a bottle that he did not want. What do you mean? >> I'm
just saying you wanted to bring other names into this. >> When
did I say Squeeze was drinking? I never seen Squeeze even drink
alcohol. >> I didn't say that. You said that. >> So,
I didn't bring other names in
other
>> cuz you're a and you're and you want to take people
down with you. >> You needed me to have a restraining order.
I'm But you needed me to have a restraining order so that my
ex didn't beat the out of you at brand risk so that you could
beat up squeeze because you take squeeze because you can't take
my ex >> right now. Why don't you show the last text that
I sent you when I told you to take me off of it so your whole
argument just falls and now you only say that because you knew
I was going to take you off of it. That's why we have argument
with the messages. >> If I said I would stay with you just
so that you would keep me on the protective order though. If
I was so scared. What do you mean show the last text I sent?
Well, then if you're not scared, you should probably just agree
to the brand risk. The [__] Duh. Fight him at brand
risk. They want you to >> Go ahead. >> Go ahead.
What? >> Like what? >> Who do you want me to fight?
>> I don't want you to fight anybody, but the chat wants
you to fight somebody. Aiden Ross wants you to fight somebody.
Everybody else wants you to fight somebody. You should probably
just do >> Who is that? Who is that? >> You should
do it. >> The person they want you to fight. I don't know.
Maybe chat can tell us. Chat, who do they want him to box at
brand risk? Who is he supposed to box at Bran Risk that he wanted
me to get an order against so that he could be on the protective
order and not fight him because he wanted to fight Squeeze instead?
Who did he want to fight? Who do they want him to fight at Bran
Risk again? I'm like not following the content at all. By the
way, I I understand Zena's calling him a that doesn't want to
fight Darius. Shu would probably get by Darius. That's why it's
up for Zena to pick fights with Darius, right? As as uh as much
as I know people here don't like Darius, he's been to the gym
a lot recently. He's probably he probably beat the [__]
out of Shuy who's already like a reasonably strong guy. Yeah,
we can tell yourself Zanic Cali
>> who's the guy they said they wanted him to fight at
Brand Risk. >> W chat >> cuz I already W chat. Yeah,
they're saying um they're saying the guy you're afraid of. >> Who
is that? >> You know who it is. >> I don't I don't
know. >> You know who you scared of, boy. >> I mean,
why don't you be more specific? Who did you say assaulted you
and bit >> I'm not sure. >> Oh, wait. Okay, here.
I'll show then. Hold on.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Marty Epstein,
thank you for the five gifted. Let's Thank you. Thank you. >> Wait,
do I show this or >> Yeah, like Oh, I was saying it's it's
up for Zena to like constantly pick fights with Darius. Like,
get physically in fights with Darius and then Shuy's supposed
to step in and Shuy's probably like 40 lbs lighter, right? Do
like do I throw it off of your thing or Anony's thing? Okay.
>> Uh on D10. Yeah. >> Let me scroll up and go to
it. >> D10. I think your flipped foe. Do you know how to
fix that live or is it even >> I don't think I can fix
it right now.
>> It shouldn't be flipped. It's flipped right now. >> Let
me see. >> No. No, it's not. It's not. We're good. We're
good. My bad. Wait, in that recording of me like allegedly you
was Did it show everything in the recording or did stuff happen
off recording? >> He No, the whole thing is recorded. I
never said you me. I never made claims. >> you're showing
the same thing that you already showed for the third time. >> Because
you said you're not afraid of him. Why did you need Why did you
need that order?
>> You already showed this. This is the third time. >> Why
did you need the order? You just said you're not afraid of him.
>> If I need the order, then why did I leave you and tell
you to take me off? Oh, because you didn't want to get your >> argument
makes no sense. >> Because you didn't want to get clowned
for it. Why did you text me? I already know what's going to happen.
>> Why would I get clowned for it? I don't care if I'm
on the order. >> Wait, what? >> You trying to say
you don't want to be with me? Wait, why are you texting me stuff
like this all the time? >> You do all this to someone who
just simply doesn't want to be with you. >> No, I'm just
sharing. >> Like, you cannot accept the fact
I'll remove it. can't accept the fact that people do not some
people do not love you. >> Dream, look at the stream. >> It's
honestly very sad. >> It is sad. Just look. >> I
didn't see. Can you show again? >> There's no reason to
remove it cuz I'm saying I'll remove it. You're saying there's
no reason to remove it. >> I mean, yeah. I don't care whether
you leave it or not. Why don't you show the text where I said
remove it? I will I'll you know what? I'll just show the stream.
Like I don't know what you think you're proving it. Like I said,
I don't care whether you leave it or take it. It wasn't part
of It wasn't an issue to me. You could leave it. You could take
it. I don't give a [__]
>> You were talking about trying not being safe, bro. Why
would you not be safe? Why are you using that kind of words?
>> There's some chance your hero. I don't know if Zena
is going to keep the restraining order to be honest. >> Oh,
that's a great text.
That was fact. >> I feel like Hold on.
>> Sorry. I I feel like Zena might actually drop it entirely.
Um, if she's not with Shuy, I feel like she might just drop it
entirely cuz she's kind of said Shuy pushed her to get it. And
I have a feeling that like that is probably not really the case,
but also she's going to like run with that and drop it entirely
now. I think Shivy clearly wanted him like to face consequences
for his actions. But I don't think I think like going through
with the restraining order that had to have been Zena's decision
in my opinion. In my opinion. In my >> I sent a text when
you said a minor can't rap an adult. Like you sound >> I
already said that. That sounded stupid. So, I don't know why
you're still bringing it up. Unless you want to be childish >> cuz
I just think it's so funny. Then you're talking about how you
mentioned couples therapy before, but I didn't seem interested
or like I'd actually care about it. >> Anthony, you can
bring up bring up the text that I sent if you want. >> Okay.
Yeah. >> I would like if you
>> the couple's therapy is so funny. >> On the way.
Big big talk about I'm mad he doesn't love me. No, that got out
already. Like the we weren't together for two and a half years.
I don't >> You're doing all this because I did not >> You're
doing this cuz you Okay, you already showed that on someone to
be with you. >> Nobody's crashing out. You're asking for
this. You keep asking me to show proof. How am I >> Every
time I leave you, you say you're >> We watch this or we
we read this right.
>> Pause. Anthony, I'm confused. Let me ask you. If he
asked me for something that I wasn't sharing and I kept saying
I'm not sharing it, how am I crashing out if he said show proof
when I wasn't even showing anything?
I I'm genuinely
>> Everything that you're doing right now is cuz somebody
just simply doesn't love you when they are not obligated to.
>> No, because >> you're mad you can't find love.
>> No, dude. You did this. What are you talking about?
I can't find love. Didn't you block people out my phone because
they're interested in me? >> But didn't you block people
out my phone because they were texting me and you got mad that
a dude? >> This is This is Shuy, by the way. This is Shu
>> try to text me in June and I was like, I barely know,
bro. You get mad that dudes hit me up because they want to around
and and get to know me and you made me block people for you.
What are you talking about? I can find people and you know that
>> everything you're everything you're doing.
It's easy to find people. So anyway Anyway, >> no wonder
I couldn't love you. No wonder I couldn't love you. Like, are
you trying? Like, what do you Am I supposed to cry?
I wasn't with you for 2 and a half years, Sean. I cried before.
Do I need to cry again? Like, I don't I don't I'm not crying.
>> I mean, you were crying when you said you're going to
yourself cuz I wanted to leave you. So, >> okay. And I
was crying when I said I wanted to kill myself over Enzo, too.
Am I crying now? I'm clearly not.
>> You think that makes you special? I I try to kill myself
over all my exes. All right. You just You're just number six.
You think you're special to me? You're just number six.
>> Yeah, you cry when everyone leaves you cuz you're lonely
and nobody actually wants to be with you and that's what you're
realizing. >> You're trying to bait me to feel bad right
now and you're >> Oh, you don't need to feel bad. I mean,
it's just >> you're trying to. You want me to cry and I'm
not crying over you. >> I wish you the best of the luck.
>> Do you? Because you're the one that started all this
leaking stuff and legal
>> All I did was leave you and expose how you try to manipulate
me. >> Okay. And then I showed how you manipulated me and
controlled me and went through my phone and controlled who
>> She Hold on. Wait, did that not pop up? Oh, for some
reason this message, Alien Mode's message didn't pop up. It didn't
pop up in my thing. Alien mode said, uh, Alien mode said she
did actually say that earlier. She was like, I tried to kill
myself when I crashed my car. I
Oh, it finally popped up over here. The hell? Yeah. Awesome.
>> Oh, you got mad and started trying to make up accusations.
>> I didn't make up accusations. I proved and showed facts
of you trying to control my phone. Are you Dude,
>> you said I was manipulating you and controlling you
and I showed that you were doing the exact same thing to me multiple
times. >> Why were you at the end of the day? This is just
cuz you're sad that somebody doesn't want to be with you. >> How
how are you not controlling when you're when you're going through
my phone? When you're going through my phone every day, when
you're doing stuff out my phone, controlling my phone. Look,
you're talking over me. I don't make accusations and I didn't
make one about you. You made one of me. But you wanted to say
I was doing things to you and I showed what you were doing to
me. But you talking over me. Look how he's talking over me. What
do you need?
>> I'm taking control of my phone. It's multiple times
and I have arguments in our phone about
control on FaceTime. Is there proof? >> [__]
you went through my phone multiple times and we argue about it
in the phone. So >> your phone. What a crazy crime. >> Why
were you going through my phone every day and blocking people
and telling me who I can and cannot be with? Why did you tell
me So, is it not me? >> Chibi wants to control your iPhone.
Allow. Don't allow. >> Manipulating to say that you wouldn't
be in a relationship with me and take me serious and that I didn't
love you all the way if I didn't press charges and make sure
my ex was out of my life >> I did not say that. >> You
did.
>> You absolutely [__] did. You absolutely
did. You pushed me to get the legal stuff, dude. >> Guess
what? You're not going to show proof, so don't bring it up. >> I
already
was showing proof, Sean. I already was. >> She showed some
proof of this that Sean uh sorry, Shuy wanted the charges pressed
for sure. >> Telling how you were telling me to do
>> where is me saying I will not love you if you do not
do this. Where >> he didn't say that? She didn't say that.
She said you told her that she didn't fully love you unless she
made sure her ex was out of her life, which is why you pushed
her to get the restraining order. And Right. That's like that
makes sense that somebody could say that.
Uh but it's weird that he doesn't get it now. You said >> Sean,
you telling me to get him arrested is enough. What are you talking
about? You're the one texting my phone and telling me to get
him arrested. >> I didn't say I said you should bring this
up,
>> assuming that you wanted >> I said he's getting
arrested. You said to make it worse for him. What? >> Yeah,
cuz I thought
>> see Mantis on Twitter talking about getting you for
ban evasion earlier. >> What? I was giving you >> I
dude the the DG like coordinated harassment meme is out of this
world, isn't it? >> It's pretty It's pretty nuts.
>> The funny thing is the funny thing is I obviously was
in a toxic relationship with him for 2 and 1/2 years. And never
ever did I need to ever say or threaten a restraining order against
him until you got involved. And look, you're the one that's completely
always talking about legal stuff like even now. Thank you so
much. That was all you bring up. You're the one bringing it up.
I told you. You said you were suing me. How the are you about
to sit here and lie and say you didn't bring me regardless of
everything? We don't We could >> regardless of everything,
Sean. >> We could We could argue about small things forever.
>> I just want to play this. >> The fact of the matter
is you are crashing out because a nerash. You asked me to play
these audio. >> You asked me to play these audios for you.
I'm not crashing out. You asked for these audios. >> This
is the reality of a narcissist collapsing around the of a narcissist.
Let me mute you.
>> Dude, he thought he cooked with that one. This is the
reality of a narcissist. Okay. And their reality collapsing around
them like Okay. What?
>> Their actions too much. >> What is this? Hold
on. What? Huh? What is this?
>> Banned from Discord for banned from Discord. No reason
given. Yog banned again.
Uh,
asserts anti-DG bias with no evidence. Not a great way to start
a ban
Oh, he got banned from the Pisco
dude, I got to Whoever the mods are in the Pisco Discord, those
people are sharp. Okay, they picked up the energy vampire in
a millisecond. Okay, in a millisecond. You love to see it. You
love to see it.
Wait, Queenie, you get clapped, too, from the Pisco Discord.
Really? They knock you out of the Is that what you're saying
right here? I don't even know what you're saying right here.
Why? Oh, really? I wonder why. Zero messages sent. Oh, that's
unlucky.
I hate when people handle things that way. It seems goofy, but
I I guess I get it, right? They just don't want, you know, it's
one of those things where it's like they feel like it would take
too much time to litigate and then
it would take too much time to litigate and so they don't want
to and so they're just like, I'll just ban everybody. I I understand
it. It's weird. It sucks, but Oh, where are we at? 6 hours in.
>> We're getting there. >> We're getting there, guys.
>> Watch out for Yogs.
>> I don't know what I'm hearing. Oh, I will say though
what is very funny to me. Quan, do you have that do you have
that uh Avi Avi Cathy call? I' I'd give that a listen right now.
People don't know about that, but I I don't my my I don't have
a good artifact of that call. I kind of described it to people
earlier. I don't know >> the same thing. Like you're just
hearing the same thing. >> Why are you playing the same
over and >> Why can't I?
>> There's no point. >> But why can't I? You're bringing
up the same [__] over and over. I'm doing the exact
same thing.
>> so Anthony, did I make claims at all? Did I make any
threats or claims? I I don't remember making >> We could
walk away from this call with completely claimless, no cops,
no >> But Anthony, who's the first one who mentioned anything
about lawyers and suing? I'm just curious who who did that cuz
I I didn't. >> I did that. I did that. >> Okay. Okay.
>> So, let's just refrain from the lawyer >> You
think this is Yog the image you post? I have no idea. talk and
then we'll all be content creators moving forward. Right, Chuy?
We'll just
>> keep all the legal cop stuff on the >> Is that
what you want? Zen, >> excuse me.
>> I said, is that what you want? Did you not hear me?
>> What do I want? >> Did you not hear what?
>> Auntie is a mod for Pisco. He probably knows about his
previous behavior. Oh, he might.
Yeah, I think I'm chill with Auntie. So, I think like Auntie
hangs out in my community. I don't think Auntie's ever had any
problem with me. I literally talked to Auntie like one time and
it went fine. I don't think I got any problems with that guy.
But I wonder I I just wonder why Queen would have gotten kicked
out. I I really don't think Quimman does anything. People like
make this guy out to be so evil. I don't understand why. Like
I get made out to be less evil than this guy. It's like it's
just that he's
>> I I I actually don't get it. Well, he's just trying
to verify if if you basically are >> the way he presents
himself. If he was just the Quigler, he'd be fine. But then you
see like the actual when he cams up, you see the nose, you're
like, "Yeah, this guy's evil. I I see this guy evil." I see him
being evil. Okay. I just I feel he's got an evil essence to him.
>> we're on the same page with not wanting to get cops
involved and things of that >> Oh, I never said anything
about wanting to get cops involved. I never even said I wanted
a war.
>> he started his stream. He started. Yeah, he's talking
over me. He started his stream and it literally was about war.
Saying something about war, like he's going to war with me.
>> Psycho got banned after she just got insulted by Destiny.
I don't know. It seems like they just want no problematic people
except Destiny.
>> Wait, there's no way they banned Psycho and didn't ban
Destiny, right? There's no chance they banned Psycho and not
No way. Hold on. I actually have to look at that right now. There's
no way. That's not possible. That's crazy.
That's not possible. Oh, Psycho's messages are removed. What
did she say? She just said like you're a you're or something
and then Destiny was like dropped a bunch of insane Hold on.
It's possible that like Destiny is not actually still there
and he's like banned or something. Nope.
That's very crazy to me. That's totally wild to me. Huh. That's
okay.
>> Okay. Can you not cut me off and let me finish my part
cuz I'm about to get off this call anyway. Anyway. and he's doing
all this stuff. He started leaking stuff and then it's she's
going to regret leaking anything. So, I only leaked about him
talking about how he loved me so much, whatever, whatever. And
it just went from there. I never sat here saying I was going
to try to ruin him or >> what's happening. Oh, I was just
wondering the the apparently apparently Queenman's banned from
the qu the Pisco Discord. I didn't know that. >> Throw
him in jail or anything like that. The only thing I did say was
I'll take him off the the order so like he can do the content
thing with the Aiden thing that has nothing to do with me. Whatever.
He's saying I'm using it as a threat to make him not feel safe.
Like why wouldn't you feel safe? You're not afraid of that guy.
Like what the [__] are you talking about? How are
you not safe? At what point he like what? Anyway, and then the
only reason the audio of tonight even came out with the other
stuff and the only reason that came out is because he asked me
to play it. I did not talk about it until he asked me to play
it. though.
>> that's it. We're not actually >> right. They They
actually went super Dude, I I do wonder about that. They went
super hard. I wonder if it's all just the um
cuz Yeah, I saw Doobie got kicked. Queen got kicked. Psycho got
kicked.
I I wonder why they would just clear out all the That just seems
a little weird to me.
Especially if Queen not sending any messages. Why is Queen just
getting kicked out with like no talk at all? Sorry. This actually
seems like isn't this totally against the principles Pisco stands
for,
right?
Like Pisco stands up for immigrants
who don't get fair representation in the country, okay, in America.
Why wouldn't he s stand up for one small lad and one extremely
skinny Swedish woman? What the what the guys?
Pisco was being told he was being influenced and probably took
it that to heart. I mean, maybe the DG narrative is purge snarkers
right now.
It's not even like, oh man, maybe he only burns spicy chat. Dubbie
is not a part of spicy chat. Also, I'm perfectly happy for Dubbie
to be in my community. Okay, I watched Dubbie throw down like
150 bucks in super chats to Piscll in one night. Doobie, you're
welcome here any day. Okay, any day, Doobie, you're welcome.
We love you here. You can come over here. If Pisco wants to dodge
all the guilt by association charges, then it'll be interesting
how far he goes. Well, that's the thing is when you when you
start letting people push you with the guilt by association thing,
that doesn't end, right? There will always be a new person who
has like a valid criticism who will just get webbed into whatever
that was and they'll be gone too.
So, like you have to be you have to be discerning with how you
deal with that, right? You can't just say, "Oh, I'm going to
get rid of all of these people." You you got to you got to cut
that off somewhere. #free doobie. Oh, sweatpants freedom. I've
seen you in in Pisco's Discord quite a bit. Yeah, I wonder what
happened to Doobie. I would I would love to know. I might I might
message Auntie and just go look. I It's It's not like a big deal
either way. I would just be interested
>> I'm not done. I'm not done. I'm not done. Does the audio
prove anything? I mean, it sounds kind of crazy, but anyway.
Um I guess
I guess look you talking over me. >> She's not insinuating
anything. She's not. She's not. She's saying everything blunt.
She's saying everything blunt. Just let her go. Just let her
go. should let it go. >> I mean, the audio does sound crazy,
but I'm not insinuating anything cuz I'm not using it for anything.
I have >> nothing happened, right? >> Why is he talking?
>> Look at him. >> I'm just asking some Yeah, let's
just let's just let her speak and then it'll be fine, Shy. Trust
me, she'll respond to anything. >> So, anyways, he wouldn't
even have this question if he wasn't baiting me to share audio
to show proof after he made claims against me and I said we mutually
did things to each other that might kind of seem, you know, crazy.
He's like, "You don't have proof I did that. You don't have proof."
And instead I have obviously I don't even just I have multiple.
So like I said I showed one I've showed this I showed that I
keep showing he just wants me to keep showing stuff and showing
DB got osted because there's a mod that doesn't like him. So
I saw DJ just legit argue that Pisco is getting mind controlled
by snarkers because Pisco is in his Discord in stream chat.
You mean Doobie or Quean or I'm not fit to do this. Pisco is
far more fit to do this. I like politics, but I also like drama.
And I'm like I Man, I I'd probably need more time streaming to
do something like that. That's uh that's not something I'm going
to look to do. We go our own way. All right. Oh, wait. Who are
you talking about here? BB Poison. Hold on. I got to pull this
up. I'm just more interested. I'm kind of interested in this.
I just uh I Man, I I understand the not wanting to be a part
of a tug-of-war or some proxy war. I do get that, right? I do
get that. Yeah, MC boots. That's fair. You saw the conspiracy.
Well, we didn't cover any of that [__] We didn't
cover any of Destiny's totally skitso meltdown. I just I feel
like um I don't know. I'd just be like kind of shocked if that's
that's the line they're taking. Not for any particular reason.
It just um like the thing I like about Pisco
and it might not just go into um it might not go down to his
mods. His mods might just be like honestly I would more expect
him to just really not pay attention to his mods at all. Right.
I would expect him not to pay attention at all. Just do whatever
with the mod. mods will handle stuff and them making these decisions.
I just feel like, you know, the thing, the reason I like Pisco
is he's just going to come to his own determinations.
And I feel like if it's just people going, "Oh, look, look at
these like vague associations with no no proof at all and then
people get banned from that that I'm like, yeah, that's weird.
That's really weird." Like Destiny has not proved anything about
Queen or me or anybody and he's just like making wild allegations
and apparently that's like bearing fruit for him in another community.
That would be very frustrating to me. See you, Kuryoko. Have
a good one, buddy. >> He wants this as content. I think
I gave enough. You can do and say whatever you want. If you want
to go do legal stuff and say I held you hostage, by all means,
maybe. Yeah, get a lawyer and do stuff that you have to do. Just
know I'm obviously going to defend myself, lawyer up with either
Jerry or Robert and maybe get a different one. Who knows? But
yeah, I'll take care of what I need to take care of, too. And
just, you know, best of luck to both of us. >> But that's
not the route she wants to go, Shiv. She's just saying she's
ready to defend herself at any moment. And I'm sure you're in
the same mindset, but both of you would would probably equally
not want to do any of that. You guys would just want to be amate.
Yeah. No. No hate, no legal, no law, no,
oh, you kidnapped me. You blocked my way out of the door. Whatever
the Let's just get rid of all that and just chalk it up to a,
you know, a turbulent relationship that's coming to an end. Boom.
>> I mean, I'd be willing to do that, but I feel that she's
trying to insinuate
>> She's not. You're the one creating
>> Let me make this very clear. Thank you, Anthony. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. That's all I wanted to make clear.
I never once even in my Discord earlier, I I literally said he
never hurt me or D like I made that very very clear because my
intention is not to make this legal or or put him in jail or
any of that. I genuinely my feelings were honest. Everything
I said in the relationship situationship, whatever the ship,
whatever fling thing where we were both saying I love you, I
meant the stuff I was saying. I genuinely did catch feelings
for this person. So, I don't while I'm done and I'm like seeing
everything for it is just like he is. I think I'm at a mutual
stance to be like, "Yeah, this is definitely not for me, which
I concluded from the beginning." And I'm pretty sure he figured
that out too, like he said. Um, but that doesn't mean I hate
this person. It doesn't mean I need to have revenge on this person.
The only reason I've said anything is because he is speaking
about me and this is not the first time he spoke about me and
I stayed quiet. He spoke about me like three or four other times
and I stayed very quiet which you know I never leaked anything
until today. So yes, I only leaked to clear things the up for
my goddamn self and that's it. >> And so moving forward,
you could probably both agree to to like maybe rest this here,
right? And then you can stop leaking.
He just >> He just mentioned uh I don't have to get revenge.
So, are you insinuating that you will get revenge? I don't >> dude.
No, she's saying that it's not in her interest. You're trying
to solve
>> Not everything can be solved. >> You said I needed
revenge. I said I don't need to get revenge. What are you >> You're
you're on some like >> It's like you're showing out that
it's a possibility and I'm just wondering why would you >> Anthony
she brought up
so so to say that she did not actively saying no wait she's actively
saying that she that none of that happened so it doesn't matter
what you think is >> you get her to say that that didn't
>> when he joined this call he said that I touched his
dick without his consent who brought it up you brought that up
I never did you did your opening statement was about >> said
that never happened I'm just wondering can you confirm that with
her >> do you hear him Anthony he brought up and everything
is he serious and then he's talking about revenge. I said, "I
don't need revenge."
>> So, even if you feel as though she's implying something,
but she's not actually saying it, right? It's possible that you
you that you would just you have a the wrong implication, right?
You just have the wrong implication. If she's saying the opposite,
>> oh, I absolutely do not. >> But she's not I haven't
heard her say anything at all about those things. Maybe I'm just
high, but >> Juvie is not the smartest guy.
>> Elmo compromised. Dude, I didn't >> The only thing
In this exact moment, wait. In this exact moment, are you able
to consite cuz this is getting jumbled up. Are you able to say
that that recording and things that have happened between you
guys were consensual and complicated, not anything more than
that? Is it possible for you both to just say that? Cuz if you
could both just say that and let go of the ego, then it's over.
>> Sexual Anthony, remember I asked him if it was salt
when I was touching on his and stuff. >> I remember. I
remember. And he decided to take that route. I know. But if but
if I mean per me personally I just ignore all this noise and
keep doing what I'm doing if I'm Pisco. But I'm sure it's annoying
to have DG and also every other force that DG is at war with
trying to pull you one direction or the other. Well, sure, but
I just feel like if you're only going to mod one side of that,
it it gets a little awkward, right? It just gets a it's a little
awkward. But it's fine. We're uh I I just have faith, okay? We're
in the right. We will win. Our cause is a righteous one. Inshallah,
brothers. Okay. Inshah,
we will be victorious. We will be victorious. >> He could
just say our cause is righteous. Then you would also say that
is not. And then there would never there wouldn't be an issue,
right? You you guys could just move the on >> cuz there
was no there's probably nothing actually serious here. It's just
a complicated back and forth with the toxic relationship between
two streamers. Like it doesn't need to go further than that.
Like yes, you guys are capable of making each other seem crazy
and you are both a little crazy, so it's kind of easy to make
each other crazy uh seem crazy. I get it. But let's just not
do that and move on and be >> Are you comparing me to >> Trump
is president right now? But far more concerning Ozel is the fact
that Hassan [__] has 50,000 concurrent viewers. 40,000
30,000 concurrent viewers. Okay. Far more disturbing than the
fact that Donald Trump is the president. Is the fact that Hassan
[__] himself has 30,000 viewers. Okay. How could
we possibly allow Destiny to lose his lawsuit or face any consequences
for his actions when Hassan [__] has five times his
viewership?
That is crazy. That is crazy. >> Zena the witch. >> No,
I'm saying that it's easy to make anybody look crazy that's a
streamer, >> You're supposed to be crazy, dude. >> It's
easy to make any I could look crazy, too. I'm I'm hot. I'm red.
I've been sitting here for four hours listening to this. I'm
insane. Everybody in the chat is crazy as Okay, we're all crazy.
Shuy, it is what it is. But just let's let's not let it escalate
because of like implication potentials and oh, I'm afraid of
this maybe happening and and like a paranoia thing. Let's just
bring it all back down. Bring it back down to base level and
just
call it a complicated ending relationship and that's it. We've
all had them, >> we've all had them. >> That's what
I thought it could be like even still like so that I could just,
you know, it should be we break up. I'm sad. I'm crying. I'm
pretty sad about it for a couple of days.
>> I used to think Pisco obviously reads the court documents,
but now I think he avoids it. >> Wait, the Pixie ones.
I don't think he read I don't think he keeps up on that case.
I don't know why he keep up on that case.
What is this real one? Yeah, I saw Deon Nash on the I saw I saw
like the clips. I didn't actually watch it yet. I kind of want
to watch it, but think we're going to run out of time on the
stream tonight. People wanted the Darius, sorry, the Shuyena
content. It is what it is. It's not up to par with It's not up
to snuff with the Xenadarius content. Okay, it's not the same.
It's not as good,
but it's not bad. It's not the >> days. And like, okay,
there's nothing really talked about it cuz nothing was supposed
to even be public. And eventually it would just stop and then
yeah, people just go about their lives and that's just >> and
that's still possible. It's still totally possible. We can still
do that. >> He felt like he needed to say things like say
I manipulated him and stuff like that. So, of course, I'm going
to counter with how he also was doing things to me. I only spoke
up when he was speaking on me but not being honest about the
things that was really going on like what we had going on with
each other the intimately whatever whatever
>> do you want to get back together >> no Sean
>> okay good just making sure >> shut the up you
dumb because you say that you talk like that whenever I say something
about if I even express things aren't working or um he's doing
something wrong I guess that means you don't really love me subs
Sounds like you're trying to get rid of me, huh? So, you don't
want to have my kids no more? So, you don't love me no more?
Damn, you really don't want to be my wife no more. Like, some
of that recording you showed and had turned down. Like, you know
how you talk, bro. You know what you're talking and this is why
we're not
>> And this is why the relationship didn't end up working.
And that's okay. That's okay cuz your communication styles are
different.
Communication and >> I know it's D10's stream, but it's
like it's not like somebody will see that and go, "Oh, I need
to give subs to D10." It's like they're watching it on your stream.
I'd be like, "Yeah, give subs to me." Obviously, >> age
difference. >> Yeah, it's just different communication
styles and it's okay. That's all. Complicated for sure. Stressful
for sure,
but you know, everything it can be and will be okay moving forward
100%. >> I got I got played. He got He got pegged. It's
about gold. >> And you guys should just start memeing.
Look, Shy, just start memeing and just get over it. >> I
got I got played. He got He got pegged. That's just it. That's
the end.
>> But the thing is, you're just making this up. So, like,
I don't understand.
>> Pause. I don't You know, I can't
>> But, you know, I can't revenge.
>> Either of us can revenge because the Here's here's the
only way you win. >> No, D10. D10 does. D10's got uh
he's got no aura. D10's got negative aura. He won't hit. I'm
sorry. Zena don't respect no broke bum ass. N-word ninja. Okay.
She she D10's got no aura. He's not gonna hit. It's not possible.
>> Consent to prove that you peg me. >> I don't think
I don't think Zena give out like pity. Okay. I just don't think
I don't think that's the case. Go ahead. >> No, I can I
cannot show um videos. I cannot show that stuff on the internet.
>> Wait, you were just going to that you can't cuz you
don't have consent. But I give you full consent to show this
alleged video that you have a peg me. Go ahead, do it right now.
Post it right >> Did you have Wait, did I have consent
to record? Wait. Oh,
that's a
gigachad move,
right? That's a Oh, yeah, sure, Ginger. That's entirely possible.
I don't think I'm saying with Zena, he's got no shot. I'm sure
with He's not like an ugly guy. I just I'm I'm com I'm commenting
on Aura only. Okay, Aura only.
That was a confident move from Shuy right there. You got a video
of me getting in the ass? Post it. Post it. I consent. I consent.
You got a video of me getting in the ass? Post it now.
That's the strongest move Shu's made all night. That's the first
time I've actually been like, "Okay, actually,
bro, that would be crazy if he called her bluff on that and lost.
That would be like the end of your internet career. You want
to call the bluff on that one?" I respect your only chance to
make money with their consent to record it. Actually, I forgot
you did. Wait, I you you're right. You actually did sign You
actually did sign a waiver. Why you talking over me? Why you
talking over me? You actually did sign only Why you talking over
me? for video.
>> That's I thought that was my raid. I came back to check
it. >> Wait, we're both farming each other right now. >> He's
talking over me. Mute him real quick. Anthony, can you mute him?
>> Yeah, shoot me. Just wait. Just wait. Just wait. >> He
actually did sign a waiver to be on my Only Fans. I forgot. I
actually have the waiver right here. Let me pull it up real quick
for myself cuz he actually did sign it. >> Look. So, you
see Shuy when you're >> Oh, never mind. He said he did.
I don't even got to pull it up. He said he did. When you're trying
to get her to to step on a on a
trap mine, that's whenever she starts to think, "Okay, now I
got to get in defense mode and talk about doing this and legal
and lawyers and Jeffrey and Ronald or whatever the fuck." Stop
trying to bait her into making a legal claim or some just get
over it. >> Yo. Yo, am I right? >> Okay. Uh, I'm
actually fully I'm fully confident that Shu's booty virginity
remains intact. Okay. At least from Zeta I think I think he said
if you got a video she's like you want me to post a video you
know I got the video and he's like you got a video of me getting
in the post it right now and she's like why I look I got a waiver
you signed to be on my only fans she changes it entirely right
she changes it entirely
it's
>> you're right you're right let him let him cover himself
and let him say >> am I unmuted Anthony >> yeah yeah
>> bro this is why I'm saying respectfully I believe that
you may be compromised cuz I think you're believing everything
that comes out of her mouth. If she makes a claim, I will defend
myself. Why would I? You just got to lay down arms and then she
wants to try to say that she did something to me to try to get
one over on me. We cannot be I don't know why you're embarrassed
by that. >> You don't have to be cool. You don't have to
be cool, but you can you can let bygones be bygones. You can
you can let everything cuz as it is, everything is not a big
deal at this moment. You could just This is It's just a night.
It's one night, bro. So, we could all move forward from this.
Look at the straps and the toys and stuff he bought me. The straps
on the bed and everything. This bed he was sleeping on. I mean,
I got pictures of him sleeping on his bed with the straps on
it. >> I'm not Look, I'm not compromised or whatever the
you said. I uh I'm just trying to search for a peaceful resolution
that has a mutual benefit to everybody in attendance.
>> The thing is, >> bro, you can show the strap on.
It doesn't mean that that went in his booty hole. Okay, this
is not okay. If the butt if the butt plug does not fit, you must
acquit. And I do not believe it will fit in this case. I believe
Shuy's booty hole remains mostly non-spoiled. Okay. Mostly undesoiled.
>> He has a lot of pride and stubbornness,
>> And you don't got to worry about that stuff anymore.
You got to worry about that anymore. >> Same as me. >> Yeah,
I know. I know. And if you guys just do your own things independently,
like get back on the boat,
>> get squeezed back, go do something else. Just do your
own [__] bro. you're good on your own. She's doing
her. Let's just have that happening instead of these back and
forths because the back and forth clearly end up in some really
heated territory with each other, right? That's why we broke
up. >> I think we might we might have to do this with another
moderator because I think this is viol. >> It's Dude, I'm
trying to just resolve the problem. >> Saying that some
of the [__] you're saying is stupid. >> Like
he's not agreeing with me either. He said some of what I said
was [__] >> I agree that there's no resolving.
That's why That's why the decision needs to be to walk away.
>> Hold on. I'm genuinely not even trying to come for you,
chat. Do you believe that this is a biased debate? Yes or no?
I mean, honestly, I mean, you could say no. You could say yes.
I really I'm honestly curious. Yes or no? Bias, yes or no? >> But
bias what? What is >> bias in any way? It could be bias
on my side, bias on her side, any >> I mean, that's the
one of the biggest open-ended questions I've ever heard in my
life. Of course, everybody's bias. Everybody has self- inentions
and and they're trying to protect themselves. >> Okay.
Oh yeah. >> Okay. I don't think guys, we'll see here. What
do we got on the on the docket here? We got what? 30 bucks. We're
We're nine subs away from another hour on the stream. I don't
know if we're going to get there. We're going to finish this
content.
I think we're going to have to leave the Destiny skitso [__]
for tomorrow. Okay. I think that's what we're doing. We're leaving
it for tomorrow. As far as I know. As far as I can tell.
>> Otherwise, you guys you guys could donate. We are nine
subs. $45 away for another hour on the stream. >> Up to
you guys. Let me ask a more direct question, chat. Do you believe
that Anthony is biased in this situation? Either toward me or
towards you. It could be anyone. >> I'm biased towards
you guys not calling the cops on each other and and putting this
to rest. That's what I'm biased to. And you just want it to be
this big eruption of chaos that you just need to deal with. Dude,
walk away. >> And I'm really I'm not even trying to come
for you. I'm just That's just how I I feel a little bit
>> homie. I've been sitting here since I met you telling
you to not do this with
Oh. Oh. Oh. Gentle whale with the 10 gifted. Oh my god. That
puts us up to what is that? 16 subs. That is 30, 50, $80. $80
out of the 75. We will go for another hour on the stream. Oh
my
Reset the goal. We will reset from scratch as well. All right.
Me reset my subs here. We are good to go. Uh, actually, hold
on. I should set this in the goal. One second. >> Maybe
you're not. Maybe you're not.
>> But I have a question. >> Okay, Anthony. Maybe
you're not. You're not fully.
>> Maybe you're right. Maybe you're right about that. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Maybe you're right about that. For sure. >> But I
actually have a question.
>> Even if Anthony agreed with Shuy or agreed with me,
why the does him agreeing with anything negate anything that
was actually discussed?
>> I didn't say I was definitely going to do the dest.
There's going to be so much of it, right? I think it went so
long from the first day that I might need more than one stream
to go through it, right? And all the he says, like him just going
through the Discord parts and stuff. We will see. We will see.
We will >> I just realized maybe >> the only thing
that matters is what was actually shown >> cuz we could
do we could totally also do Fuentes. It depends on if Gentle
Whale feels like I am baiting him. Do you feel like I baited
you with the Destiny skitso? Cuz we could also do the Warren
Smith Nick Fuentes content. But if Gentle Whale feels like I
baited him and said I'd do the Destiny stuff, then maybe. Kathy,
nobody cares. Kathy, nobody cares. Kathy, nobody cares. Kathy,
shut the [__] up. Nobody cares. >> No, it doesn't
matter what his opinion >> I think maybe he's not exactly
I think maybe he's not exactly says do whatever you want. >> I
think maybe he just doesn't fully understand the grasp of this
situation and maybe all the lore in history. He thinks that maybe
it's easy for us to just put it aside and the fact that I want
to keep going. I may be in the wrong for that. I think that's
what might be the situation. >> And you're absolutely right
because I just came into this today. It's been like a multi-day
thing. >> By all means, like I said, I I implore it and
encourage it just like I told Benny when I told Benny Mac, I
was like, "You should have called the cops." Like, >> but
let's let's implore and encourage
>> stand on your
opposite. >> Stand on your [__] [__]
as a man and do it. If you need to take legal proceedings, do
it. I will also do what I need to do for me. I'm not making claims
here and right now. I will defend myself when need be. If you
>> I do not think
that we're going to do the pisco stuff. If that's what you're
here for, Bruce Willis, I don't think we're going to do Timool
Pisco. >> You want to go and do legal stuff? By all means,
>> that's fine. You have every right to do.
>> You're the one throwing that out there. And I'm saying
do what you need to do. As far as like what Anthony said, yeah,
I agreed with Anthony. I personally don't want to go make accusations
and claims and threaten to call the cops or this that and the
third like whatever whatever poison if you're here give a >> Um
I did give a about some things
I'm not done. >> I don't give a about you anymore. I give
a about the truth and the fact that there was secrets and stop
>> stop talking
you tell me to stop talking but you interrupt everything. >> If
you guys give each other the consideration then it'll start momentum.
the whole time he was talking. >> Yeah. Yeah. Just go.
Just go. You're >> You constantly >> just let her
talk. Let her talk. It's fine. If you give her the respect, she'll
give you the respect. It's a It's a back and forth and then you
can give it and she'll give it and you can give. >> I'm
constantly interrupting. You interrupted me. You interrupted
videos even playing. Anyways, you're the one that wants Here
you go again. >> Go ahead. Just keep talking. Go. >> At
the end of the day, I don't give a what you have to say. I left
you. You're mad. You're faulty. You want to come for me. You
want to attack me. You want to accuse me and allegationate me.
I don't give a You're a washed up hoe and I'm good and I'm good
off you and I'm glad I escaped. I didn't dodge a bullet. I dodged
a nuke. Anyways, thank >> Jesus for interviewing me, Anthony.
I'm out of this. >> Thank you. >> Amen. Amen, brother.
>> Anyways, I guess I came for him. Um, I came for him.
I threw allegations because I mentioned the fact that he got
a strap on, bought me the strap on, bought me the toys, and let
me peg him in the ass. So, and that's why he's mad and started
talking about legal stuff. I never did. I don't care about the
legal stuff. Yes, like I said, I guess. Yeah, I got I got played.
He got He got pegged. Simple as that. He dodged a nuke. Cool.
Um, he kept coming back.
If he wants to keep leaking stuff, I will continue to leak the
same stuff. Like I said, like in that video, he didn't think
I had. >> Or the opposite, right? Or if he's willing to
not do things, then you're you're willing to not do things. >> So,
I played the video. >> We got anything else from Zena here.
Zena is basically >> thing with the legal stuff. He was
>> I may have found Okay, somebody may have sent me
the Kathy video. Okay. The Kathy Avi video. I don't remember
exactly. I don't know how it started. I don't know where they
were arguing. Let me see what's happened in a queen and VC. Maybe
they started arguing there from Avi.
What is Avi saying in here?
Oh, Avi joined up. He says, "I've heard there have been some
claims about my
Interesting. Let me let me get this for you guys. So, Avi joined
Avi joined Queen's Discord. He rolls in, says, "Hey guys, I heard
there have been some claims about my practice.
I don't know if we have the whole call cuz it started." Okay,
it started kind of disjointed,
but I may have. All right, this is the same guy that Destiny
has been going back and forth with who's been posting messages
in my Discord.
now if you want a good idea of how serious a debater this guy
is, I believe personally from what I heard that he kind of just
totally rolled Avi in a debate on A's, you know, medical practices
and his possible discrimination against Arabs. This is the person
that Destiny wants to take very seriously in my Discord. By the
way, I just want to make it clear to you guys. This is the guy.
This is the very threatening guy. Okay, it's the very scary guy.
Let's see. I don't I don't think we're going to have this from
the beginning for some reason, but let me let me check it out.
What do we got here?
Open it up. We're going to see what we got here. >> Said
you
they only said you don't read
>> Hold on. Is this I need to one second. I need to see
I just need to check one other thing really quickly. Hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on, guys. We're going to We're going to
make it, but just give me a second. Okay, give me a second. I
think I think the other one's longer. Hold on. I think the other
Yeah, the other one's longer. Okay. No, not Muslims. They only
said you. >> All right, I'm going to restart this. This
is Kosher Kathy, the gossipy woman that Destiny referred to in
my stream. Okay, the gossipy woman. Hold on. Can I
Can I find that quote? This is the gossipy woman that Destiny
was seething about in Discord logs.
>> Yeah, people were saying that that >> No, not
Muslims. They only said you don't read Arab patients. >> Okay.
No, I see. For some reason, somebody put the queen in normal
like transition overlay here. I'm going to I'm going to play
this, but I don't know where this came from. >> Who Who
said that? >> I heard somewhere. I don't remember, but
that's not something I just heard. I heard it maybe over a year
ago. >> Over a year ago.
>> Okay. Well,
I don't know if you ever know who's told you that, let me know.
But that's never been true. That it's again, it's not true. That's
never been true. And it never will be true. >> Okay. But
let me ask you a question.
>> is it related to that claim? I think it's related to
that claim. >> Yes. Yes. That claim. Let's say that. >> Oh,
uh, somebody didn't turn their Discord notifications off. That's
>> Uh, a criminal comes in front of the prosecution and
they tell him, "Oh, did they do that crime?" What do you think
they would say? They would say, "No, right?" Well, the judge
then say, "Okay, you didn't do the crime. You are free to go."
Every criminal say no. It's >> What do you want me to Wait,
what do you want? What do you want me to What do you want me
to to say? Do you want me to like prove You want me to like violate
HIPPA and prove to you that I've treated Muslim patients in the
past? Like what what's the >> No, no, no. I'm just saying
I can't send my my uh I have Arab Where do you practice if you
don't mind? >> I I don't Okay. Do you want to do you want
to know something hilarious and how stupid this claim is?
>> You know, I don't I don't currently treat any patients.
I'm a dermatopathologist. I I diagnose slides. I don't treat
patients. I don't treat white patients. I don't treat anything.
>> This is interesting because we just got a screenshot
from uh >> Oh, this is interesting because we just have
a screenshot of
he said in that screenshot you >> when I did. >> I'm
sorry, but this this debate is instruction is instructional
is it it helps us understand the mind of Kathy, okay? Okay. And
where he's coming from in that he's a total troll. I don't I
don't vow anything Kathy said any of the things Kathy says. But
I would say if you take Kathy seriously, if you're willing to
take Kathy seriously, there's something wrong with you. Is he
playing up the accent or is it legit? I'm positive that this
is a white dude. I am
screenshot sorry text. He had a call with you and in the code
he said I did treat a lot of Arab patient. Did you treat a lot?
>> I have
now
please now say I never treat any >> No, that's not what
I said. No, no, that's not what I said. Just to be just to be
clear, I have treated patients because I was a I'm also a dermatologist.
And so when I was practicing dermatology, I treated every patient.
When I practice dermatopathology like I'm doing now, I treat
no patients. And so I've been practicing germatopathology right
now and so now I don't treat any patients but when I did treat
patients I have always treated every patient and I don't even
know if it would be even be legal for me to not treat patients
under >> that's why we are concerned but let me let me
say so you are saying that you stopped treating patients after
you had a patients come
it's because I no because I I specialized in dermatopathology
which is a field where it's just purely diagnostic. You don't
actually treat >> Okay. But but you said you treated patient
in the past. >> Yes. Because I when I was when I was
>> right after you treated them, you
>> No, not right after I treated them.
>> Then the timeline doesn't make sense. >> What
doesn't make sense about it? I It's when I specialize them and
then you say, "Oh, after I treat them, I stop treating." No,
>> no, that's not No, it's not because it's it's also Yeah,
it's also after I stopped treating It's also after I stopped
treating after I treated patients. Like if you want to get technical,
but it's not because of it. It's because I specialized in another
field. That's all. >> Yeah. Just But just because you stop
treating patient doesn't mean you are antiatic. Correct. >> Right.
And just because I just because I stopped treated treating Arab
patients or any patients doesn't mean I hate >> So you
treat stopped treating Arab >> I stopped treating all patients.
with it. You said, >> "Dude,
I think I joined at this point." And when he when he pulls this
on him
>> just because I stopped treating Arab. >> This
is bad. This is >> Everyone here can >> Okay, just
to be clear, just to be clear, when I say I stopped I I stopped
I did not say I stopped treating Arab patient. I said I stopped
treating all patients. You're I said I stopped treating all patients.
>> Oh, no. You said when I stopped treating Arab doesn't
make me anti something like this. So, you did stop? >> Yes.
No, I said yes. When I stopped treating all patients, it doesn't
make me anti-Arab. That's correct. >> I didn't stop treating
at no point did I stop treating Arab patients >> Why didn't
you just say that? >> I didn't. >> Okay. He technically
did, but that's cuz Kathy baited him, right? Kathy says, "Well,
just because you don't treat patients doesn't mean you're not
doesn't mean you're anti-Semitic, right?" And he's like, "Yeah,
and you know, if I treat if I stopped treating Arab patients,
I think he said, and then if I stopped treating Arab patients,
that would make me anti-Arab." And Cathy goes, "So, you did stop
you did you did stop treating them?" >> Okay. I wish. I
don't know. We I'm not recording. I hope I was because I heard
you say that. >> Yeah. I hope so, too. Just to be clear,
>> I hope somebody was cuz I heard you say that. Let's
go. >> Treating Arab patients or any patients doesn't mean
I hate anyone. >> So, you hit >> Right. And just
because I just because I stopped treated treating Arab patients
or any patients doesn't mean I hate
>> Listen, we clip ship it there. That don't sound so good
for Avi. Okay. >> All patients. You're I said I stopped
treating all patients. >> No, you said when I stopped treating
Arab patient doesn't make me anti-Arab. Something like this.
So you did stop >> No, I said yes. When I stopped treating
all patients, it doesn't make me anti-Arab. That's correct. >> I
didn't stop treating at no point did I stop treating Arab patients
>> Why did you just say that? >> I didn't.
>> Okay. I wish. I don't know. We I'm not recording. I
hope I was because I heard you say that. >> Yeah. I hope
so, too. Just to be clear,
I stopped treating all patients. >> Okay. Yeah,
doesn't mean you didn't treat patient in the bust. That was >> okay.
So when I was Okay. So So I'm here I'm here to deny the claim
that when I was treating patients,
I was not treating Arab or Muslim patients or just Arab patients
or whatever. I was I was treating them. I had no problem treating
them. They had no problem being treated by me. What the [__]
>> Okay. But I >> And by the way, if I went back
and just to be clear, if I ever went back to treating patients,
>> at what point does he realize he's being trolled? I
don't know if my memory is perfect. I do not believe by the time
he leaves he realizes he was being trolled. I don't I don't think
he realizes it ever. I think he leaves without realizing it.
>> I I would abs of course I would treat Arab patients.
>> Why would you target Arab patients? >> I wouldn't
Oh, this is so No, no. Target. No, >> I want to treat Arab
patients. >> No, you treat everyone.
>> Am I being trolled right now? I feel like I'm being
trouble. No. >> Okay. Okay. Never mind. He does realize
it. He >> You're coming in way too hot, right? I think
you're assuming he's trying to strike you or something, but I
think if you just listen to what he's saying. >> It really
seems that bad. Okay. Okay. Sure. So, just so I
>> Who was that? I can't remember. >> Something and
he interrupt interrupt all the time. So, maybe that's >> because
I don't have time cuz I I really just don't have time. Like,
I just want to be I'm just I just want to give my position clear.
I don't care. Listen, I'm not here. >> Was that Was that
Doobie? I was going to say I think it's Doobie, but I didn't
want Doobie to get in trouble for >> I just want to make
my position as clear as possible to you. If you don't get it,
it's fine. I'm not here to target anyone. I'm not like I treat
everyone the same. I'm here to treat everyone the same or not
treat everyone the same. If I treat patients, I'll treat everyone
equally. If I don't treat patients, I won't treat everyone equally.
That's all I'm interested in. >> Okay. Time will tell.
>> Okay. Time will tell. All right. Is that
>> Okay. Bye. >> Yeah. Kathy, thank you. Um >> Oh
my
god, dude. >> Kathy, were you recording that? Oh my god,
he's muted. >> Okay. Anyway, there eventually quite a few
people joined and it was uh it was just funny. Okay, it was just
funny. It's a little little bit of rousing of Avi. It's not Nobody
got hurt. It was just a funny time, funny little thing that happened.
Okay, but I will say that um that is the person that Destiny
takes incredibly seriously in the Discord. He's got to post this
guy's logs like every day.
Has Kathy broken character yet during any of his episodes? Yes.
Uh, is it during the It might be during the
VM one that he breaks character, right? He's definitely broken
character before. Uh,
what character? Yeah, he's broken character. He's definitely
broken character. He's also come in with like different accents
entirely before, I'm pretty sure. If I don't if I don't mis if
I'm not misremembering, I think he's had just totally different
accents